en tribune de presse pour ne rien rater
des débats bonsoir à vous Mathias alors
expliquez-nous comment ce sont tout vert
ces débats autour de l'article 7 et bien
Quentin comme depuis le début de ces
débats ici cet article 7 c'est ouvert
avec une motion de renvoi partielle en
commission une motion défendue par la
présidente du groupe communiste Eliane
assassy cette fois encore pas de
surprise Quentin la motion a été rejetée
et donc depuis et bien les prises de
parole préalables à l'étude du Premier
Amendement s'enchaînent alors avant la
suspension de 20h on a eu le droit à des
prises de parole des trois présidents
des groupes de gauche avec différents
angles d'attaque le socialiste Patrick
canard par exemple décidé de continuer
sur la dialectique du silence de la
droite dans l'hémicycle
mais où est la droite vous avez décidé
effectivement à ce stade de ne pas vous
prononcer j'en suis déçu mais n'ayez pas
la droite honteuse
défendez défendez vos opinions défendez
devant les Français ce qui vous semble
bon dans cette réforme un populaire
inutile injuste réactionnel la
communiste Eliana Sassy à elle rappelait
au ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
et au sénateur de la majorité le rejet
de cette réforme par une grande partie
des Français je rappelle que le 19
janvier il y avait 2 millions de
manifestants le 31 janvier 2,8 le 7 2
millions le 11 2,5 millions le 16 1,3
millions et c'était pendant les vacances
scolaires aujourd'hui et nous y est on
présente je me félicite d'un mouvement
social d'ampleur et rassembleurs ce sont
plus de 3,5 millions de manifestants
parmi lesquels des milliers de jeunes
qui ont défilé aujourd'hui autour d'un
mot d'ordre retrait de votre réforme
monsieur le ministre
le président du groupe écologiste
liseroy Guillaume Gontard à lui
souhaiter évoquer la question du monde
associatif et des pertes de bénévoles
que pourraient engendrées à report de
l'âge de départ en retraite
plusieurs associations ont déjà tiré la
sonnette d'alarme l'association Les
Petits Frères des Pauvres a expliqué il
y a quelques semaines que le report de
l'âge légal de départ la retraite à 64
ans suscité de vivienquétudes car 14%
des bénévoles réguliers et 15% des
nouveaux bénévoles de leur association
on entre 60 et 65 ans le rengagement
représente plus de 200000 heures de
bénévolats par an quand on sait
l'importance que les associations dans
notre société on peut se demander
pourquoi le gouvernement veut à tout
prix
ignorer les nombreux effets négatifs de
sa réforme voilà donc pour le résumé des
premières minutes d'échanges autour de
cet article 7 Mathias qu'est-ce qui nous
attend maintenant bien écoutez les
prises de parole se poursuivent derrière
une certaine façon d'ailleurs rajoutées
pendant la suspension ensuite dès
qu'elles seront terminées ces prises de
parole Quentin s'ouvrira le chapitre des
amendements alors un peu moins de 80
tout d'abord sont des amendements de
suppression de l'article à noter que
parmi ceux-ci un a été déposé par un
sénateur de concentriste il s'agit de
Jean-Michel Arnaud il a été consigné cet
amendement par 7 de ses collègues
centrices et puis commencera ensuite le
travail de l'usure la tactique de la
gauche depuis le début de ces débats à
Linéa par alinéa afin de s'attaquer à
cette mesure d'âge sur cet article 7
Quentin environ 1300 amendements ont été
déposés c'est le plus gros total tout
simplement depuis le début de l'examen
ici au Sénat voilà et donc on est dans
la 40e prise de parole sur les 48
introductives à l'article 7 c'est le
président qui préside cette séance et ce
jusqu'au bout de la nuit comme je vous
le disais direction
de ne plus déposer d'amendements sur les
retraites merci
Monsieur Patrick Joly
[Applaudissements]
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais
souligner les inégalités territoriales
supplémentaires
que va générer ce projet de loi et ce
report de l'âge de la retraite de deux
ans en effet les territoires ruraux
présentent des caractères particuliers
sur les métiers exercés métiers
particulièrement pénible et donc qui use
ce qui les pratiques le poids de
certains secteurs est nettement plus
élevé que la moyenne nationale sur ces
territoires je fais référence à
l'agriculture à la civiculture à la
transformation du bois au bâtiment aux
travaux publics au métier de l'industrie
notamment métallurgique car et oui les
territoires du Rhône sont des
territoires d'industrie historiquement
et présentement mais je pense également
aux métiers de service à la personne
aide ménagère aide-soignante infirmiers
liés à la part des personnes âgées au
sein des populations de ces territoires
les écarts d'espérance de vie entre les
territoires sont déjà importants deux
ans en moyenne au détribuant des
territoires ruraux et jusqu'à 4 ans dans
certains cas en particulier dans le
département que je représente les
raisons sont multiples niveau de revenus
accès difficile aux professionnels de
santé aux établissements de soins nous
sommes d'ailleurs payés en ce moment
pour le savoir avec la fermeture de
inacceptable en ce moment de la
maternité d'Autun fermeture contestée
par les élus et la population à cause
des risques qu'elle générait pour les
maires et pour les nourrissons des
écarts liés bien sûr au métier tels que
je viens de les évoquer et à leur
pénibilité si nous n'y ajoute les écarts
selon les catégories sociales jusqu'à
présent comme nous l'a rappelé à
l'instant notre collègue Emilienne
pomirol on mesure alors les inégalités
existantes déjà et pour lesquelles
aucune politique suffisante n'étant
n'est mise en œuvre pour les réduire
alors Monsieur le Ministre n'ajoutez pas
de l'injustice à l'injustice et retirer
ce à la fois cet article et ce projet de
loi je vous remercie madame Préville
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous les
femmes allons subir une régression de
nos droits sans précédent à cause de
votre réforme des retraites nos droits
nous les avons acquis difficilement nous
nous voyons pas à vrai dire le bout du
chemin vers l'égalité ce qui est
légitime
et c'est d'ailleurs à se demander
combien de milliers d'années il nous
faudra pour aboutir enfin à l'égalité
salariale et combien de temps il nous
faudra quémander justice c'est bien
d'une tristesse absolue et en plus le
peu que nous avions voulant levez les
trimestres légitimement pour les enfants
vous les supprimer sans vraiment le dire
et c'est parce que vos incantations à la
pédagogie sous prétexte de mieux faire
comprendre votre projet qu'enfin le
lièvre a été levé maintenant nous le
savons les femmes sont perdantes elles
sont les grandes perdantes de votre
projet de loi et c'est scandaleux
comment
osez-vous comment avez-vous osé laissez
croire le contraire preuve de
l'injustice fait aux femmes je vous en
donne une une femme dans le privé né
après 1967 début de carrière à 21 ans un
enfant sans réforme elle peut partir à
62 ans à taux plein
et elle peut bénéficier même d'une
surcote de 10% si elle va jusqu'à 64 ans
avec la réforme pas de départ à 62 ans
un départ obligatoire à 64 ans et elle
n'aura qu'une surcote de 5%. voilà la
preuve est faite la réalité la voix là
je vous donne également la parole d'une
manifestante dans mon département aesh
dans un collège qui devra travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans pour avoir 500 euros de
retraite on a dit et je l'incite on a
des trous dans nos carrières on a des
métiers précaires et mal payés et notre
statut n'est pas reconnu elle était dans
la rue aujourd'hui comme plus de 3
millions de Français le mauvais coût que
vous faites aux femmes ne m'inspire
qu'une seule chose impardonnable
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
je crois que nous avons tout ce que nous
ici un certain nombre de chefs de l'État
et des chefs de l'État qui confrontaient
à des mouvements d'opinion parfois bien
moins importants que ce I qui a lieu en
ce moment on s'y prend la bonne décision
c'est à dire retirer un projet je pense
à François Mitterrand en 1984 et ça ne
faisait pas plaisir
et il est resté 11 ans à l'Élysée
derrière sa vie politique ne s'est pas
arrêtée et n'a pas été condamné à
l'inaction je pense à Jacques Chirac
aussi et n'a pas plu c'était condamné à
l'inaction il y a une sagesse à écouter
le peuple et je dois dire que à ceux qui
prétendent que ce n'est pas la rue qui
gouverne ce n'est pas la rue qui fait la
loi c'est slogans éculé je réponds que
la démocratie parlementaire elle ne
s'affaiblit pas quand elle écoute le
peuple elle se renforce et elle se
renforce parce qu'elle montre qu'elle a
un lien direct avec le peuple qu'elle
écoute et si elle n'écoute pas si elle
ne répond pas à ce dialogue à ce lien et
bien ce sont les extrêmes qui en
profitent derrière et ce qui est en
train de se passer dans notre pays
m'inquiète je comprends que vous soyez
attaché à cette réforme vous l'avez
toujours porté je sais les valeurs
qu'elles réelles pour vous dans la
majorité sénatoriale je sais les
messages que vous voulez porter
politiquement
mais interrogez-vous vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui le lien que vous avez que
nous avons enfin vous en l'occurrence là
et menacé parce que c'est dans les
petites villes parce que c'est dans
toute la France que le mouvement est
puissant que ce soit la rue ou les
enquêtes d'opinion vous le voyez alors
je crois qu'il est il est temps de faire
prévaloir des intérêts qui dépassent ce
simple texte
renoncer ce n'est pas une honte
reprendre remettre l'ouvrage sur le
métier dans de meilleures conditions
c'est la garantie que la société entière
l'accepte il faut cesser digne viser
notre pays il est assez fragile il faut
le rassembler et retirer ce texte
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président sur le
ministre mes chers collègues malgré
l'opposition historique qui a eu lieu ce
mardi 7 mars malgré l'opposition de
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
malgré l'opposition de plus de 8
Français sur 10 vous vous obstinez à
vouloir aller au bout de cette réforme
injuste cet article 7 parler le
royaumement de l'âge légal de la
retraite et l'accélération de la hausse
et durée de cotisation impose une double
peine pour ceux ayant commencé à
travailler tôt où il y a eu des
carrières hachées ou pénibles cet
article 7 concentre le cœur des
injustices de cette loi c'est une mesure
brutale et disproportionnée par rapport
aux prévisions de déficit du système de
retraite ce report de l'âge légal nous
est présenté comme un horizon
indépassable alors qu'il résute il
résulte bien d'un choix idéologique
promu par la droite malgré cette
opposition d'une majorité de nos
concitoyens là un vrai la réalité la
vérité c'est que le système de retraite
n'est pas structurellement en danger il
n'y a pas de menace de déficit
insurmontable
lui-même juge dans son rapport qu'il n'y
a pas de dynamique non contrôlée des
dépenses de retraite il parle de
territoires maîtrisés jusqu'en 2070 mais
sans doute voyez-vous plus loin vous qui
n'avez pas vu venir le réchauffement
climatique vous souhaitez réquilibrer
financièrement un système de retraite
que vous estimez à la dérive et bien
nous vous avons donné de nombreuses
pistes taxées davantage pension de
retraite les plus élevées augmenter le
taux d'emploi des seniors et donner à
chacun une garantie d'emploi dans des
métiers utiles à la société mais
n'imposait pas cette réforme contre la
vie de toutes les organisations
syndicales contre la grande majorité des
Françaises et des Français si vous
choisissez de poursuivre dans cette voie
vous causeriez un tort considérable à
notre pays retirer cette réforme tant
qu'il en est encore temps merci
[Applaudissements]
le président monsieur le ministre Aya de
Dream j'ai eu un rêve
celui du vrai loi travail une loi du 21e
siècle une oie qui tienne côte des
énormes modifications de l'organisation
du travail que vivent nos sociétés une
loi qui fasse ruisseler les gains de
productivité de mécanisation de la
robotisation sur les travailleurs et les
travailleurs et pas uniquement pour
aborder les profits des grands capitaux
celui d'un gouvernement monsieur le
ministre qui gouverne c'est-à-dire qu'il
prévoit qui co-éabore avec les citoyens
avec les travailleurs avec les
parlementaires avec les syndicats au
lieu de cela cette loi de calcul
comptable de fin de siècles et bâti sur
des présupposés qui ne sont plus
réalisés aujourd'hui dans nos sociétés
industrielles au lieu de cela le
gouvernement s'apprête mais dans la main
avec la majorité de droite et centrices
du Sénat à porter atteinte au droit à la
retraite de millions de nos concitoyens
et à notre système de retraite par
répartition
un projet de loi qui contrairement aux
annonces de l'exécutif ne permettra pas
d'équilibrer financièrement le système
vous commencez à le dire de préserver le
système par répartition on a vu les
amendements sur le système du
capitalisation ni de garantir une traite
minimum de 1200 euros par mois ça vous
avez dû l'avouer on repoussant de deux
ans la joueur des droits à la retraite
le but de cet article n'est ni plus ni
moins que de faire peser l'équilibre du
système de retraite sur le dos des
travailleurs et des travailleurs plutôt
que sur le capital ne parvenant pas à
défendre son projet le Gouvernement a
souhaité museler et tronquer le débat
par le recours à un texte de financement
avec le PLF RSS
après les alertes du Conseil d'État dans
un avis resté fantôme et du président
constitutionnel nous demandons qu'avec
notre groupe le retrait de ce projet de
loi et le vrai débat des négociations
avec la terre syndicale monsieur
thérouche
le président monsieur le ministre ce
soir tous ensemble sur ces bancs nous
sommes les voies les interprètes de
toutes ces voix qui se sont réunies
nombreux par centaines de milliers par
millions cet après-midi alors au moins
cette réforme aura eu un avantage de
révéler un bloc de gauche et un seul
bloc de droite dans cet assemblée
pourtant rien ne va dans cette réforme
on l'a dit et on vous le répète sans
cesse la procédure fixée un critère une
décision unilatérale du montant à
rembourser prendre le critère le plus
injuste celui des 64 ans avec des études
d'impact lacunaire avec une absence de
prise en compte des conséquences sur le
chômage sur les seniors et puis des
vérités alternatives comme celles des
1200 euros les Français ne veulent pas
de cette réforme et ils voulont dit haut
et fort une réforme à justifier parce
que ce n'est pas une question de déficit
c'est une question de manque de recettes
et puis on vous l'a dit et vous le redis
monsieur le ministre une réforme qui
fait des perdants les femmes les plus
faibles les carrières hachées
et
j'en viens à Monsieur le Ministre
à vous poser une question vous êtes
comme moi comme d'autres dans cette
hémicycle ce qu'on appelle un tranche un
transfuge de un transfuge de classe vous
avez eu une
trajectoire tout à fait particulière et
pourtant vous avez des origines modestes
vous avez été comme moi je crois
boursier qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
monsieur le ministre à quel moment
avez-vous oublié d'où vous venez comment
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
brutaliser ce que vous avez connu et qui
vous regarde monsieur le ministre que
vous est-il arrivé réveillez-vous
réveillez-vous monsieur le ministre et
souvenez-vous de celui que vous avez été
madame louero
merci monsieur le Président il y a d'un
côté les coûts cachés qui limitent
l'intérêt de reporter l'âge à 64 ans le
surcoût du report à 64 ans atteignait 8
milliards d'euros de coûts liés à
l'invalidité c'est le président national
de la Mutualité Française qui donne ce
chiffre c'est un risque supplémentaire
d'ouvrir et de renforcer la trappe à
pauvreté pour les seniors qui sont ni en
emploi ni à la retraite mais il n'est
absolument pas démontré que les seniors
coûterait globalement moins cher à la
société en restant plus longtemps sur le
marché du travail les jeunes retraités
de ma région Bretagne me témoignent de
leur rôle essentiel et leur
investissement dans des associations
caritatives culturelles sportives ou
dans la vie municipale nombreux sont
ceux qui se lèvent à 6h du matin pour
préparer les colis des Restos du coeur
ou pour récupérer le pain invendu dans
les boulangeries
ces Français préfèrent prendre leur
retraite certains Français préfèrent
prendre leur retraite et travailler
bénévolement pour une cause à laquelle
il croit et dont il mesure concrètement
l'intérêt plutôt que de continuer à
travailler ils sont là où le service
public a défaillance auprès des jeunes
pour l'accompagnement aux devoirs auprès
des familles pauvres des étrangers
délaissés de nos aînés isolées ils
interviennent dans les EHPAD pour
soutenir le personnel qui n'en peut plus
vous n'avez pas tenu compte de ces coûts
cachés avez-vous évalué la richesse
cachée qui est produite par ces jeunes
retraités qui sont inquiets du report
obligatoire de l'âge de la retraite avec
cette proposition de loi sur les
retraites ne risque-t-on pas de voir
s'écrouler tout un pan économique de la
société qui n'est pas analysé et qui
constitue des richesses cachées ces
retraites ces retraités s'inquiètent de
votre réforme ils étaient dans la rue
aujourd'hui pour défendre les droits de
leurs enfants ils vous demandent le
retrait de l'article 7 de la loi il veut
de il vous demande le retrait de la loi
monsieur merryou
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames et messieurs et chers
collègues
le rapport de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite constitue une
mesure antisociale et une grande
injustice en frappant avec les mains
avec une brique brutalité inouïe toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie toutes celles et tous
ceux qui se sont levés tôt vous attaquez
l'idée même du progrès et de la justice
sociale
vous imposez à toutes et à tous un impôt
sur la vie en bonne santé un impôt de
deux ans sur ce temps libre qui échoua
chacune et à chacun après une vie de
labeur
au nom d'un second pseudo pragmatisme
gestionnaire qui ne saurait dissimulé
une certaine soumission à la cupidité
des actionnaires vous sacrifiez lui-même
pour assurer les marchés en imposant
votre dogme libéral vos arguments sur le
ministre sont fallacieux le corps la
démontré les études et les contre
projets latent et pourtant vous vous
arc-boutez à une mesure profondément
juste et antisociale au nom d'une
urgence imaginaire qui menacerait le
système par répartition et ce n'est pas
faute d'avoir été sur nos bancs force de
proposition pour imaginer ensemble notre
avenir malgré beaucoup de mentons malgré
votre tsunami de communication vous qui
est occupez jusqu'à ne plus finir les
plateaux de télé des millions de
Français vous disent non ils ne sont pas
dupes vous baptisez progrès des reculs
sociaux vous appelez réforme juste un
impôt sur la vie à force de fascination
pour les destiné de conseils vous avez
perdu je le crains le sens du réel vous
ne mesurez plus le coût humain de vos
arbitrages vous n'avez pas parmi vos
statistiques celui de la désespérance
celui de la colère de ceux qui par de la
colère de ceux qui ne se sentent plus
entendu
monsieur Assouline
je crois que pour comprendre ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui et ce qui est
incompréhensible dans cette émission il
faut qu'ensemble on essaye de
retournez un peu en arrière dans cette
hémicycle un moment de tétanisation dans
le pays
qui a été la crise du covid
on n'avait jamais vu ça
et
on a vu un pays qui a tenu à travers ses
premiers de corvées c'était les
infirmières c'était les aides-soignants
c'était les salariés de la grande
distribution c'était tous ceux qui
continuaient à faire tourner le pays
et on s'est dit à ce moment-là
dans cet tétanisation qu'il y avait
peut-être un moment de grâce car de
droit ou de gauche tout le monde
regardez
ces gens là
avec une admiration et une
reconnaissance inouïe et nous les
applaudissions et on se disait ça pourra
pas être comme avant après ça
souvenez-vous
les salaires
derrière l'inflation aujourd'hui les
angoisses de la crise climatique
et puis pour eux c'est comme avant
empire
c'est-à-dire qu'on vient leur dire merci
on leur autant à eux ceux qui font les
métiers les plus pénibles et qui se
lèvent tôt le matin et qui ont tenu le
pays à ce moment-là qu'on va leur
prendre les deux meilleurs années de
leur retraite
et que s'ils veulent travailler plus
alors je le dis très franchement pour
mesurer l'ampleur du mouvement social
qui s'est exprimée dans la rue prenez en
compte tout ça et vous venez ajouter la
goutte d'eau qui peut faire déborder le
vase et ce mouvement ne va pas s'arrêter
là parce qu'il est profond oui mais il y
a un seul président
oui mais il fait respecter le temps s'il
vous plaît monsieur fichier monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues
il y a gêne de ce côté-ci de l'hémicycle
il y a gêne et elle est palpable à
travers votre mutisme il y a plusieurs
formes au silence j'en retiens 3 le
premier c'est je me tais parce que je
n'ai rien à dire le deuxième c'est je me
tais parce que je ne crois pas à ce que
je vais dire le troisième c'est je me
tais parce que je pourrais donner raison
à mes contradicteurs même sur les
réseaux sociaux le projet qui est censé
apaiser les gens et leur faire rêver à
une retraite agréable ne marche pas
alors service minimum et les
commentaires à ceux qui se risquent ce
les réseaux sociaux sont impitoyables
tout cela
s'illustre par une prise de position
d'une parlementaire de votre majorité ou
plutôt de la majorité de renaissance
dans mon département
elle dit en première page d'un grand
quotidien je vote parce que je ne peux
pas faire autrement
tout est dit
il vous reste à évaluer en quoi vous
allez améliorer l'avenir des Français à
travers votre projet de loi
et comme on n'a pas beaucoup de moyens
d'évaluer dans un temps immédiat on va
retenir les sénatoriales
les mers qui sont très proches de leur
population qu'ils entendent
régulièrement sont sensibles à leur
difficulté et à l'inertie de cette loi
et je pense très clairement qu'il vous
le diront très prochainement à tous les
candidats des sénatoriales de la droite
qu'il aura imposé un système de retraite
qui leur fait travailler deux années de
plus je vous remercions conclure Madame
Lubin
si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes en
direct sur Public Sénat et ce jusque
tard dans la nuit car les sénateurs
viennent d'entamer l'examen de l'article
7 sur le report de l'âge de départ à 64
ans et en ouverture on vient d'entendre
déjà 49 sénateurs qui prennent la parole
pour dénoncer cet article 7 et ça
continue il y a encore des dizaines
d'orateurs inscrits
importants de la dépense publique donc
vous avez choisi de taper les retraites
et comme vous voulez faire des économies
immédiates vous devez organiser un
moindre versement de pension et des
rentrées de cotisations plus importantes
donc empêcher les Français qui doivent
faire valoir leur droit à la retraite
dans les deux ans qui viennent
de le faire
ceux qui travaillent déjà depuis plus de
cas depuis plus de 40 ans
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler jeune
donc
et qui exerce souvent les métiers les
plus difficiles
ces Français ont parfaitement compris
mais vous vous ne comprenez pas
les millions de Français descendent dans
la rue font grève se prive de salaire
et le président de la République regarde
d'ailleurs
le porte-parole du gouvernement a
annoncé la fin du monde si les Français
persistaient à manifester leur colère
déclaration ridicule s'il en était
mais ce ne sont pas ces Français là qui
menacent d'autres pays
c'est l'entêtement de votre gouvernement
son mépris qui blesse les Français et il
n'y a rien de bon à attendre d'un peuple
blessé
et en toute état de cause je sais une
chose c'est que les ministres aux bandes
ne m'ont pas entendu pas plus que ses
éminents représentant de cette majorité
dans le Sénat parce qu'il se moque du
tiers comme du quart de ce que nous
avons à dire et qui sont plus occupés à
discuter et à rigoler entre eux
allez allez monsieur vallée
merci monsieur le Président au moment
d'aborder l'étude de l'article 7
monsieur le rapporteur a parlé d'une
équation qui n'aurait que deux facteurs
pourtant rien n'interdisait d'en
introduire d'autres ils ont tous été
refusés mais encore une fois avec si peu
d'explications de vote c'est pour cela
que d'autres parlent pour vous et que
faute de mieux nous sommes obligés
d'aller les écouter c'est le cas d'Alain
mainq pensez à organique de la droite et
de la macronie qui écume ses jours-ci
les plateaux télé et je vais le citer en
mettant bien les guillemets pour être
sûr de ne pas le plagier lui qui comme
auteur pluri condamné pour contrefaçon a
déjà brillé par un comportement fautif
en la matière mais au moins lui il parle
sans sur moi et sans pudeur je le cite
dans la vie on a l'obligation de bien
parler à son banquier fin de citation
comme si ceux qui triment en fin de mois
ne le savaient pas plus que les autres
et notamment ceux qui sacrifient du
salaire pour faire grève comme
aujourd'hui encore je poursuis on ne
paye que 5% de taux d'intérêt en plus
que l’allemagne ce qui finalement est
une bénédiction imméritée pour la France
on saluera l'esprit patriotique du
monsieur qui confine au masochisme et
enfin ouvrez les guillemets celle-là est
à encadrer le marché est un être
primaire s'il voit qu'on a changé l'âge
il considéra que la France est enfin un
pays sérieux fin de citation pour être
sérieux il faut donc être injuste tout
est dit par ce monsieur sans filtre et
sans honte le marché primaire alors
soyons le avec lui si c'est ça le projet
ce serait déposer les armes devant la
brutalité de la vie et sacrifier
l'honneur de la politique à l'appétit
insatiable du marché fut un temps hanté
maastrichien où vous proclamiez avec le
général que la politique de la France ne
se faisait pas à la corbeille c'est
là-dessus qu'on a envie de vous entendre
ne laissez pas les autres parler à votre
place Minc n'est rien le peuple qui a
défilé aujourd'hui et tout exprimez-vous
comme nous vous le disons aujourd'hui
pour vous demander le retrait madame
cucurban
merci monsieur le président
l méchant entre collègues alain Milon a
convoqué ici même Spinoza sachons
ensemble finalement continuer de
comprendre ce réel qui sous-tend le
pacte social parce que je demeure
convaincu messieurs les ministres que
oui la retraite dans notre pays en
France à travers son histoire constitue
un des piliers fondamental de ce pacte
social et je veux ce soir rendre hommage
à celui qui en 1884 des
inspirateurs de la première loi sur les
caisses de secours et de retraite de la
loi
Waldeck-Rousseau ce n'est autre que
Michel rondès est habitant de la commune
de La Ricamarie au cœur de la vallée de
London dans le département de la Loire
de s'évaler ouvrière terre de solidarité
et de fraternité je veux ce soir aussi
rendre hommage à cet homme embrasse
croisat qui au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale a su si bien un carnet
c'est héritage du Conseil national de la
résistance ou gaulliste et communiste se
disait que pour reconstruire la France
nous avions besoin à travers d'impact
social de la sécurité sociale et d'une
branche vieillesse qui prenait en compte
ce nouveau temps de la vie
inévitablement ce pacte social a évolué
parce que la société a évolué nous en
sommes à bientôt près de 80 ans
cependant année après année la retraite
n'a jamais perdu de son utilité sociale
de ces femmes et de ces hommes présents
dans nos communes de ces femmes et de
ces hommes présents dans les
associations de ces jeunes retraités qui
aujourd'hui donnent tout leur sens à ce
que doit être la retraite un moment du
troisième du quatrième âge de la vie
personnelle mais aussi un moment de la
vie collective de celle où on rend à la
société qui nous a tant donné mais sur
les ministres votre projet de loi
aujourd'hui ne répond plus à ce pacte
social en ce sens ne voteront pas
l'article 7
[Applaudissements]
mini chers collègues enfin l'article 7
centre de cette réforme dimanche je vous
ai parlé de mon rêve ou plutôt de mon
cauchemar d'une corde de livreur à vélo
de 65 ans qui venait vous livrer trop
lentement des plats qui arrivaient froid
déclenchant votre courroux un collègue
de la majorité ma précisé dans le
couloir qu'effectivement certains
métiers on ne peut pas les faire toute
sa vie d'ailleurs c'est vous monsieur
Dussault lors d'une conférence de presse
du 10 janvier qui avait dit ce site la
reconversion est le meilleur moyen de
prévenir l'usure professionnelle pour
les salariés les plus exposés pourtant
votre gouvernement a retiré les critères
de pénibilité le livreur à vélo qui n'a
rien d'autre rigole devant votre propos
l'agriculteur que je suis rigole de même
la reconversion est un luxe qui n'est
pas accessible à tous et qui ne peut
justifier votre réforme dorénavant
matinée ici d'une perspective de
capitalisation une une forme injuste que
vous faites payer au seul salarié car
vous refusez toutes nos propositions
d'alternatives financières préférant
d'accès les gens sur leur vie plutôt que
d'aller chercher l'argent là où il est
en abondance les Français voulant dit
massivement aujourd'hui renoncer à cet
article 7 et à cette réforme je vous
remercie
monsieur Lurel
merci monsieur le Président
j'aimerais rappeler ici dans ce temple
de la Raison laïque et un peu trop
instrumental que tu gagneras ta vie à la
sueur de ton front n'allait pas récuser
l'origine de cette phrase et que l'une
des racines latines de travail ces
tripalium c'est instrument de torture
vous avez beaucoup croire que le progrès
s'est rivé l'homme à son établi
le sens de l'histoire c'est précisément
émanciper l'homme soit par la technique
soit par des lois c'est parce que vous
êtes en train de faire vous êtes à
contre histoire c'est une méchanceté
infligée au peuvent des travailleurs la
France des fils dans les rues le
président est muré dans le silence et
dans son palais et Laurence Rossignol a
parfaitement raison de dire nous sommes
dans une impasse démocratique et à
limite on pourrait dire ce que
un récuse et que je partage ouais oui le
peuple la représentation légale n'est
pas la représentation réelle oui vous
avez là à mon sens en étant sourd et
aveugle vous avez là un abus de majorité
et vous faites preuve de majorité
tyrannique le peuple de l'oubliera pas
et c'est vous je le dis qui fait le lit
du Front National et des extrêmes demain
vous serez comptable de cela et je le
dis sans le souhaiter parce que je suis
en républicain conséquent ce que vous
faites en étant fermé vous aurez vous
appelez à la radicalisation et vous
appelez aux violences et il faut en
sortir et le seul et le seul façon de
sortir c'est de retirer ce texte
monsieur Cabanel
rassemblement
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je comprends tout à fait les
arguments qui ont été développés et j'en
partage beaucoup et voilà les débats qui
se poursuivent ici les prises de parole
préalables plutôt avant l'examen du 1er
amendement sur cette article 7 c'est un
hémicycle bien garni ce soir dans le
palais du Luxembourg il n'y a que très
peu de sièges qui sont vides ici on sent
que les débats sont en train de monter
en puissance aussi également il y a eu
des pics dans un sens et dans l'autre je
retiens notamment cette prise de parole
du socialiste
Eric et rouge qui a interpellé
directement le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft en lui disant comme moi
monsieur le ministre vous êtes un
transfuge de classe vous êtes un
boursier que vous est-il arrivé monsieur
le ministre Olivier du soft qui est
resté impassible qui ne sait pas
retourner mais qui a bien été défendu
par contre par les des bancs de la
droite vous le voyez donc des débats qui
sont en train de monter progressivement
en puissance avant même l'examen du
premier amendement et des prises de
parole qui vont continuer notamment dans
quelques instants le président du groupe
LR Bruno retailler s'il veut partir à la
retraite à 62 ans parce que je suppose
que vous voulez rester à 62 ans
mais il aura une décote
une dicte de 5 %
100 euros par mois de moins alors que
ici et là nous sommes tous d'accord pour
que effectivement les pensions soient
les plus hautes possibles pour les
futurs retraités donc je crois que il
est important pour nous à travers donc
ce projet de loi qui nous est présenté
et même si je partage le fait que il est
pas dans un dans un au niveau de du
projet de loi de finance c'est pas le
véhicule législatif il y a quand même
donc d'autres articles notamment le 8 et
le 9 sur la pénibilité sur la retraite
progressive sur le droit des femmes sur
les carrières longues ou à mon sens là
nous devons apporter tous les éléments
pour assurer les Français
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on collègue qui se sont
exprimés précédemment je demande la
suppression de cet article pour trois
raisons d'abord parce que on a
l'impression avec ce texte que
l'important est le rallongement du
nombre d'années travaillées 65 puis
maintenant 64
est devenu un totem finalement pour
démontrer que vous réussissez là où vous
prédécesseurs ont échoué ou peut-être
non pas osé afin que cette réforme
figure parmi les autres au tableau
d'honneur d'un président qui se veut
réformiste ensuite parce que l'ampleur
des manifestations aujourd'hui et la
démonstration vous n'avez pas pris en
compte un changement radical dans le
rapport au travail dans la société
française accélérée et certainement
amplifiée par la crise covid enfin parce
que dans quelques heures nous serons le
8 mars et je ne doute pas qu'un nombre
de gestes symboliques qui ne coûte pas
cher certes seront faits pour nous
rappeler la grande cause du quinquennat
précédent le droit des femmes avec cette
réforme vous le referez pour ce 8 mars
2023 le droit de travailler plus pour
gagner moins et une retraite à minima
parce qu'elles n'auront pas pour
beaucoup d'entre elles les 43 à nuités
en continu parce qu'elles n'auront pas
l'argent nécessaire pour contribuer à
une assurance ou un fond de pension
privée pour compléter une retraite
minimum parce qu'elles auront abandonné
leur carrière en France poursuivre leur
conjoint en partant à l'étranger et
auront une finnée des carrières hachées
des cotisations faibles voire
inexistantes et pourtant vous leur
demandez de travailler deux ans de plus
si vous leur promettez une retraite de
misère alors les plus beaux gestes que
vous pourrez faire pour les Françaises
en ce 8 mars 2023 et de retirer votre
réforme
monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues je
ne l'ai pas m'exprimer en tant que
sénateur mais en tant qu' ancien chef
d'entreprise pendant 38 ans dans
l'agroalimentaire
je voudrais qu'au-delà de ce ces
discussions que nous avons depuis
quelques jours vous puissiez réfléchir à
un problème majeur nous sommes dans un
monde de compétition
j'ai connu des entreprises qui étaient
en Allemagne qui était dans le nord de
l'Europe et qui avait effectivement
beaucoup plus compétitivité que la nôtre
nous sommes passés de 10 milliards
d'exportation il y a trois ans à moins
de milliards cette année dans la
groalimentaire donc je vous invite à
réfléchir aujourd'hui s'il vous plaît
aujourd'hui on vous a écouté aujourd'hui
la compétition la compétitivité dans un
monde avec la Chine les États-Unis
l'Inde et bien d'autres pays nous oblige
à être véritablement compétition le
problème n'est pas toujours de régler le
problème des rémunérations je vous
rappelle que le Medef a fait un accord
avec les syndicats pour dans quelques
jours proposer une réglementation qui
permettra la capitalisation l'indemnité
mais en même temps le principe de
capitalisation qui est un sujet
intéressant et important donc je vous
invite à réfléchir sachez que l'avenir
appartient à ceux qui sont à même
d'apporter aux autres des raisons de
vivre et d'espérer c'est ce que nous
souhaitons ici merci
monsieur le président Bruno Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me souviens parfaitement c'était en
octobre 2010
et nous étions sur ces mêmes bancs le 12
octobre une énorme manifestation une
énorme mobilisation 3 millions de
personnes
j'étais ici
je soutenais cette réforme
et je me souviens les mêmes arguments
souvent caricaturaux le même ton
imprécatoire la réforme est votée vous
arrivez ensuite au pouvoir l'avez-vous
aboli non vous ne l'avez pas aboli vous
l'avez
vous l'avez durci avec les 43 annuités
de la réforme Touraine c'est ça la
vérité c'est ça le double langage ça
signifie aujourd'hui pour des Français
qui arrivent à 22 ans sur le marché du
travail un départ à taux plein un départ
à 65 ans voilà votre double langage oui
cette réforme nous l'avons déjà voté ici
nous l'assumons nous assumons le critère
d'âge nous l'assumons parce que c'est un
levier qui nous permettra de sauver le
régime des retraites c'est un levier
efficace c'est aussi parce que c'est un
filet de sécurité vous enlevez cette
borne d'âge et alors vous aurez une
machine à des parce que vous savez
parfaitement que c'est ce qui crée des
retraités pauvres vous savez aussi que
la décote des plus modestes c'est le
double par rapport au décote des cadres
alors oui nous l'assumons nous
l'assumons parce que cette borne d'âge
permettra non seulement de sauver la
réforme et le régime par répartition et
même si la réforme est provisoirement un
populaire nous en avons connu d'autres
mais quand on est et quand on fait de la
politique on assume ce qui est bon pour
le pays et c'est très fort à terme elle
ne sera pas abrogée pas plus que vous
n'aviez abrogé la précédente
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur Martin lévrier
merci monsieur le président
nos prédécesseurs nous ont laissé une
extraordinaire un extraordinaire système
de solidarité intergénée
intergénérationnelle c'est le système de
répartition de nos retraites qui nous
obligent à avoir systématiquement un
équilibre entre les actifs et les
pensionnés
nous savons tous aujourd'hui que cette
ce système est déséquilibré et de
redevenu fragile nous le savons tous et
nous en connaissons tous les raisons et
nous en connaissons tous les solutions
possibles des solutions possibles il y
en avait trois je ne le répéterai pas
nous avons choisi celle du déplacement
de l'âge de la retraite et vous savez
aussi pourquoi alors on peut nous dire
c'est une réforme de droite parce
qu'effectivement les amendements ont été
portés depuis quatre ans par la droite
ici mais on pourrait aussi dire que si
une réforme de gauche quand on regarde
les articles qui suivent l'article 7
monsieur le Président vous comprendrez
pourquoi on parlerament puisque c'est
assez difficile avec la avec ce qui se
passe ici
je vous rappelle je vous rappelle que
les efforts qui sont faits dans cette
loi sont de l'ordre les efforts sociaux
sont de l'ordre de 6 milliards et demi
ils étaient de l'ordre de 1 milliard
pour la réforme overte et de 4 milliards
pour la réforme Touraine c'est important
de le rappeler
cette réforme elle nous paraît aussi
très importante parce qu'elle rappelle
les relations du travail moi j'entends à
ma gauche depuis 5 jours maintenant une
enfin ma droite pardon vous avez raison
Unis une image une image du travail qui
est assez pitoyable qui est assez
pitoyable et qui montre à le travail
comme de l'aliénation moi je le crois au
travail comme l'épanouissement aussi
enfin vous ne vous le dites très très
rarement
enfin enfin je vous rappelle que c'est
une réforme et moi j'y crois beaucoup
qui est faite pour les jeunes quand j'ai
eu 30 ans quand j'ai commencé à
travailler à 25 ans on m'a dit que je
n'aurais pas de retraite je ne veux pas
dire aux jeunes de 25 ans aujourd'hui
qu'ils n'auront pas de retraite tout
cela pour vous dire que le manque de
courage c'est cela qui fait le lit des
extrêmes
madame Robert
pardonnez-moi
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je vais commencer par dire notre
collègue Retailleau qu'il est exact que
nous avons pas remis en cause la réforme
de retraite que vous avez vous-même mis
en œuvre de la même manière vous n'avez
pas remis en cause les 35 heures ni le
mariage pour tous
au-delà de ça
au-delà de ça mes chers collègues je
pense que nous traversons une période
particulière où notre démocratie
véritablement est en danger et je pense
qu'à travers cette loi nous jouons un
peu avec le feu d'abord sur la forme
parce que les organisations syndicales
pour la première fois depuis très
longtemps sont unis qu'il n'a pas été
compte de ce tenu compte pardon de ce
qu'elle proposait et qu'elles ont été
laissés en quelque sorte sur le bord du
chemin
sur le fond ça a été rapide tout à
l'heure mais je vais y revenir quelques
instants
depuis 2010 et même plus que cela notre
société a considérablement changé
le covid est passé par là certes c'est
si vrai que dans les accueils d'opinion
nous voyons que
ceux qui sont proches de la retraite
préfèrent finalement faire deux années
d'au moins de travail et en envisageant
une diminution sensible de leur pouvoir
d'achat c'était l'inverse de ce qu'il
déclarait voici seulement deux ou trois
ans
depuis
les présidentielles sont passés par là
et aux élections présidentielles que ce
soit la candidate de la droite ou la
candidate de la gauche ou Emmanuel
Macron qui a fait moins de 20 % que le
total des voies de l'extrême droite
montre bien que notre démocratie est en
danger c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense que l'assemblée des territoires et
le huitième qu'il a soutient à une
importance très forte et qu'il faut
faire preuve d'une grande responsabilité
d'écoute et d'attention et ne pas dire
qu'on met en place ce que nous avions
prévu voici quatre ans alors que depuis
4 ans beaucoup de choses ont changé
madame Robert
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la vie doit
toujours porter en elle une lueur
d'espoir car la fin de l'espoir elle au
commencement de la mort je pense que
beaucoup d'entre vous ici reconnaissent
cette phrase du général de Gaulle
hors reculé l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans donne comme
perspective aux françaises et aux
Français qu'il n'auraient peut-être pas
d'autres choix que de cesser leur vie au
travail au moment où ils ne seront pas
capables de la vivre en bonne santé et
on pense bien sûr à tout cela les plus
vulnérables les plus précaires les
femmes celles et ceux qui ont commencé
tôt à travailler et qui considère tout
simplement que cette réforme est brutale
alors pourquoi
n'écoutez-vous pas celles et ceux qui
crient cette injustice pourquoi
n'entendez-vous pas ces millions de
Françaises et Français qui aujourd'hui
vous ont dit qu'ils n'en veulent pas
c'est une affaire de légitimité et cela
devient une question démocratique alors
Monsieur le Ministre ayez du courage
abandonné c'est très forts et on pourra
peut-être faire résonner en nous cette
citation de Voltaire qui disait la
retraite et ce port heureux où l'on peut
se réfugier après les orages de la vie
chez olivierno pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
oui merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres vous nous avez
dit plusieurs fois que nous étions
silencieux que nous avions peur de
parler non simplement on a une obsession
c'est celle d'aller au bout du texte et
aller au bout du texte c'est la
responsabilité
je suis sorti de mes gonds tout à
l'heure quand j'ai entendu le sénateur
qui est rouge qui a interpellé le
ministre sur ses origines sociales
ça ne vous grandit pas c'est le marxisme
le plus terrible
oui
figurez-vous c'est la terre qui est
rouge moi
j'ai eu l'enfance heureuse j'ai pas
souffert dans ma vie et pourtant je
crois que je sais le généreux avec les
plus modestes d'entre nous et je
revendique cette qualité vous avez
appelé Marx j'appelle Max Weber
l'éthique de conviction mais surtout
l'éthique de responsabilité
monsieur Kanner vous avez tout à l'heure
dit que nous étions en train de revivre
le clivage droit de gauche oh je vois
bien que vous souhaitez ça mais nous ne
sommes plus en 1981 pourquoi parce que
les Français ne vous croient plus comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure quand vous
êtes au pouvoir quand vous êtes au
pouvoir vous choisissez la
responsabilité vous choisissez la
réforme Touraine et quand vous êtes dans
l'opposition vous choisissez
l'indignation vous choisissez une forme
d'irresponsabilité une forme de
démagogie mais méfiez-vous
électoralement ça ne vous grandit pas ce
sont les populistes qui sont à la porte
c'est eux qui encaissent votre
comportement et votre irresponsabilité
et nous nous choisissons le la
responsabilité parce que pour nous la
responsabilité c'est la meilleure
antidote au populisme je vous remercie
monsieur Lucia escort-girl
[Applaudissements]
et
messieurs les ministres en définitif je
serai très court
tout a été pratiquement dit par mes
collègues oui mais je peux
je peux encore le répéter si vous le
souhaitez
cette réforme est mauvaise et c'est un
coup bas pour les Français
mauvaise pour les Français qui vont être
frappés par la mesure que vous prenez
mais qu'est-ce qui vous a pris pourquoi
êtes-vous engagé dans cette aventure
vous êtes aveuglé par les mesures que
vous prenez vous même mais je crois que
vous êtes aveuglé par l'engagement du
président de la République dans cette
démarche funeste vous avez peut-être
même peur de ce président qui va imposer
ce triste sort à nos camps patriotes
d'ailleurs ici il n'y a pas que vous qui
êtes aveuglé par ce président de la
République qui ne s'occupe pas des
Français lui qui a obtenu moins de 30%
des voix du des Français au premier tour
et qui a été élu car personne ne voulait
de la candidate du RN alors nous allons
vous aider bien sûr les ministres n'ayez
pas peur aujourd'hui 3 millions de
Français ont manifesté plusieurs
millions sont en grève c'est un signal
courage ayez du courage
retirez cet article 7 numéro 7 retirez
cette mauvaise loi madame et Marco
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur des
ministres chers collègues je vais relier
retraite et climat ce sont deux
questions majeures qui sont pourtant
liées cette réforme des retraites repose
sur un postulat productiviste travaillez
plus encore plus longtemps qu'importe
encore qu'importe la pénibilité les
conditions de travail
pour toi pourtant soigner le présent
c'est préparer l'avenir c'est ça serait
une retraite digne à toute et toute et
garantir justement ce droit à la
retraite aux prochaines générations
côté climat nous subissons déjà les
conséquences de l'inaction climatique et
justement elle frappe les plus
vulnérables
soigner le présence et préparer l'avenir
c'est agir aujourd'hui pour préserver
notre planète pour protéger les hommes
et les femmes qui vivent c'est avec
cette réforme de la retraite que nous
prévoyons pas l'avenir
ce n'est pas sérieux nous ne sommes pas
à la hauteur des enjeux aujourd'hui je
me permets de terminer par une citation
de Pablo Neruda
poète chilien mais aussi sénateur
il meurt lentement celui qui ne change
pas de cap
alors je vous dis aujourd'hui il est
encore temps de changer de cap merci
bien
alors nous avons terminé avec les
paroles monsieur le ministre vous
vouliez intervenir il est 22h55 sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat vous suivez
l'examen de l'article 7 de la réforme
des retraites et on vient de voir à ces
prises de parole introductive et le
ministre qui répond
merci Monsieur président d'abord pour
dire que si nous présentons cette
réforme et si nous avons fait le choix
de proposer au Parlement l'adoption cet
article 7 avec des mesures qu'on
qualifie parfois de paramétrique parce
que tout à fait entre nous entre
paramétriques et systémique parfois la
confusion peut régner et ce qui
systémique systémique à un moment
s'accompagne généralement de critères
paramétriques pour fonctionner mais
parfois il y a une volonté divisée
peut-être de manière un peu arbitraire
les choses dans la matière pourquoi
est-ce que nous avons présenté cette
mesure là d'abord parce que je l'ai dit
à plusieurs reprises je le dis très vite
le système de retraite que nous
connaissons pour des raisons
essentiellement démographiques n'est pas
un système équilibré et donc il y a un
équilibre financier à retrouver un
déficit à combler et par ailleurs nous
souhaitons financer de nouveaux droits
des nouveaux droits en matière
pénibilité des nouveaux droits en
matière de prise en compte des carrières
longues des nouveaux droits en matière
de niveau minimum de pension des
nouveaux droits aussi sur la question de
la prévention et de l'emploi des seniors
et lorsque l'on finance des nouveaux
droits lorsque l'on crée de nouveau
droit en même temps qu'on crée de
nouveau droit on crée de nouvelles
dépenses c'est très normal et donc il
nous faut trouver des recettes qui
permettent d'atteindre cette équilibre
nous avons regardé les choses et parfois
j'entends mais pourquoi est-ce que vous
ne vous seriez pas contentés si je puis
dire d'accélérer la mise en œuvre de la
réforme Touraine de 2013 parce que
l'accélération de la réforme Touraine de
2013 c'est 2 milliards 3 en 2025 les 4
milliards 6 en 2030 le déficit en 2030
c'est 13005 et la réforme que nous vous
proposons permet de générer 17,7
milliards d'euros sur les seules mesures
paramétriques et avec les quelques
mesures financières que nous ajoutons
d'arriver à 19,5 milliards d'euros de
recettes ce qui permettra de financer à
la fois le déficit de 2030 et le
financement des nouvelles mesures c'est
la première fois depuis plus de 30 ans
parmi les cinq dernières réforme des
retraites que la part des économies des
recettes générées par la réforme est
aussi importante pour ce qui est ce qui
concerne le financement de nouveaux
droits et de mesure d'accompagnement
social
en tête que la réforme de 2010 et j'ai
aussi en tête que le déficit a à résorbé
était beaucoup plus important du fait de
la crise financière mais la réforme de
2010 consacrée 6% des recettes générées
au financement de nouveaux droits et aux
mesures d'accompagnement social nous
sommes à 33% des financements des
mesures d'accompagnement social et nous
le faisons avec une volonté qui est de
protéger les plus fragiles les celles et
ceux souvent celles qui sont amenées à
travailler le plus tard possible et
c'est vrai la raison pour laquelle de la
même manière c'est la première fois
qu'un relèvement de l'âge légal de
départ et la retraite ne s'accompagne
pas d'un relèvement de l'âge
d'annulation de la décote nous le
maintenons à 67 ans de la même manière
mais j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
précédemment que nous maintenons les
âges de départ anticipés notamment pour
les travailleurs handicapés mais pas
seulement et le fait de maintenir l'âge
de suppression de la décote est une
vraie mesure de protection
j'ai enfin entendu dans les différentes
interventions un certain nombre de
reproches de critiques d'interrogations
sur le caractère juste ou injuste du
système de retraite mais en réalité et
je dis en regardant les bandes à gauche
c'est de là que ça venait
ce que vous nous reprochez ce que vous
reprochez au système de retraite ça
n'est pas tant la réforme que le système
actuel vous reprochez l'impact les
conséquences des carrières arrachées sur
le calcul des pensions particulièrement
des femmes vous reprochez l'absence de
prise en compte suffisantes de la
pénibilité alors que nous vous proposons
d'avancer vous reprochez le faible
niveau des retraites et finalement vous
nous reprochez d'avoir le courage de
faire ce que vous n'avez jamais eu le
courage de faire et c'est ce que nous
faisons avec cette réforme et je vais un
peu je vais même un peu plus loin si
s'il s'agissait de voir nous convaincre
un peu plus mais le président retaillou
m'a précédé pour une partie de cette
démonstration aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
vous faites de grandes déclarations vous
évoquez de grands auteurs que l'on
pourrait peut-être laisser en paix mais
vous avez posé de grands auteurs pour
dire votre position absolue à la réforme
regardons ce qui s'est passé depuis le
début des années 80
pas une réforme des retraites quelle que
soit l'ardeur avec laquelle elle a été
combattue et je prends ma part pas une
réforme des retraites n'a été remise en
cause par une quelconque alternance que
ce soit pas une et celle-ci comme les
autres si un jour est d'aventure vous
revenez au pouvoir vous la maintiendrez
vous la maintiendrez et comment en 2013
vous l'accentuerez parce que en 2013 et
ce qui s'est passé et je l'ai voté mais
contrairement à vous je l'assume je l'ai
voté l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation était aussi justifiée par le
fait que l'âge avait été relevé et qu'il
fallait trouver une cohérence pour
éviter justement qu'il est discordant
entre l'âge et la durée de cotisation il
se passera exactement la même chose si
d'aventure vous deviez retrouver des
responsabilités et un esprit majoritaire
et puis enfin une dernière chose j'ai
évoqué la comparaison avec la seule
accélération de la réforme Touraine mais
il faut aller plus loin dans la
comparaison et regarder les alternatives
quels sont les alternatives j'entends
parfois mais arrêtez avec l'âge
d'ouverture des droits et conc
rendez-vous sur la durée de cotisation
nous avons fait la simulation c'est 45
années minimum c'est 45 années minimum
dans une période où l'âge moyen d'entrer
dans la vie active est à est à 22 ans ça
signifie que ceux qui ne se concentrent
que sur la durée de cotisation créer de
la décote ou accepte la perspective d'un
âge effectivement
j'ai aussi entendu c'est le chef de
votre partie mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs socialistes monsieur fordir on
revient à 60 ans mais avec 43 années de
cotisation c'est une machine à pauvreté
c'est une machine à décote parfois même
son numéro 2 dit que c'est une utopie et
que c'est totalement irréaliste donc
nous proposons quelque chose qui est
protecteur protecteur parce que ça
permet de garantir l'égalité protecteur
parce que ça permet de garantir la
pérennité du système son financement son
retour à l'équilibre et le financement
des nouveaux droits c'est la raison sont
les raisons pour lesquelles monsieur le
Président et j'irai plus vite sur les 70
ou 72 je crois un moment de suppression
mais comme il s'agit de supprimer des
dispositions auxquelles nous sommes
attachés j'ai essayé de vous le
démontrer j'irai plus vite pour donner
tout à l'heure des avis défavorables
merci nous allons commencer
l'examen de
amendements qui font qui sont identiques
et qui sont les amendements de
suppression la maman numéro 3 madame à
poursuppoli
merci pour le début de l'examen des 1311
amendements déposés rien que sur cet
article 7 du projet de loi retraite et
donc les 77 premiers examinés d'une
traite sont tous des amendements de
suppression de la mesure de l'article
c'est parti pour ce débat
aujourd'hui cet article s'est inscrit
dans la durée le principe d'un
allongement de la durée de cotisation
nécessaire pour obtenir une retraite à
taux plein la durée de cotisation est
relevée d'un trimestre tous les trois
ans jusqu'en 2035 pour atteindre 172
trimestres soit 44 ans pour les
générations nées en 73 et suivantes le
pouvoir accélère la réforme Touraine
contre laquelle nous nous étions opposés
sur les banques communistes tous les
salariés vont devoir travailler
davantage même ceux qui exercent des
métiers pénibles et à cet instant je
pense aux salariés de l'agroalimentaire
qui travaille dans le froid à la chaîne
qui feront les qui font les trois huit
femmes comme homme comme un Moïse dans
le Pas-de-Calais qui sont usés je pense
au sous aux ouvriers aux salariés qui
travaillent en fonderie à 1400 degrés à
Arc International ou à stellankees je
pense aux ouvriers des ports aux agents
de police aux sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels aux égoutiers qui devront
travailler au moins jusqu'à 59 ans
contre 57 aujourd'hui ainsi les Français
passeront moins de temps à la retraite
toutes ces réformes successives ont
organisées la paupérisation de nombreux
retraités avec cet article vous actez le
retour aux années 70 ou la retraite
était à 65 ans contrairement au
gouvernement qui veut faire un retour
dans le passé nous voulons aller vers
l'avenir en réduisant le temps de
travail et en réduisant le temps passé
au travail en partant à la retraite à 60
ans je vous remercie madame Cohen
merci monsieur le Président plus le
texte de la réforme des retraites avance
plus l'injustice sociale du projet
éclate au grand jour elle est unique
elle est injustifiée nous avons nous
l'avons démontré depuis le début de nos
discussions pour toutes et tous moins de
2,5 % des futurs retraités concernés par
une revalorisation à 1200 euros par la
réforme moins de 1,5% des retraités
actuels verront leur pension franchir le
seuil des 1200 euros mais comme
visiblement vous n'entendez ni les
arguments du peuple dans la rue ni ceux
des parlementaires de gauche ici présent
laissez-moi faire référence à un appel
de personnalité qui elles aussi sont
exprimé leur refus de cette réforme le
18 janvier dernier plus de 100
personnalités ont rédigé une tribune
pour dénoncer les dangers de ce projet
des personnes des personnalités issues
de la culture des économistes des
sociologues des philosophes des
historiens qui participent à la vie
intellectuelle de notre pays et à son
rayonnement et qui toutes s'unissent
pour écrire
contre cette réforme je cite Annie
Ernaux prix Nobel de littérature Barbara
Carlotti compositrice Lydie Salvaire
écrivaine et j'en passe l'objectif je
les cite l'objectif de cette réforme à
rebours de l'histoire sociale et de
faire travailler plus et plus longtemps
des femmes et des hommes qui aspirent au
repos et a donné libre cours à leurs
projets dans un moment privilégié de la
vie pour y parvenir le gouvernement
tente de nous enfermer dans une querelle
budgétaire et comptable vous l'avez
exprimé admin de reprise la réforme va
frapper plus durement ce qui exerce des
métiers les plus difficiles
usant tant physiquement que
psychologiquement et qui ont moins de
chance de profiter d'une retraite
paisible et de s'imaginer un avenir
après 64 ans le report de l'âge légal
n'a aucun effet sur les plus diplômés et
fait peser la charge entièrement sur les
-10
voilà pourquoi nous demandons la
suppression de cet article
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à supprimer l'article
relatif au recul de l'âge de départ
obligatoire à 64 ans d'ici à 2030 il y a
quelques heures monsieur le ministre
Attal parler d'équilibre du système de
retraite pour les prochaines années moi
je souhaite vous parler d'équilibre
entre une vie complète au travail et un
droit au repos ce droit au repos n'est
pas un caprice c'est la possibilité de
s'épanouir et de profiter des siens
après avoir contribué tout au long de sa
vie à la dynamique économique de notre
pays
cette mesure est inéquitable est injuste
pour tous ceux qui ont des parcours
hachés en premier lieu les femmes pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tôt
et pour ceux qui ont qui sont exposés à
des métiers pénibles cette mesure est
également brutale puisqu'elle
s'appliquera dès le premier septembre
2023 et concernera des personnes très
proches du départ à la retraite cette
mesure est un indice proportionnée par
rapport aux prévisions et nous pensons
que d'autres moyens auraient pu être
proposé pour résorber ce déficit tout
ceci est le sens de notre amendement de
suppression merci
merci monsieur le Président alors moi je
ne reprochais je ne reprocherai pas à
Monsieur le Ministre de ne pas faire une
réforme de gauche c'est normal et encore
moins une réforme écologiste c'est
normal vous êtes de droite et
productiviste effectivement il faudrait
il faudrait pour faire une
autre partition des richesses vous avez
montré que vous ne savez pas le faire et
vous ne savez encore moins passer de la
notion de croissance à la notion de
prospérité il faudrait avoir le projet
de changer le travail et sa place dans
la vie vous vous ne pensez qu'elle
intensifier pour produire plus de profit
très rapidement je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est une réforme de droite
parce que les en fait si vous pouvez
vous permettez de parler ça va être
interrompu merci
donc oui je vais vous dire pourquoi
c'est une réforme de droite parce que
c'est sur les travailleurs et sur eux
seuls que vous allez faire les économies
10 milliards en leur payant pas de
pension pendant deux ans et c'est eux
qui vont vous apporter des recettes les
7 milliards encore en cotisation et et
en impôts donc c'est eux 17 milliards
c'est eux qui vous apportent toute la
réforme et quand à vos 3 milliards 3 est
passé de mesure d'atténuation de la
brutalité de de la réforme c'est pris
sur ces 18 milliards ce sont les
travailleurs qui se les payent c'est pas
les employeurs c'est pas l'état c'est
personne d'autre sur les 18 milliards il
y a effectivement 16% qui va atténuer
les les la brutalité de la réforme et
c'est 16% et c'est pas 33% et c'est les
travailleurs qui se les payent
monsieur le Président Gautard
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
depuis le début de cette récent le
gouvernement s'obstine a répété en
boucle à mensonge ce recul de l'âge de
départ en retraite serait inévitable il
serait la seule solution pour résoudre
le futur déficit de notre système de
retraite cependant nous l'avons répété à
maintes reprises c'est faux faux et faux
ce report de l'âge légal est un choix du
gouvernement et un choix injuste le
choix de faire reposer tous les efforts
sur les épaules des travailleurs et des
travailleuses particulièrement les plus
précaires celles et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler les plus jeunes et
qui ont des carrières incomplètes pire
encore cette réforme est brutale et ne
prévoit à peu près pas de mesure
d'accompagnement votre choix est de ne
pas redistribuer les richesses et de ne
pas les prendre en compte à l'inverse
depuis le début de cette réforme nous
martelons la même chose il existe des
alternatives à la fois socialement et
écologiquement juste pour renforcer
justement notre système de retraite que
vous avez méthodiquement refusé
l'élargissement de l'assiette des
cotisations et dividendes l'augmentation
des la réduction des inégalités de
salaire entre femmes et les hommes ou
encore la semaine de 32 heures sur
quatre jours il y a à dire vrai des
dizaines de milliards d'euros de
financement possible qui mettrait un
rebours de votre projet de revenir
progressivement vers l'âge de départ de
60 ans que nous défendons et nous le
ferons monsieur le ministre nous le
répétons cette réforme est injuste elle
aura un nombre d'impact négatifs
importants sur le chômage des seigneurs
des seniors sur notre tissu associatif
sur notre démocratie locale j'y
reviendrai et surtout surtout sur le
quotidien des Français et des Françaises
ceux qui devront travailler 2 ans de
plus mais aussi leurs enfants et
petits-enfants monsieur le ministre plus
personne ne croit à votre projet à votre
réforme est-ce qu'il reste de votre
majorité se fissure petit à petit votre
seul créneau travaillait plus votre
absence de vision de manque
d'imagination votre dogmatisme vous
empêche de voir l'évolution de notre
société
notre système de retraite par
répartition auxquelles nous sommes tous
très attachés il me semble enfin je
l'espère n'est pas menacer il exécutif
dramatise la situation qu'il a un peu
créé lui-même de manière caricaturale il
attaque notamment à ses calculs le poids
des pensions des fonctionnaires sous
financés par l'État ce qui est une
hérésie l'objectif est de faire une
réforme budgétaire en ne sollicitant que
les efforts des travailleurs sans jamais
remettre en cause la gabegie d'aide aux
entreprises sans aucune contrepartie la
baisse permanente des impôts sur les
entreprises le renoncement à la lutte
contre l'optimisation fiscale ou encore
la course à l'extravagance financière
qui déséquilibre chaque jour un peu plus
la répartition des richesses cette
présentation caricaturale a besoin
urgent de réforme du système de retraite
se part d'attention noble toutes plus
fausse les unes que les autres la vérité
est tout autre les femmes codent parmi
les grandes victimes de cette réforme
avec l'annulation de l'effet
bonificateur de maternité les
travailleurs et travailleurs ayant
commencé à travailler tôt vont
travailler encore Dav et seul une petite
partie minime des retraités sera
concernés par la mesure des 1200 euros
mensuels le reste des mesures
d'accompagnement de la disposition phare
du recul de l'âge ne sont que des
tentatives d'amortissement des
conséquences de cette disposition à
juste la chance et le drame du pays
c'est que les citoyens et les citoyens
salariés fonctionnaires se sont aperçus
de ces contre-vérités en même temps
qu'il ne se découvrait aucune appétence
pour travailler dans des organisations
où il se sent très souvent indésirables
à l'âge de 55 ans c'est une chance parce
qu'il le manifeste dans des cortèges
d'une importance inédite à Paris est en
haut et en province c'est un drame parce
que le gouvernement reste sourd à une
argumentation technique solide ancrée
dans la réalité du travail le
gouvernement reste sourd à cette volonté
populaire et l'incompréhension à laisser
place à l'indignation ainsi qu'à la
colère il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'empêcher l'adoption et la mise en
place d'un dispositif à juste il s'agit
également de redonner à l'anus à la
nation confiance dans la réalité la
vigueur de sa démocratie et de maintenir
de cohésion sociale menacée nous vous
demandons que solennellement de voter le
rejet de ce projet de loi et plus
particulièrement de son article 7 madame
latrix compta
mes chers collègues des millions de
Françaises et Français sont descendus
dans la rue partout en France pour la 6e
journée de mobilisation contre votre
réforme des retraites ajuste brutale et
siniquement négocié avec la droite aussi
tient de ces millions manifestants 80%
des salariés s'opposent à votre projet
de réforme ils disent non au report à 64
ans de l'âge légal la fin du travail des
enfants le repos dominical est congés
payés la semaine de 40-39 35 heures et
bien sûr les retraites démontent que
libérer le travail et l'horizon depuis
le 19e siècle des luttes sociales et du
sens du progrès humain pourtant votre
gouvernement veut dans cet article
imposer de travailler plus longtemps en
repoussant l'âge légal de la retraite à
64 ans au lieu de 62 actuellement la
durée de cotisations nécessaires pour
avoir une cotisation à temps plein à
taux plat augmenterait de façon brutale
alors qu'elle était prévue de manière
plus progressive jusqu'en 2035 et vous
oubliez de dire que l'objectif de la
réforme Touraine était justement
d'éviter un report de l'âge légal
à rebours de tout progrès social votre
gouvernement prévoit des économies
exclusivement sur le départ différé en
retraite des travailleurs et sur
l'allongement de notre temps de travail
cette réforme se fait sur le dos sur la
santé des Français parce qu'il faut
réduire les déficits que vous avez
creusé déficit public déficit du
commerce extérieur c'est difficile de
jumeaux c'est vous et c'est les
travailleurs qui doivent payer d'autres
choix politiques et sociaux fiscaux sont
possibles vous avez renoncié à l'ISF à
la taxation des ce super profits à une
réflexion sur la taxation plus juste de
la valeur créée à l'augmentation des
salaires tout cela vous le faites payer
au travailleur pour nous c'est non il
est temps les Français de retirer votre
réforme injuste
Monsieur Arnaud
oui monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs chers collègues le présent
amendement vise à supprimer l'article 7
du texte nous examinons il s'agit en ce
qui me concerne en aucun cas de
manifester une opposition dogmatique
idéologique à ce projet de réforme je
présente ce projet d'amendement avec
calme sérénité et modération comme
banque centriste nous devons bien avoir
conscience que cette réforme
paramétrique répond à nécessaire à
équilibrage budgétaire mais cette
réforme est aussi un choix de société
pour les générations à venir l'unique
critère permettant de partir à la
retraite à taux plein doit être la durée
de cotisation ainsi toute personne doit
pouvoir liquider ses droits dès lors
qu'elle acquis ses 172 trimestres de
cotisation sous réserve de la prise en
compte des critères de pénibilité en
fonction de la nature des métiers
exercés même si le gouvernement
maintient un dispositif de carrière
longue afin que les assurer
qui commence à travailler tôt puisse
partir à avant 64 ans certains assurés
commencent à travailler très tôt où les
femmes bénéficiant de trimestre acquis
au-dessus de la maternité de rond
cotiser 44 ans ou plus aujourd'hui la
réalité que près de 40 % de nos
concitoyens sont prêts à avoir une
retraite minorée en partant plutôt alors
il faut laisser la possibilité à chaque
citoyen d'opérer son propre choix de vie
d'avoir son destin en main poursuit une
activité prendre sa retraite à partir du
moment où la contribution de chacun à la
solidarité nationale c'est-à-dire les
172 trimestres cotisées sont réalisés
leur équilibrage financier budgétaire
peut également se concrétiser par une
réouverture du débat sur le temps et
l'organisation du travail sur un nombre
de trimestres éventuellement
complémentaires par une fiscalité plus
adaptée bref faire le travail dans le
bon ordre et pas comme cela nous est
présenté aujourd'hui je crois pouvoir
dire également que nous pourrions
considérer que la retraite pourrait se
prendre entre 60 et 67 ans suivant
l'histoire de chaque vie avec bien sûr
des pensions différentes intégrant
pénibilité
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues c'est
amendement vise à ne pas décaler l'âge
légal de 62 à 64 ans et à ne pas
accélérer la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire et je le redis pour afficher
une réduction globale du déficit
structurel qui la lui-même aggravé en
renonçant une part importante de ses
recettes le gouvernement prévoit ses
économies exclusivement sur le départ
différé en retrait des travailleurs et
sur l'allongement du temps de travail et
pourtant cette réforme est qualifiée de
réforme de justice d'équilibre et de
progrès par la première ministre
étrange qualificatif pour une réforme
qui va encore et toujours pénaliser les
travailleurs modestes opérer une
régression sociale majeure et dont
l'utilité pour l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite reste à démontrer
cette réforme relève purement et
simplement d'un positionnement
idéologique dans le droit fil de la
politique menée maintenant depuis 2017
de désarmement fiscal et de faveur pour
les plus aisés
nous nous opposons résolument à cette
réforme et nous ne sommes pas les seuls
les millions de Françaises et Français
qui ont encore aujourd'hui battu le pavé
ne veulent pas de cette réforme
inutile pour le financement du régime
par répartition injuste pour nos
concitoyens et à rebours de tout progrès
social je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement donc je présente vise à
supprimer l'article fin d'un projet de
loi de régression sociale inacceptable
le coeur coeur de la réforme cet article
7 est une mesure injustifiée injuste
inefficace et brutale plus précisément
parmi les mesures d'augmentation des
ressources du système de retraite les
mesures dit d'âge sont les mesures les
plus injustes car elles touchent
aveuglément les assurés sans tenir
compte de leur situation à l'inverse
d'autres réformes celle-ci présente le
caractère la caractéristique d'avoir un
impact immédiat en effet un travailleur
né en 1968 qui a commencé à travailler à
20 ans aurait dû partir avec 42 années
et d'autres trimestres de cotisation
avant la réforme et bien il devra
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans après la
réforme soit si trimestre supplémentaire
une partie ira donc pas à la retraite en
2030 mais en 2032
tous nos débats depuis 6 jours le prouve
votre réforme monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre est injuste et pas
utile en l'état pire elle ne fera que
des perdants et ça les Français l'ont
parfaitement compris et ils le disent
mais vous ne voulez pas les entendre
retirer votre réforme
cet amendement vise à ne pas décaler
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans et à ne pas
accélérer la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine en plus d'être
profondément injuste et inutile cette
réforme en se conjuguant à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui réduit la durée
d'indemnisation à celle du RSA va enfin
précariser les travailleurs seniors qui
veulent leur durée d'indemnisation
chômage réduite de 8 mois il n'est donc
plus que le RSA pour survivre s'ils y
ont droit qui peut croire
raisonnablement que ce que propose le
gouvernement dans sa réforme un nouvel
indicateur que devront publier les
entreprises sans aucune obligation de
résultats et un quelconque est fait
amortisseur sur cette popularisation en
marche des travailleurs seniors face à
ce projet de loi de régression sociale
terrible et sénateurs socialistes
écologistes et républicains combattons
pierre et puis le gouvernement et sa
réforme injuste
inutile et
inefficace merci
madame arrivée
merci voilà il est 23h21 nous sommes en
direction interne de Public Sénat à
priori pour toute la soirée une partie
de la nuit pour suivre l'examen de
l'article 7 sur le report à 4 ans de
l'âge de départ à la retraite et on voit
cette longue liste d'orateur de gauche
qui ont proposé des abonnements de
suppression de la mesure ils sont au
total 77 à avoir déposé un tel
amendement et on va donc écouter ses 77
orateurs prendre la parole alors Mathias
existe-t-il des dispositions dans le
règlement du Sénat qui pourrait
permettre à la droite et au centre voir
au gouvernement d'accélérer cette longue
vitamine de prise de parole absolument
Quentin il existe plus plusieurs
manières d'accélérer ces débats on a
beaucoup parlé de l'article 38 du
Règlement intérieur du Sénat cette
disposition prévoit que lorsque au moins
deux orateurs d'avis contraire sont
intervenus le président un président de
groupe ou le président de la commission
saisie sur le fond peut proposer la
clôture de ladite discussion la clôture
doit être alors votée à main levée il y
a d'autres dispositions par exemple
l'article 42 du règlement et ses alinéas
10 et 16 qui permettent à la Conférence
des Présidents de prévoir pour des temps
qu'elle détermine 15 seul orateur ne
s'exprime pour par groupe il y a aussi
une autre arme réglementaire du Sénat
c'est l'examen d'articles en priorité
une disposition sur laquelle le Sénat
peut statuer sans débat et puis il est
enfin une disposition qui cette fois
elle est constituationnelle il s'agit de
l'article 44 alinéa 3 il dépend d'une
demande du gouvernement de simplement
s'intéresser aux amendements que lui a
proposé il est également connu dans le
jargon comme le vote bloqué ouais merci
Mathias pour tous ces explications et
une rumeur qui circule dans les couloirs
du Palais du Luxembourg qui pourrait y
avoir l'utilisation d'une de ces armes
de règlement ou de la Constitution à la
fin de la prise de parole des 77
amendements le suppression va suivre ça
au plus près bien sûr
et devant lui à l'échec de la réforme
systémique il y a un retour au Paris aux
paramétrique un retour aux paramétrique
de la fin du 20e siècle et c'est un
rendez-vous manqué un rendez-vous manqué
paritaire et parlementaire paritaire car
vous avez réussi l'exploit de mettre
tous les partenaires sociaux
pratiquement contre vous parlementaire
car de 49-3 en 47 1 vous avez
volontairement réduit le débat
démocratique et réduit une fois de plus
le parlementarisme alors que ce dialogue
induit la capacité de contribuer à
l'apaisement social par son absence vous
contribuez à la désinstitutionnalisation
vous alimentez la colère en refusant le
libre choix de partir à 62 ans même avec
une carrière incomplète vous cassez
l'anticipation de sortir d'un parcours
salarial vous cassez le libre choix que
chaque personne peut avoir à un moment
donné et c'est bien cette rupture à
l'évêque l'évolution sociétale qui pose
problème aujourd'hui et qui crée
effectivement
du conflit vous rompez donc ce subtil
équilibre et en repense aussi petit
liquides vous semblez découvrir la
colère qui existait aujourd'hui dans la
rue et qui risque effectivement de
s'amplifier voilà donc toutes les bonnes
raisons aujourd'hui qui mériteraient de
faire en sorte que cet article 7 soit
supprimé car il attaque contre sens de
l'évolution de la société
monsieur Michaud
oui monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues c'est
amendement propose de supprimer
l'article relatif au recul de l'âge de
départ obligatoire à 60 ans d'ici à 2030
beaucoup de mes collègues ici l'ont
rappelé et l'opposition massive qui
s'exprime d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans la
rue le confirme cette mesure est injuste
en particulier pour ceux qui exercent
des métiers pénibles qui ont commencé
tôt au pion des carrières hachées les
dispositifs mis en place en parallèle de
cette réforme sont insuffisants pour
combler toutes les failles qu'une telle
disposition entraîne nous considérons
que la mesure dash empêche tout des
basses sereins sur l'avenir de notre
système de retraite elle cristallise les
tensions et les appréhensions des
Français qui plus est un moment donné où
les conditions de vie et la perte de
pouvoir d'achat du à l'inflation sans
source de force inquiétudes pour nos
concitoyens c'est une mesure trop br
aller injuste disproportionné qui plus
est par rapport aux prévisions de
déficit du système de retraite l'exemple
des femmes et particulièrement parlant
le report de l'âge sera plus marqué pour
les femmes que pour les hommes en effet
l'étude d'impact anticipe un relèvement
de l'âge de départ lié à la réforme de 7
mois moyenne pour celles-ci contre 5
mois pour les hommes d'autre part
doivent être étudiés afin de résorber le
déficit sans que les travailleurs les
plus modestes n’est à supporter seul
l'effort demandé je vous remercie
monsieur Redon sarzy
la parole
merci monsieur le Président donc cet
avendement du sénateur socialiste
écologiste et républicain vise à ne pas
décaler l'âge légal de la retraite
malgré l'opposition de l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales de salariés et
de la population en témoignent
aujourd'hui l'inédite
intérêt de cette manifestation le
gouvernement sauf si à vouloir mener sa
réforme injuste des retraites et
notamment à décaler l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et augmenter plus
vite que prévu le nombre d'années de
cotisations les sénateurs socialistes
sont profondément opposés à cette
réforme qui n'est ni plus ni moins que
le plus juste des impôts injustes les
impôts sur la vie pour financer les
belles impôts au ménage les plus riches
et aux grandes entreprises cette réforme
va en effet obliger les travailleurs et
les travailleuses de première ligne à
travailler plusieurs années de plus
jusqu'à 64 ans pour ne pas subir de
décote mais parmi les plus défavorisés
un homme sur trois et déjà mort avant
d'atteindre l'âge de 64 ans le
gouvernement veut faire supporter au
seul travailleur le coût de sa réforme
aucune autre piste étudiée il préfère
tuer à la tâche des travailleurs et des
travailleurs au métier les plus durs que
de faire payer ces sommes à leurs
employeurs dont il a choisi de faire
baisser les prélèvements de 18 milliards
par an en l'espèce de deux ans
en plus d'être profondément injuste et
inutile cette réforme en se conjuguant à
la réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
réduit la durée d'indemnisation et celle
du RSA va enfin précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite et
qui n'auront donc plus que le RSA pour
survivre aussi bien sûr toutefois ils
ont droit en reculant les gale de deux
ans l'adresse prévoit une hausse cumulée
de 5 milliards d'euros des dépenses
sociales 1,3 milliards pour les dépenses
d'assurance chômage et 3,6 pour les
dépenses de prestations sociales qui
peut croire raisonnablement que ce que
propose le gouvernement dans sa réforme
est un quelconque qui est fait
amortisseur sur cette pauvrisation en
marche des travailleurs en particulier
nous combattons donc cette réforme
injuste inutile et efficace monsieur
devinez
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre c'est amendement vise bien
évidemment à ne pas décaler l'âge légal
de 62 à 64 ans et à ne pas accélérer la
mise en oeuvre de la réforme Touraine le
mouvement social qui s'oppose au report
de l'âge de départ en retraite à 64 ans
s'inscrit dans une longue liste de
luttes sociales qui ont marqué
l'histoire de la France il a toujours
fallu que les Françaises et les Français
arrachent aux puissants les concessions
qui leur refusaient aujourd'hui le
président de la République veut revenir
sur une de ces conquêtes sociales il
s'attaque à un pilier à un des piliers
de notre modèle social la retraite de
tous les Français
en Velan 2 ans de vie aux françaises et
aux françaises pour réaliser des
économies budgétaires vous choisissez
l'injustice plutôt que la solidarité
vous sacrifiez notre système de retraite
sur l'hôtel du déficit de l'État pour
les seigneurs qui sont mises en emploi
ni en retraite le recul de l'âge de
départ il faudra au rallongement de leur
période de précarité la part d'inactif
non retraité et de 25 % à 60 ans 61 ans
et ces seigneurs n'ayant ni emploi ni
retraite sont en majorité des femmes en
refusant d'accompagner cette réforme
d'une politique volontariste en matière
d'emplois des seniors votre gouvernement
en voici amant une partie d'une classe
d'âge dans une trappe à pauvreté sans
fin vous vous obstinez à ne pas
abandonner cette réforme injuste nous
nous obstinons à la refuser comment
rester sourd à la mobilisation d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui à l'espoir de tous ceux
pour conclure sont la valeur de notre
pays
je vais conclure non au sacrifice de nos
retraites je chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président nous voici
au cœur de votre réforme la mesure d'âge
qui recule de 62 à 64 ans là je l'égal
de départ à la retraite je tiens à
saluer le courage du sénateur Arnaud et
de plusieurs parlementaires centrist qui
disent tout haut ce que d'autres à
droite pensent tout bas le critère d'âge
est injuste de toutes les façons de
faire une réforme des retraites c'est la
plus injuste qui soit ce n'est pas moi
qui le dit ce n'est pas uniquement ces
quelques parlementaires centrices qu'ils
disent c'est le président de la
République lui-même qui dans une
interview datant du 26 août 2019
déclarait si on fait une réforme comme
d'habitude comme on fait depuis 20 ans
on dit on va décalage de départ à la
retraite j'ai dit il y a quelques mois
je ne ferai pas ça pourquoi c'est pas
juste de faire ça parce que quand vous
avez commencé à travailler à 16 ans si
je vous décale votre âge de départ à la
retraite alors même que généralement
quand vous avez commencé à 16 ans vous
avez moins de diplômes vous êtes dans
des métiers plus pénibles c'est
profondément injuste deuxième chose on
est dans une économie où il y a encore
beaucoup de chômage il y a beaucoup de
chômage des seniors des plus âgés si on
décale l'âge légal on dit aux gens
restez plus longtemps au chômage c'est
pas correct et non c'est pas correct
parce que c'est une façon de dire que
les femmes et les hommes de ce pays ne
se que des bêtes de somme dont il faut
tirer la plus grande rentabilité
possible
donc comme la majorité des Français nous
nous battrons pour bien évidemment le
retrait de cet article mais pour le
retrait de cette réforme profondément
injuste et brutale
merci monsieur le Président avec cette
amendement nous demandons la suppression
de l'article 7 comme 8 Français sur 10
et les 3 millions et demi de personnes
qui ont défilé aujourd'hui nous nous
opposons à cette réforme et en
particulier le reportage de départ à la
retraite depuis 2017 le gouvernement a
fait le choix de baisser les impôts des
plus riches cela a été rappelé le
déficit actuel ne vient pas d'une
augmentation des dépenses mais d'une
diminution des financements et des
exonérations de cotisations patronales
il est paradoxal d'implorer l'urgence
financière pour justifier votre réforme
et en parallèle de diminuer les impôts
pour les plus riches supprimer la CVAE
mettre en place la flat tax ce choix est
donc un choix politique en reculant
l'âge de départ à la retraite le
gouvernement exclut d'emblée les
solutions alternatives pourquoi ne pas
choisir d'instaurer une surcotisation
sur les plus hauts salaires certains
grands chefs d'entreprises n'y sont pas
opposés et n'ont même proposé il y a
plus de levier plus levier pour remédier
à de prochain déficits le recul de l'âge
de départ est en état parmi d'autres et
ce n'est pas notre choix vous faites le
choix de l'injustice le choix de
privilégier la plus riche au mépris
d'être travailleuses et des travailleurs
contraints de travailler deux ans
supplémentaires en particulier les plus
précaires vous êtes délibéraux pourquoi
voulez-vous toucher à cette liberté de
partir dès 62 ans pour les travailleurs
parmi les plus défavorisés un homme sur
trois est déjà mort avant d'atteindre 64
ans voilà la réalité de votre réforme
Michel Audiard disait la retraite faut
la prendre jeune faut surtout la prendre
vivant c'est pas les moyens de tout le
monde nous ne voulons pas imposer aux
Françaises et en français qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie et qui aspire à
un repos bien mérité de travailler deux
années de plus c'est l'objet de mon
amour Mickaël
merci monsieur le Président l'amènement
que je défends porte sur le même objet
les débats l'assemblés national que nous
avons suivies tous avec attention nous
ont permis malgré la violence des débats
de faire parfois mieux connaissance et
d'essayer de comprendre la façon de
fonctionner de Monsieur le Ministre et
comme il commence à se faire tard et que
c'est bien compréhensible nous sentons
l'attention qui s'émoussent un peu pour
essayer de faire passer le message de
notre groupe j'ai trois questions à
l'attention de Monsieur le Ministre et
je demande sa concentration alors en 10
lettres horizontale commençant par e
synonyme d'obstination
entêtement merci en 7 lettres verticale
finissant également par E se dit d'une
réforme qui toucherait les plus faibles
et épargnerait le capital je pense que
vous l'avez injuste et pour relier les
deux et essayer de faire passer le
message toujours en horizontal aussi en
7 lettres commençant par R et finissant
par T décision qui montrerait que le
gouvernement s'est entendre les millions
de manifestants et renoncerait à
fracturer encore plus le pays retrait je
sais que vous levier car vous êtes connu
pour être meilleur cruciverbiste que
camarade monsieur le ministre donc c'est
une demande de retrait madame de La
Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président
tout à l'heure monsieur le ministre du
socle vous avez me semble-t-il pointé le
fait que les réformes des retraites
avaient pu se succéder qu'elles avaient
pu être contesté mais que pour autant
l'opposition d'un moment devenu la
majorité ne les avait pas remises en
cause
et bien je voudrais simplement vous lire
des propos que vous teniez vous-même en
2010 à l'occasion de la réforme des
retraites de 2010 vous disiez la chose
suivante cette volonté de reculer l'âge
de la retraite et doublement injuste
injuste car elle écarte d'emblée la
recherche d'autres recettes tiens tiens
notamment tiens c'est de moi
notamment la mise à contribution de
l'ensemble des revenus et en particulier
ceux du capital
tiens tiens
injuste aussi car elle fera porter les
forces sur des générations aujourd'hui
plus préoccupés par leur situation
actuelle par leur entrée sur le marché
du travail que par la question de la
retraite un de vos collègues qui fut
ministre de la Santé et qui est
désormais porte-parole du gouvernement
vous l'avez
Olivier Véran a dit lui-même mais vous
savez ce gouvernement propose des
réformes de droite et il a choisi pour
les porter des anciens socialistes c'est
vous dire comme notre cœur saigne
Olivier Véran rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales sur
PLFSS 2015
reculez l'âge de la de départ comme le
demande la droite et l'UMP en
particulier
aurait été une option bien injuste et
pour ma part je suis content que le
gouvernement ait fait le choix de porter
cette vitale de ne pas porter cette
vitale évolution avec justice et enfin
votre maître à tous le président de la
République est-ce qu'il faut reculer
l'âge légal qui est aujourd'hui à 62 ans
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas pour
deux raisons la première c'est que je me
suis engagé à ne pas le faire la
deuxième c'est que tant qu'on n'aura pas
réglé le problème du chauffage ce serait
hypocrite c'était le 25 avril 2019
monsieur Lauzac
merci monsieur le Président se décalage
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
de 62 à 64 ans mais connaît totalement
la perception de la retraite par les
Français ceci perçoivent ce moment de
résistance comme injuste retour des
choses après des décennies de labeur et
de labeur souvent arrassant une
reconnaissance de ce qu'ils ont apporté
la nation durant leur vie
professionnelle or avant même la réforme
qui nous est aujourd'hui proposée selon
une étude récente de la Caisse des
Dépôts c'est 40% de nos concitoyens qui
pensent ne pas avoir de penser au moment
leur départ la retraite et 25%
d'outeraient même de la survie du
système de retraite c'est dire comment
nos concitoyens perçoivent notre système
combien ils s'en sentent eux-mêmes
éloignés de par sa complexité et son
injustice en cette réforme n'est pas de
nature à les rassurer bien au contraire
les Français perçoivent que s'éloignent
d'eux une retraite bienvenue dans ces
conditions et son financement car les
choix retenus ne sont pas bons
aujourd'hui l'article 7 symbolise ses
choix just logiquement par des raisons
budgétaires comme si des possibilités
alternatives de recettes n'existaient
pas la contestation d'une force sans
précédent de ce report de l'âge de la
retraite rejoint le rejet du sens que
certains donnent au travail aujourd'hui
à savoir le culte de la performance et
du rendement l'appât du gain de la
spéculation bref un travail perçu comme
de moins en moins épanouissant et
émancipateur pour nos concitoyens
douleurs impatience pour une période de
retraite la plus sereine et la plus
longue possible c'est cette perspective
que vous retirez des millions de
Français en faisant reposer la totalité
de votre réforme sur l'allongement du
temps de travail quand on a une réforme
rejetée par deux Français sur trois
voire plus c'est bien qu'on touche aux
vivre ensemble à la cohésion sociale du
pays au bien-être collectif c'est ce que
vous ont rappelé ces foules
considérables de manifestants
aujourd'hui je prendrai comme seul
exemple la ville de conclure ou 7000
personnes c'est-à-dire plus de la moitié
de la population de cette ville
préfecture était à la rue ce matin alors
oui retirez votre réforme
j'aimerais associer Catherine qu'on
connait là à cette question et victoire
jasmin qui a du regagner la Guadeloupe
en posant la question si j'ose dire à sa
place monsieur le ministre du soft a
bien voulu dire jeudi dernier vous
comprenez dans les outre-mer vous partez
déjà à peu près à 65 ans cette loi ne
vous dérangera pas je résume sa pensée
mais c'était un peu ça j'aimerais lui
répondre simplement par quelques
chiffres dans les outre-mer l'âge moyen
de départ à la retraite est déjà
beaucoup plus tardif ici entre
64,3 ans à la Réunion 65 ans en Guyane
62,7 ans dans l'Hexagone ce n'est pas
pour le plaisir mais bien sûr pour ne
mais bien pour ne pas partir avec des
pensions trop faibles que ce départ sont
plus tardifs du fait de carrière moins
stable que dans l'Hexagone interruption
de carrière nombreux emplois emploi
informels l'entrée tardive en activité
s' est également par le fort taux de
chômage chez les jeunes en Guadeloupe
près d'un actif sur du plus de 50% des
jeunes de moins de 30 ans de travail pas
et la même chose pour les seniors à
partir de 55 ans la difficulté à
accumuler le nombre de trimestres pour
une carrière complète et d'autant plus
dommageable face à la plus faible
espérance de vie des populations
ultramarines l'espérance de vie à la
naissance pour les femmes et de
73,9 ans à Mayotte 81 Guyane 83 à la
Réunion compte 85,5 bref
cette loi là fera très très mal dans les
outre-mer et heureusement la commission
des affaires sociales a rectifier les
tensions du ministre qui voulait
supprimer le seuil de récupération sur
succession on a également mis en
extension litière notamment pour les
fonctionnaires des tailles plus
particulièrement pour les militaires et
bien là c'est une méchanceté infligée et
il serait peut-être bon ce que le
président de l'archive
retirer cette mauvaise loi je dirais
excusez-moi
merci monsieur le Président pourquoi
faut-il supprimer cet article 7 pas
parce que la droite est droite et on
peut vous reconnaître une certaine
constance peut-être davantage parce que
Messieurs Macron et du soft disent
aujourd'hui l'inverse de ce qu'il disait
naguère peut-être aussi parce que la
procédure parlementaire a été détournée
et que les choix qui ont présidé à ce
véhicule législatif
font douter de la qualité du travail que
nous conduisons ensemble la forme c'est
le fond qui remonte à la surface si on
croit si on en croit la forme qui a été
retenue c'est que le fond n'est pas bon
davantage encore il faut supprimer cette
article 7 à cause de l'unité syndicale
que vous avez su réaliser dans la rue la
concertation a été manquée nous ne
voulons pas cautionner l'injustice et la
brutalité de deux ans de travail
supplémentaires à une population qui
n'en veut pas et qui n'en peut plus il
faut supprimer l'article 7 parce qu'il
catalyse
les angoisses toutes les peurs et toutes
les colères il faut surtout
cycle 7 parce que vous n'avez pas de
plan B quel est le coût d'après qui
soutient cette réforme personne vous
avez tous été des élus locaux vous savez
ce qui peut passer et ce qui peut ne pas
passer ce qui peut être acceptable et ce
qu'il n'est pas il n'y a pas de plan B
et je voudrais vous renvoyer à ce que me
disait certains syndicalistes on a peur
on a peur que ça tourne mal parce que
250 000 gilets jaunes qui ont tout cassé
ont réussi à arrêter les réformes et
quand il y a plusieurs millions de
salariés dans la rue on continue que
faut-il faire alors tout casser pas là
c'est ça la réalité ce n'est pas le bon
moment ce n'est pas la bonne méthode il
y a une population qui est dans
l'inquiétude face à l'inflation face aux
difficultés du quotidien face à un
profond doute démocratique il n'est pas
trop tard pour renoncer à ce mauvais
article 7 il n'est pas trop tard pour
renoncer à cette mauvaise réforme
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
7 prévoit le report de deux ans de l'âge
légal d'ouverture des droits à la
retraite et cela pour tous les salariés
quel que soit leur difficulté la durée
de leur carrière mais il prévoit aussi
l'accélération de l'augmentation de la
durée des cotisations de la loi Touraine
ces deux dispositifs vont augmenter les
inégalités pour les plus précaires les
femmes ce qui exercent des médias
difficiles cet article 7 comporte les
dispositions les plus régressives de ce
projet de loi ce conjuguant à la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui réduit la
durée d'indemnisation et à celle du RSA
cette réforme va précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite de
8 mois et n'auront donc plus que le RSA
poursuivre s'ils ont droit qui peut
croire raisonnablement que ce que vous
proposez c'est à dire un nouvel
indicateur que devront publier les
entreprises sans aucune obligation de
résultat
est une quelconque est un quelconque et
fait d'amortisseur sur cette
paupérisation des travailleurs seniors
de plus vous n'avez absolument pas
mesuré les couches supplémentaires où
nous nous le savons pas induit par cette
réforme sur l'assurance chômage sur le
RSA sur l'assurance même l'a dit cette
réforme est injuste elle est aussi sans
aucune mesure par rapport aux prévisions
du corps sur le déficit du régime de
retraite et au contraire va au contraire
augmenter certaines dépenses publiques
nous vous l'avons déjà dit c'est pour ça
que cette amendement vise à supprimer
cet article 7 monsieur le ministre je
pense que vous n'avez pas d'autre choix
que de retirer cette loi injuste
inutile et inefficace vous devez laisser
le choix aux Français de partir à l'âge
de 62 ans ou de continuer une activité
professionnelle s'il le souhaite je
Cardon
merci monsieur le Président
rendez-vous pas la grande qui partout en
France d'Abbeville à Montauban de
Marseille à Péronne vous en juin à ne
pas décaler l'âge légal de 62 à 64 après
avoir méprisé le dialogue social après
avoir
ignoré les unes après les autres les
revendications des travailleurs après
avoir piétiné le Parlement vous vous
apprêtez à prendre les deux plus belles
années de la vie de celles et ceux qui
l'ont passé à travailler et qui méritent
le repos
et tout ça pourquoi pour équilibrer les
comptes publics asséchés par votre
politique intensive des cadeaux fiscaux
au grandes entreprises avec notamment la
fin de la CVAE et au ménage les plus
riches en particulier la suppression de
l'ISF et la création de la factase alors
chez moi dans la Somme grâce à vous
l'entreprise Amazon à Bove un milliard
de chiffre d'affaires ne paiera plus de
contribution de 140 000 euros à mieux
métropole par an alors oui vous me direz
c'est une coude d'eau qui est trois fois
rien mais en période de sécheresse on a
besoin d'un ruissellement justement qui
arrose les plus fragiles
mais les gouttes d'eau font les grandes
rivières et vous le savez la suppression
de la CVE c'est 20 milliards d'euros par
an en moins pour l'État que vous vous
entendez compenser en taxant le 2 années
supplémentaires pour les Français en les
faisant travailler drôles de
ruissellement n'est-ce pas à l'époque où
il n'y a plus d'argent magique il est
grand temps de ne plus offrir un pognon
dingue à ceux qui n'ont pas besoin enfin
je me tourne à la droite de l'hémicycle
et leur offrir une petite citation
et visuelle Émile Zola nous prévenait il
y a déjà un siècle l'injustice sociale
sème la haine éternel et récolte
l'universel souffrance voilà en quelques
mots ce que seront les fruits de cette
réforme injuste et inutile dont vous
faites complices éco-auteur majorité
présidentielle et majorité sénatoriales
même combat ne faites pas davantage
souffrir les Français entendez leur
souffrance de notre relation et retirer
cet article
je suis le président rénal
comme on a plusieurs plusieurs prises de
parole de cette soirée qui va nous
passionner tous
je vais quand même répondre
quelquefois
à ceux qui sur les bancs de la majorité
ce sont exprimés et à ceux qui ont pris
position évidemment pour la réforme
alors notre collègue Cadic par exemple
sénateur des Français établis hors de
France
bien sûr c'était normal dans sa fonction
c'est amusé évidemment à faire une
petite comparaison européenne un peu
mondial aussi mais mondialement c'est
plus compliqué alors on va faire
européen et donc il nous a dit que la
France avec ses 62 ans semble aller
faire figure d'exception finalement face
à l'Espagne à l'Allemagne au Pays-Bas ou
à l'Italie mais finalement est-ce que
cette comparaison qui a la route alors
on a une réponse je vais convoquer
évidemment un directeur de recherche du
CNRS qui a travaillé sur ces questions
Bruno palier et il nous rappelle tout
simple c'est que des deux âges de départ
n'est que une question française et
qu'ailleurs en Europe il n'y a pas deux
âges de départ il y a un nombre de
trimestres de cotisation et des droits
qui sont liés à cela et donc je voudrais
vous le dire très simplement
vous avez effectivement deux âges de
départ et dans la plupart des autres
pays c'est deux âges n'existent pas dès
lors 10 directeur qui connaît juste un
peu la question il dit les comparaisons
sont totalement biaisées d'ailleurs sans
même bouger l'âge on arriverait alors ça
c'est le corps qui le dit qu'on
arriverait finalement assez rapidement
vers 64 ans de départ en retraite sauf
que avec on a la liberté de prendre
avant si on le souhaite la retraite avec
une décote et bien c'est cette liberté
monsieur Cadix vous qui est un libéral
vous devriez défendre cette notion de
joie bah j'ai fini alors je suis pas
libéral avec l'heure maintenant monsieur
Tissot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai bien
entendu Olivier Véran nous alerter sur
le risque d'une catastrophe écologique
agricole et sanitaire que nous ferait
courir la mobilisation massive contre
cette réforme de retraite il y a en
effet bien des urgences qui devrait nous
occuper aujourd'hui l'urgence en premier
écologique n'est plus à démontré mais ce
gouvernement qui a été condamné deux
fois pour une action climatique n'a pas
attendu le mot d'ordre de
l'intersyndical pour se mettre à l'arrêt
sur le sujet l'urgence sociale est bien
là aussi et ce n'est pas le projet de
loi indigence le pouvoir d'achat votez
l'été dernier qui aura répondu et dans
ce contexte de forte inflexion il est
23h51 nous sommes en direct sur le thème
de Public Sénat pour suivre toute la
soirée et une partie de la nuit
peut-être jusqu'au bout de la nuit elle
examen de l'article 7 vous savez sur le
report de la mesure d'âge effectivement
dans
réforme des retraites et on voit cette
longue liste d'orateurs qui sont
inscrits depuis maintenant de longues
minutes pour demander la suppression de
cet article alors comment accélérer les
débats on pourrait voir la majorité de
la droite et du centre on a usez bientôt
et bien de certaines armes du Règlement
du Sénat à suivre qui en 2010 a fait
passer l'âge de l'âge de départ des
infirmières du public de 55 à 62 ans 7
ans travaillant en plus auquel c'est
très fort va venir ajouter deux années
supplémentaires soit 9 ans de travail en
plus rajouter en l'espace de 13 ans on
est un peu au-delà de l'accompagnement
de l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
il me semble-t-il d'ailleurs celui-ci ne
progresse plus depuis 2014 et pendant ce
temps la charge en soins n'a fait
qu'augmenter les soignants sont très
souvent épuisés tant physiquement comme
moralement
bien avant la fin de leur carrière cela
pousse nombre d'entre eux à quitter
l'hôpital entraînant des vacances de
poche et de fortes difficultés à
recruter pensez-vous que vous redonnerez
ainsi de l'attractivité au métier du
soin et de l'accompagnement donc
effectivement non seulement cet article
7 ne répond pas à ces différentes
urgences mais je pense même qu'il va
plutôt en aggrader certaines aussi avec
cet amendements je vous propose de faire
oeuvre d'efficacité en supprimant tout
simplement cet article 7 madame Lubin
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai une question
jusqu'à quel âge pensez-vous que les
Français du moins un certain nombre
d'entre eux peuvent travailler
vous croisez tous les jours
tout un tas de personnes qui font des
métiers différents
les femmes de chambre dans les hôtels
infirmiers les aides soignants dans les
hôpitaux les gens que vous voyez en
train de réparer les routes tout ça vous
savez bien vous le savez bien qu'au-delà
de aller 60 ans ça devient compliqué
tout le monde le sait quand même et donc
et donc
[Musique]
si vraiment la situation parce que pour
l'instant je rappelle quand même que au
moment où on se parle là il y a pas de
déficit
des régimes de retraite si vraiment la
situation de devait empirer la situation
financière devait se compliquer
terriblement est-ce que vous pensez que
indéfiniment on pourra retarder l'âge de
la retraite non mais moi je vous pose
une question c'est quel modèle de
société que vous voulez alors vous vous
moquez beaucoup de nous là je vois si si
si si je vois que bon voilà vous n'avez
pas à porter grand chose au débat
jusqu'à maintenant les uns et les autres
par contre et vous êtes resté très
silencieux par contre là ce soir on sent
que vous voulez acheter et que pour vous
payer notre tête vous êtes là bon bref
passons nous nous avons apporté nous
avons essayé d'apporter parce que pour
comme on ne pourra pas indéfiniment
demander aux gens du moins à certains de
travailler plus nous avons essayer
d'apporter des idées parce que oui à un
moment si nous voulons conserver notre
modèle de retraite par répartition il
faudra bien trouver d'autres moyens il
faudra bien élargir l'assiette des
cotisations il faudra bien trouver
d'autres solutions voilà et donc bon
quel modèle de société voulez-vous
d'où nous au moins nous aimerions y
travailler c'est tout
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues alors
oui là nous sommes au cœur de cette
bataille pour le temps de vivre je
pourrais continuer à insister sur le
caractère unique de ce texte et vous
dire que effectivement et nous l'avons
tous dit cette présente réforme est
purement financière mais je préfère
exprimer ce qu'il finalement il aurait
pu être si vous aviez fait les choses
dans le bon ordre c'est-à-dire une
grande réflexion sur le travail et
ensuite un projet de loi sur les
retraites parce que finalement une
réflexion sur le travail dont la
retraite n'est que l'aboutissement nous
aurait permis de montrer que les
évolutions qui traversent le monde de
travail aujourd'hui sont très nombreuses
le véhicule législatif que vous avez
choisi ne nous le permet pas et c'est
très dommage en tout cas il faudra
arrêter et il faut arrêter de feindre
que la valeur du travail est uniforme
identique pour toutes et tous car dans
certains cas oui le travail peut être
synonyme de souffrance et d'aliénation
et dans d'autres cas de bien-être et de
reconnaissance mais les Français ne sont
pas les flemmards comme j'ai pu entendre
il suffit de regarder leur productivité
en revanche il y a une profonde
lassitude qui se nourrit à mon sens de
deux mots majeurs un avenir qui apparaît
de plus en plus incertain et une perte
de sens globale et sur ce point
l'exigence de jeunes générations ne
témoignent que d'une seule chose une
conscience aiguisée des défis et des
enjeux qui nous attendent pour beaucoup
ils ne veulent plus reproduire un modèle
qui ne leur convient plus et surtout qui
n'est pas soutenable alors on aurait pu
parler l'expérimentation organisation
des carrières correction des inégalités
votre réforme monsieur le ministre est
en tout cas une réforme désuète
déconnectée et elle n'est surtout pas à
la hauteur des enjeux de notre siècle
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vous vous en doutez du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
visent à ne pas décaler là je les garde
62 à 64 ans
monsieur le ministre la mobilisation
massive aujourd'hui vous oblige entendez
la colère des Français qui ne veulent
pas de cette réforme vous faites des
cadeaux fiscaux au plus riches et dans
le même temps vous créez un nouvel impôt
sur la vie des plus modestes le repas le
report de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite et
inutile et injuste
tout le monde n'a pas la chance d'avoir
un travail passionnant enrichissant
valorisant ce report est un nouvel
exemple de l'acharnement doctrinal d'un
exécutif qui ne peut s'empêcher de
détruire les acquis sociaux monsieur le
ministre malgré vos interventions
répétées dans les médias les Français ne
sont pas dupe les perdants ne se réforme
sont des millions et sont ces femmes et
ces hommes qui défilent dans les rues
ils sont celles et ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie qui se sont
levés tôt qui ont exercé des métiers
pénibles qui ont commencé toi qui n'ont
pas eu pour certains la chance de faire
des études ils sont celles et ceux qui
sont pourtant si utiles à la France mais
que vous pénalisez sans raison valable
monsieur le ministre il semble que de
vos engagements passés ne restent des
miettes avec cette réforme vous renoncer
à l'humanisme avec cette réforme vous
enterrer toute idée de progrès social
avec cette réforme le gouvernement
révèle si le fallait son vrai visage un
visage familier puisqu'il s'agit de
l'ultralibéralisme et de la politique
des plus aisés le silence complice de la
majorité sénatoriale en atteste c'est
main dans la main que l'exécutif et la
droite sénatoriale s'apprête à porter un
coup violent dans système de retraite
monsieur le ministre écoutez les
Français retirer cette réforme sur moto
G
c'est le Président chers collègues
monsieur le ministre nous nous opposons
au décalage de l'âge légal de 62 à 64
ans et nous ne se sent pas que la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme Touraine soit
accélérée malgré les messages que vous
font passer toutes les organisations
syndicales de salariés et plus de 8
Français sur 10 plus encore aujourd'hui
vous estimez à vouloir mener cette
réforme injuste qui est de fait un impôt
sur la vie alors que notre système de
retraite n'est pas menacé à long terme
et qu'il doit simplement faire face aux
conséquences du papy boom dans les
décennies 2030 à 2050 d'autres choix
sont possibles et pourtant vous refusez
d'envisager une légère augmentation des
cotisations patronales il suffirait
pourtant de 14 euros au niveau du SMIC
et de 28 euros au niveau du salaire
moyen pour combler le déséquilibre
temporaire vous auriez même pu et vous
auriez dû vous contenter d'une
surcotisation sur les plus hauts
salaires
et puis en plus d'être profondément
injuste et inutile cette réforme se
conjuguant à la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui réduit la durée
d'indemnisation et à celle du RSA va
précariser davantage les travailleurs
seniors qui voient leur durée
d'indemnisation chômage réduite de 8
mois et le RSA en seul perspective pour
survivre Sylvie au droit le nouvel
indicateur que devront publier les
entreprises sans aucune obligation
d'objectif ou de contrepartie de
résultats n'aura aucun effet amortisseur
sur cette paupérisation en marche des
travailleurs seniors pour toutes ces
raisons et bien d'autres retirer cette
réforme inique les Français vous en
seront gras
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comment
demander à travailler plus longtemps
alors que vous n'avez pas vraiment
commencez à regarder les problèmes de
pénibilité et que même vous avez
supprimé des critères de pénibilité
d'autre part plus d'un tiers des
retraités vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté après une vie de travail la
réforme ne viendra pas corriger cette
injustice sociale mais au contraire
ajoutera d'y arriver deux ans plus tard
plus abîmé pour certains parce qu'ayant
du poursuivre une activité inadaptée à
l'âge de leurs muscles de leurs artères
de leurs articulations de leur cœur il y
aura nombre de perdants et de perdants
quoi que vous en disiez un travailleur
en situation de pénibilité reconnu
partira deux ans plus tard du fait de la
réforme pour un début de carrière à 18
ans et un travail sans interruption
avant la réforme des parts à 62 ans
après la réforme 63 ans voilà la réalité
je rajoute qu'en 2010 le report de l'âge
en général de 60 à 62 ans c'est traduit
par une hausse de cent mille chômeurs
vous jouez vous avez choisi comme seul
levier la mesure d'âge alors que non
seulement il n'y a pas de réel problème
d'équilibre mais que le taux de chômage
des plus de 55 ans et plus que
préoccupant que ceux qui comment se taux
seront défavorisés et que les femmes
payeront le prix très élevé de cette
réforme votre réforme est archaïque
ouvrez les yeux le monde change les
Français aspirent à autre chose les
Français rêvent à d'autres vies la
société française bouge elle brise de
transformation souterraines que vous ne
voyez pas vous les désespérez par votre
réforme dans l'impossibilité de se
projeter dans un avenir heureux avec
l'instabilité que vous créez et nous
avons compris lors de l'examen de cette
loi que vous pensiez à une réforme à une
une réforme de retraite par point c'est
pourquoi mon amendement propose la
suppression
et à vous si vous passez oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
cet amendement de notre groupe vise à ne
pas décaler l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans
et de ne pas accélérer la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme Touraine monsieur le
ministre avec ce nouvel âge de départ à
la retraite injustifiée les conséquences
sont nombreuses la hausse de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits est un mauvais
paramètre de pilotage du système de
retraite si votre gouvernement sentait à
appliquer indifféremment à tous les
assurés les personnes ayant commencé à
travailler tôt seront encore une fois
les grands perdants au change 20 ans
depuis plus de 20 ans notre système de
retraite tant à substituer le critère de
l'âge à celui de la durée d'assurance
requise comme clé de voûte du système
pourtant c'est la durée d'assurance
requise qui permet une meilleure
individualisation des droits selon le
parcours professionnel
de mieux cibler les mécanismes de
solidarité notamment par l'octroi de
trimestres inversement le critère de
l'âge d'ouverture des droits demande de
créer des dispositifs dérogatoires dont
le calibrage n'est jamais satisfaisant
le gouvernement veut imposer un impôt de
deux ans sur la vie des travailleurs des
plus précaires et des plus fragiles une
autre réforme de retraite est possible
nous n'avons eu de cesse de le répéter
et ce n'est ni la manipulation des
chiffres présentés par le corps ni la
dissimulation de la vie qui a rendu le
Conseil d'État ni aucun de vos tours de
passe-passe qui réussiront à duper les
Français j'ai eu l'occasion d'assister à
de nombreuses comédies pourtant aucune
ni à la hauteur de celle interprétée par
le président et ses ministres le système
de retraite par répartition n'est pas
menacée et si le gouvernement plaçait
enfin ses efforts dans la création d'une
société plus juste une société où l'on
ajouterait à l'abondance de ceux qui ont
peu plutôt qu'à celle de ceux qui ont
moins nous avons saurions enfin dans la
bonne direction les Français ne croient
plus à vos mensonges votre réforme n'est
qu'une énième acte de
pitoyable comédie merci
monsieur le Président dans le droit fil
de ce que vient de dire monsieur
je constate que avec cette réforme les
personnes qui atteindront la durée
requises pour le taux plein avant l'âge
d'ouverture des droits devront
travailler au-delà du nombre de
trimestres nécessaires sans pouvoir
bénéficier de la surcote cela est déjà
le cas mais l'âge réel de départ en
retraite du fait de l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation et selon les
situations si ce n'est proches déjà
au-dessus des 62 ans cela sera bien
moins le cas avec un recul de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits 64 ans
inversement les personnes ayant commencé
à travailler plus tardivement et ayant
fait des études longues bénéficieront
davantage de la surcote puisqu'elles
atteindront la durée requise pour le
taux plein après l'âge légal
depuis plus de 20 ans notre système de
retraite tente à substituer le critère
de l'âge par celui de la durée
d'assurance requise comme clé de voût du
système la durée d'assurance requise
permet une meilleure individualisation
des droits selon les parcours
professionnels et elle permet de mieux
cibler plus facilement de surcroît les
mécanismes de solidarité notamment par
l'octroi de trimestre inversement le
critère de l'âge d'ouverture des droits
demande de créer des dispositifs
dérogatoires dont le calibrage n'est
jamais satisfaisant en un mot
pourquoi choisir la rigidité d'une norme
unique qui est préjudiciable plutôt que
la souplesse
la possibilité d'adaptation et de prise
en compte de la diversité des situations
que proposerait que permettrait un
système alternatif terreau
[Applaudissements]
président se ministre comme je suis
sénateur des Landes
je vais me permettre de citer Henri
manueli ça fera plaisir sur les bords de
la droite
Henri Emmanuelli qui en 2010 disait le
problème n'est pas d'une ampleur réelle
qu'il mérite que l'on remet en cause une
conquête sociale majeure
avant de déplacer l'âge de la retraite
il y a beaucoup d'autres possibilités
élargir l'assiette des cotisations entre
autres pourquoi faudrait-il mettre le
pire au départ je remarque que quand il
y a une frise une crise financière on
trouve facilement 20 milliards d'euros
sans problème je ne comprends pas quand
il s'agit de 10 milliards cela
deviendrait une catastrophe nationale
modifier l'âge et le pire c'est le pire
des symboles on ferait mieux de parler
du million de chômeurs qui va sortir de
l'indemnisation bon pour le million de
chômeurs qui va sortir d'analysation
monsieur le ministre c'est déjà fait
mais pour le reste pour le reste cette
phrase ne fait que traduire le titre
d'un très beau livre de Dardot et Laval
qui s'appelle la nouvelle raison du
monde et la nouvelle raison du monde on
l'a entendu tout à l'heure sur les bancs
de la droite le néo libéralisme c'est
une rationalité c'est inéluctable on
nous a parlé de la compétition de la
rationalité
et donc cette rationalité néolibérale
elle devient le seul modèle devant
lequel il faut se plier en tout cas le
seul modèle devant lequel vous vous
pliez c'est pour ça que le président
Retailleau nous a fait le discours
habituel de la responsabilité et du
sacrifice et dans ce cas de la
responsabilité du sacrifice les gens ne
comptent plus ils ne sont plus que des
instruments et c'est ça qui vous dérange
quand on cite telle ou tel les Français
ne vous intéressent pas prier
individuellement ils deviennent des
chiffres des chiffres qui ne sont pas
importants peu importe que à l'âge de la
retraite 25% des plus pauvres soient
déjà morts
plus rien ne compte il n'y a plus que
des con il faut conclure et bien je dis
pour faire un clin d'oeil à Michael
Valley retirer cette réforme injuste
beaucoup de triple comme au scrabble
madame
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc cet
amendement vise à supprimer l'article 7
du projet de loi qui veut décaler l'âge
légal de la du départ à la retraite de
62 à 64 ans depuis plusieurs semaines
les Françaises et les Français
témoignent avaient constance de leur
refus de cette réforme injuste
cristallisée par cet article 7 les
organisations syndicales sont unanimes
dans leur opposition le gouvernement
fait pourtant le choix de rester sourd à
ce front solide et de nier manifestation
après manifestation l'importance de la
mobilisation sociale plus de 3 millions
de personnes dans les rues aujourd'hui
comment pourra-t-on s'étonner après de
la défiance croissante de la population
envers le monde politique et nos
instances démocratiques face à un tel
passage en force je comprends très bien
pourquoi mes collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale approuvent cet article il
s'inscrit dans la continuité
d'amendement déposé chaque année au
PLFSS nous pouvons le reconnaître cette
constance et leur capacité à reconnaître
une réforme de droite pas du tout de
gauche monsieur le ministre du Travail
mais cette réforme paramétrique
uniquement poussée par une logique
comptable n'était pas le premier choix
du président de la République il avait
en réalité raison de déclarer en 2019
qu'on ne savait plus déjà quoi faire
après 55 ans et qu'il serait hypocrite
de décaler l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite sans avoir d'abord résolu la
question de l'emploi des seniors et non
ce n'est pas l'index senior qui
apportera cette réponse où le CDI seni
Nord introduit au Sénat nouveau cadeau
aux entreprises au détriment du
financement de notre système de
protection sociale rappelons qu'entre la
mi 2010 et 1000 2022 le nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'allocation chômage
âgée d'au moins 60 ans cet accrue de 100
000 que selon les derniers chiffres de
l'Insee le taux d'emploi des 60-74 ans
et deux fois plus faible que celui du
reste de la population se recul bructale
de l'âge légal engendra une hausse du
chômage chez les personnes seniors
et de cette loi
madame Carlotti oui merci monsieur le
Président cette amendement vise donc à
supprimer l'article 7 qui décalage légal
de 62 à 64 ans et augmente plus vite que
prévu le nombre d'années de cotisations
ces dispositions vont provoquer un choc
de précarité pour beaucoup de
travailleurs un des classements social
pour les personnes abîmées par de
longues années passées au travail tout
le monde se répertant et d'abord les
catégories populaires les plus
vulnérables ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 23 ans et ceux qui ont
du mal les conférences ici au Sénat nous
sommes en direct pour cette soirée
d'examen de l'article 7 de la réforme
des retraites pour en parler j'avais
Roger carochi bonjour vous êtes premier
vice-président LR du Sénat sénateur des
Hauts-de-Seine un mot sur ce qui se
déroule depuis 23 heures et c'est 77
amendements qui sont examinés d'une
traite déposée par la gauche sénatoriale
de suppression de cet article que ça
vous évoque
ça m'évoque ce que nous vivons depuis
cinq jours c'est à dire que
l'obstruction est manifeste la gauche
qui avait déposé 4000 amendements
multiplie les rappels règlements les
amendements
identiques des multipliés à l'infini bon
voilà c'est la définition exacte de
l'obstruction parlementaire la gauche
elle dit aussi qu'elle se fait le
porte-voix les côtes de cette
mobilisation très forte que l'on a vu
dans la journée qu'est-ce que ça a pu
se faire le porte-voix en disant deux
fois trois fois quatre fois la même
chose 77 fois la même chose on n'est
plus importants
alors est-ce qu'il nous ferait pas que
la droite prenne un peu la parole
justement pour un peu donner et bien des
arguments en faveur de cet âge décalé à
64 ans on vous a toujours pas entendu ou
très peu au tout début en introduction
sur sur cet article 7 pour une raison
simple c'est que nous nous suivons la
commission des affaires sociales qui
s’est exprimée à plusieurs reprises et
qui a expliqué pourquoi nous voterions
puisque c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous
avons voté au Sénat de manière régulière
depuis 2018 mais en revanche nous ne
tomberons pas dans le piège de la gauche
qui se dit si par un bonheur quelconque
la droite avait la bonne idée de nous
répondre de participer au débat que nous
multiplions et des multiplions et bien
nous n'arriverions pas à voter ce texte
dimanche soir puisque c'est la limite
dimanche 12 mars à minuit et nous nous
souhaitons voter ce texte il est donc en
avance il existe un règlement du Sénat
avec des articles qui permettent de
contraindre et qui permet aussi
d'accélérer les débats on pense par
exemple un article qui est le numéro 38
et qui limite à un orateur pour un
orateur contre dans la défense d'un
amendement est-ce que la droite pourrait
y avoir recours dans les prochaines
minutes
non
il est déjà tard et nous voulons d'abord
terminer cette succession de
d'avancement de suppression puisqu'il y
a un vote
un public pour en finir avec cette
litanie d'amendement ensuite
nous nous sommes disponibles moi je suis
en pleine forme si on veut qu'on reste
là jusqu'à 3-4 heures du matin pas
d'état d'âme en restant là on restera là
tranquillement pour en finir et donc
après et ensuite on va voir si la gauche
veut encore et encore
immobilisé le débat et faire de
l'obstruction ou si elle décide une fois
mener ce combat un peu symbolique pour
le 7 mars si elle accepte simplement
d'avancer dans le texte si clairement la
gauche dit nous on utilisera tous les
moyens
tous les moyens pour empêcher d'aller au
vote du texte il sera logique et normal
que la commission des affaires sociales
que le gouvernement que la majorité
sénatoriale utilise les moyens que lui
donne le règlement pour avancer Roger
carotier l'intersyndicale qui appelle ce
soir à être reçu en urgence par Emmanuel
Macron pour qu'il retire sa réforme
l'Elysée qui répond que l'exécutif a
toujours gardé ses portes ouvertes et on
le voit comme cela certains syndicales
qui maintient des nouvelles journées de
mobilisation samedi prochain pour la
prochaine la rue qui reste fortement
mobilisée contre cette réforme ça ne
vous fait pas vaciller dans votre
soutien à cette réforme non non vous
savez moi j'étais je soutenais
d'ailleurs à l'époque le gouvernement
Fillon lorsque 2010 la réforme qui a été
votée en 2010 pour passer de 60 à 62 ans
je rappelle que le 12 octobre 2010 3
millions de personnes étaient dans la
rue 3 millions de personnes et la
réforme même été votée par l'Assemblée
et le Sénat voilà je constate d'ailleurs
que 18 mois plus tard la gauche a gagné
les élections François Hollande est
devenu président de la République et la
réforme de 2010 passant de 60 à 62 ans
n'a jamais été remise en cause par la
gauche et on l'a dit déjà tout à l'heure
je pense que très tranquillement si nous
validons cette réforme qui passe 62 à 64
ans moi je prends le pari que si un jour
la gauche revient au pouvoir elle
conservera la réforme donc assez
d'hypocrisie et avançons pour justement
faire en sorte que dans cette réforme y
est un maximum d'accompagnement social
sur les carrières longues sur les maires
de famille sur les seniors etc un
dernier mot c'est ma dernière question
est-ce qu'il y a pas un danger pour
notre démocratie avec un tel écart entre
la démocratie parlementaire et la
démocratie sociale c'est une des
craintes de certains responsables
syndicaux je vais vous dire
si le Parlement
systématiquement écouté ou suivait
suivait l'opinion nous n'aurions jamais
aboli la peine de mort nous n'aurions
certainement pas voté le texte sur
l'avortement en 1975 etc etc
malheureusement parfois il faut accepter
une impopularité provisoire qui ensuite
s'atténue voir se transforme lorsque les
gens finissent par se dire finalement
c'était sans doute utile moi je n'ai
aucun plaisir à demander à ce que les
gens travaillent davantage quel
gouvernement a plaisir à dire je m'en
fiche je veux que vous travaillez
davantage c'est pas populaire et on le
sait mais quand c'est nécessaire pour
sauver les retraites sinon vous faites
quoi on baisse les retraites on augmente
les cotisations qui accepteraient
personne merci merci à vous et carochi
d'avoir répondu à mes questions en salle
des conférences on rejoint les mystiques
on est toujours au milieu de cette série
de 77 amendements de suppression de
l'article 7 des études d'évaluation des
statistiques
espérance de vie en bonne santé est
aujourd'hui de 67 ans pour les femmes
65,6 pour les hommes je crois que les
Français ont bien compris l'enjeu de
cette réforme on constate d'ailleurs que
les efforts de pédagogie mis en oeuvre
par le gouvernement donc fait que
renforcer leur opposition à cet article
7 et on recule de l'âge légal de départ
la retraite ils ont compris que les
logiques budgétaires qui vivent de cette
réforme repose au moins autant sur la
diminution de la durée du temps de
travail passé à la retraite que sur la
durée de l'augmentation des cotisations
c'est amendement je vous propose donc
tout simplement de le supprimer
madame meunier oui monsieur le Président
ils étaient 75000 à Nantes
17000 à Saint-Nazaire 8000 à
Châteaubriant 4000 à Ancenis j'ai pas
vraiment les chiffres de Clisson mais
ils étaient nombreux devant la gare la
Loire-Atlantique était mobilisée contre
le report de l'âge légal à la retraite à
64 ans je voudrais faire valoir ici les
arguments avancés par les représentants
et les représentants du secteur du
handicap ce secteur a exprimé sa forte
opposition à la réforme au travers d'une
tribune réunissant 52 associations
organisations du collectif handicap
voici ce qu'elles exprimaient début
février je les cite avec des taux de
chômage et de pauvreté largement
supérieures à la moyenne nationale une
fatigue habilité importante et des
carrières en d'Annecy les personnes en
situation de handicap fortement pénalisé
à l'âge de la retraite selon l'adresse
en moyenne les personnes en situation de
handicap reste 8 années et demi sans
emploi ni retraite après 50 ans contre
une année et huit mois pour les
personnes sans incapacité avec cette
réforme ces situations sans emploi ni
retraite vont se multiplier la précarité
va progresser pour ces métiers du
sanitaire et du social précisément dans
l'accompagnement au quotidien des
personnes en situation de handicap le
report va encore plus dégradé leur état
de santé déjà bien fragile avant l'âge
de la retraite qui va payer l'addition
l'assurance chômage la branche accident
du travail ce secteur subit déjà une
crise de recrutement sans précédent que
votre gouvernement renonce à prendre en
compte de façon ambitieuse par une loi
grand âge et autonomie qui fixeraient
comme objectif des soins et de
l'attention à hauteur de la dignité des
personnes accompagnées
merci me le Président je veux pas être
long parce que je crois que il y aura
plus aucun argument qui convaincra qui
que ce soit de toute façon mais je
voudrais faire suite merci pour ces
applaudissements nourris faudrait faire
suite à l'intervention du président
retaillau et à celle que j'ai fait tout
à l'heure pour exprimer mes craintes sur
les suites politiques de cette réforme
je voudrais rappeler à Bruno retaillod
que certes en 2010 vous avez fait passer
à un parmiet
recul de deux ans de l'âge légal mais
qu'en 2011 vous avez perdu les
sélections sénatoriales en 2012 vous
avez perdu la présidentielle et vous
n'êtes jamais revenu au pouvoir depuis
et on sait ce que sont ces conséquences
là ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
c'est que de ce réforme oui mais faire
ça il y a des conséquences politiques
derrière et que cette fois-ci les
conséquences politiques elles ne se
situeront pas nécessairement dans l'arc
républicain et vous le savez et vous le
savez c'est tout le problème c'est que
là l'exploitation politique des
conséquences de cette réforme c'est
d'autres qui sont et vous l'entendez
dans vos départements vous l'entendez
dans vos villes alors quel que soit
la justesse que vous estimez de celle de
cette réforme et j'entends je connais
votre raisonnement encore une fois
depuis longtemps et je le respecte et
vous le savez mais les conséquences elle
les dépassent largement et cette fois-ci
cette fois-ci je crains ce qui va se
passer derrière je crains ce qui se
passe dans notre pays vous pour
reprendre l'expression qu'a tenu
aujourd'hui un ancien Premier ministre
maître de l'attention dans un pays en
implosion est un risque sérieux voilà
donc il faut être raisonnable il faut
retirer cette réforme président kaner
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
féministe
je viens d'entendre notre collègue
Bernard jumier pour une fois je serai un
petit peu en décalage avec son analyse
ça peut arriver c'est rare mais ça peut
arriver puisque finalement
il vous mobilise dans une minorité mais
vous n'êtes plus vraiment minoritaire
vous êtes dans une coalition
et le chef de la Coalition c'est pas
l'Emmanuel Macron mais ça vous avez du
mal à le reconnaître manifestement alors
mes chers collègues puis que je parle du
président de la République
le nouveau monde ça vous dit
c'était il y a 70 mois
70 mois de d'Emmanuel Macron à la tête
de l'État et ce nouveau monde vient de
produire un projet de loi
qui est probablement le plus régressif
depuis la loi Fillon de 2010 et surtout
ce qui est absolument insupportable
monsieur les ministres si vous voulez
faire payer le désarmement fiscal du
pays à nos concitoyens
majoritairement frapper déjà par les
phénomènes de l'inflation et vous
considérez de manière cynique c'est à
eux de payer pour ce désarmement fiscal
et bien nous vous disons NON depuis six
jours nous considérons que ce n'est pas
la solution et que quand on vous dit non
ce n'est pas uniquement sur les quelques
bancs de gauche ici dans l'hémicycle de
la Haute Assemblée ce sont ces millions
de Français qui sont descendus dans la
rue et ces millions de Français qui
soutiennent toutes celles et tous ceux
qui sont descendus dans la rue alors mes
chers collègues bien vous avez compris
que à l'instar de ce que on dit les
autres collègues ici présents ils nous
demandons la suppression de l'article 7
je suis insuline
oui pour prolonger avec mes collègues
cette entêtement me rappelle quelque
chose et devrait d'ailleurs rappeler
quelque chose à quelques sénateurs ici
et notamment au premier d'entre eux qui
nous préside aujourd'hui dans cette
séance le président Larcher
souvenez-vous ce débat sur la loi
égalité des chances avec ce CPE qui
était niché dans cette loi et qui nous
avait occupé jour et nuit dans une
bagarre mémorable dans cette hémicycle
je me souviens que il y avait beaucoup
de monde dans la rue et que
manifestation après manifestation on
voyait bien que ça ne désemplissait pas
et que malgré les débats ici ou tous les
arguments étaient avancés sur le fait
qu'en réalité c'était pour sauver la
genèse et que la jeunesse ne comprenait
pas et se mobiliser toujours plus
massivement contre ce CPE souvenez-vous
vous avez été
humilié de faire ce travail parce que
souvenez-vous que vous n'avez pas écouté
la rue vous êtes mis en difficulté par
rapport aux jeunes et par rapport à vos
propres électeurs mais à la fin cette
loi a été votée
mais le président Chirac il ne l'a pas
appliqué
j'ai peur enfin pour vous qu'on puisse
être dans un scénario comme celui-là sur
la loi sur les retraites parce que si le
pays continue à se mobiliser comme il se
mobilise
ce sera intenable et c'est nous qui
devons être ce qui a l'air parce que
c'est nous qui avons le lien avec les
citoyens c'est vous qui retournez dans
vos circonscriptions et c'est vous qui
avez des comptes à rendre à tous ceux
qui sont parmi vos électeurs et qui sont
contre donc vous pouvez mesurer l'écart
qu'il y a entre ce que vous faites ici
pour le bien des citoyens et comment ils
le reçoivent et à la fin ça se finit
toujours mal en tous les cas j'espère
que vous même vous battrait cette
réforme et vous votre compte
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vise à ne pas décaler l'âge
légal de 62 64 ans et ne pas accéder
ne pas accélérer la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme Touraine la réforme proposée par
le gouvernement apparaît effectivement
injuste et particulièrement parce que là
je l'égale de départ de la retraite
serait décédé et que le nombre d'années
de cotisations
vous le disent ils sont profondément
opposés à cette réforme qui n'est ni
plus ni moins que le plus injuste des
impôts sur la vie notre système de
retraite n'est pas menacé à long terme
il doit simplement faire face aux
conséquences momentanées du papy boom
dans les décennies de 2030 à 2050 et
d'autres choix sont possibles ils ont
été longuement exposés ici depuis le
début de nos débats
de plus en se conjuguant à la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui réduit la durée
de l'indemnisation et à celle du RSA
cette réforme va précariser les
travailleurs seniors qui voient leur
durée d'indemnisation chômage réduite de
8 mois et non donc plus que le RSA pour
vivre si bien sûr ici en droit qui peut
croire raisonnablement que ce que
propose le gouvernement dans sa réforme
est un quelconque qui est fait
amortisseur sur cette paupérisation en
marche des travailleurs seniors ce
projet de loi de régression sociale
apparaît inacceptable c'est une réforme
injuste
inutile et inefficacité donc ici de
supprimer l'article de ce projet
même la présidence Rossignol merci
monsieur le Président j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure l'Inter syndical
non pas que je veux absolument
parole dans cette hémicycle mais pour
connaître le mouvement social le
mouvement syndical le plus de nombreuses
années je sais mesurer ce que signifie
un mouvement syndical uni dans un moment
comme celui qu'on vit et je sais aussi
ce que signifie la mobilisation de 1
million 500 000 à 3 millions de
personnes contre une réforme
l'intersyndicale s'est réunit ce soir
elle a donné ses nouvelles
préconisations je vais vous les lire
je pense que c'est pas inintéressant
pour vous non plus même si vous les
soutenez pas c'est toujours bien de
savoir ce que font les autres le 16
février face à l'absence de réponse du
gouvernement l'intersyndicale a amené
appeler à mettre la France à l'arrêt
cette mars c'est une journée historique
par l'ampleur de ses gravés de ces
mobilisations à ce jour c'est
mobilisations énormes conduites par une
interne de syndicaturique uni non reçu
aucune réponse de la part du
gouvernement cela ne peut plus durer le
silence du président de la République
constitue un problème démocratique grave
qui conduit un manquablement à une
situation qui pourrait devenir explosive
en responsabilité l'Inter syndicale
c'est très représentant de la République
l'intersyndicale appelle à une nouvelle
mobilisation interprofessionnelle ce
samedi 11 mars puis la semaine prochaine
à une manifestation le jour de la
commission mix paritaire elle appelle la
population à continuer à mobilisation et
les actions encore plus massivement pour
dire non à cette réforme injuste et
brutale
voyez-vous
cette inter syndicale elle prend la foi
la responsabilité de continuer
d'accompagner le mouvement social et
nous nous devons être à la hauteur de
cette responsabilité monsieur le
ministre vous ne pouvez pas continuer de
ne pas répondre au mouvement social et à
l'intersyndical et nous chers collègues
en votant nos amendements de suppression
de l'article 7 nous permettrions à tout
le monde de sortir la tête haute de
cette affaire madame la Présidente
oui merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues mesdames Messieurs
les messieurs encore les membres du
gouvernement je crois qu'il n'y a aucune
mais vraiment strictement aucune donnée
chiffrique qui permet de justifier que
l'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans ainsi que
l'allongement des trimestres de
cotisation et nécessaire nous en avons
déjà fait la démonstration lors de nos
précédents débats je crois que nous
sommes assez offensif et nous
continuerons donc à dire et à proposer
que des économies et à dire que des
économies peuvent être réalisés ailleurs
sans porter atteinte au régime actuel de
retraite selon la l'Institut national
d'étude démographique l'espérance de vie
doit aussi être appréciée en tenant
compte de l'âge auquel il y a un vrai
risque d'incapacité dans les gestes de
la vie quotidienne ce concept rejoint en
quelque sorte celui de l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé que nous défendons et
bien super collègues cette espérance de
vie prenant en compte l'incapacité à
effectuer les gestes de la vie
quotidienne se situent en France à
64,1 an pour les femmes et
62,7 ans pour les hommes la réforme donc
actuelle qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement avec la complicité de la
droite sénatoriale aggrave le risque de
liquider les pensions de retraite à un
âge où le retraité n'est plus où la
retraité n'est plus en mesure de
profiter comme il ou elle le
souhaiterait du fruit de son labeur nous
maintenons donc que votre projet est
celui de la destruction sociale et après
ce que ce qui vient d'être vient d'être
dit par Madame Rossignol je le répète il
faudrait peut-être que vous entendiez à
la fois ce qui s'est dit exprimé
aujourd'hui dans les rues des villes et
qu'elles soient petites moyennes ou
grande et que vous écoutiez aussi et que
vous sachiez lire le communiqué le
communiqué de la terre syndicale
un homme Brulin
merci monsieur le Président avec cette
article 7 il s'agit en effet du recul de
l'âge de la retraite et de
l'accélération de la hausse des durées
de cotisation qui sont censées réduire
ou lutter contre les déficits de notre
système de protection sociale au passage
monsieur le ministre quand vous nous
dites tout à l'heure
que l'âge de départ sans décote sera
maintenu à 67 ans et ne sera pas à 69
ans j'espère que vous n'imaginez pas que
les Français vous remercient largement
parce que vous risquez d'être encore un
peu déçu au passage toujours je trouve
quand même assez inquiétant de constater
que
en fait la politique c'est
identifier des problèmes et il apporter
des réponses et si certains d'entre vous
sont assis à la droite de cette
hémicycle d'autres à la gauche de cette
hémicycle c'est que nous avons des
options différentes pour répondre à des
problématiques que nous pouvons parfois
identifier ensemble or je vois que
beaucoup ici
préféreraient un passage en force qu'un
débat sur des solutions alternatives à
ce report de l'âge de la retraite et les
Français le sentent bien qu'on leur
refuse ce débat c'est ça aussi qu'il
aimait de plus en plus nombreux dans la
rue parce que voilà un débat de société
au sens noble du terme qui pourrait
faire en sorte que nos concitoyens
renouent avec la politique mais vous la
refusez encore une fois certains d'entre
vous préféreraient passer en force et
enfin puisqu'il s'agit de prétendus
déficit j'ai eu l'occasion tout à
l'heure de montrer en quoi le coût
social de ce report de l'âge allait être
la conséquent sur la vie associative
démocratique dans nos communes etc je
pense qu'il leur sera aussi en termes de
pure des pensées sociales par
l'augmentation des arrêts de travail par
la baisse du niveau de pension qui va
faire en sorte que de nouvelles dépenses
sociales vont devoir être déployées pour
empêcher que des retraités dans la
pauvreté et donc je crois qu'il n'est
absolument pas question d'économie avec
ce projet
tu es gentil
nous sommes en direct sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat la chaîne qui bouleverse
ces programmes pour suivre au plus près
l'examen de l'article 7 sur la mesure
d'âge de la réforme des retraites nous
arrivons dans les 10 dernières prises de
parole sur ces amendements de
suppression de l'article 7 retournant
l'émission le taux d'emploi des seniors
et de 35 %. donc allonger la durée
créera des retraités pauvres vous nous
dites c'est pas le sujet on vous a
proposé de financer autrement
t'accélérer riche non les dividendes
sûrement pas élargir l'assiette pas
possible gagner la bataille de l'emploi
attendez la loi travail l'égalité
salariale c'est la grande cause du
quinquennat vous allez voir taxer la
rente sûrement pas vous allez tuer le
ruissellement on vous a dit vous avez
une question démocratique vous êtes
minoritaire 3,5 millions de travailleurs
et de travailleuses dans la rue vous
avez assumé monsieur le ministre on
assume d'être impopulaire et donc pour
vous une seule solution deux ans de plus
deux ans qui vont peser sur les classes
populaires les essentiel très utile
celles et ceux qui ont tenu le pays à
bout de bras pendant le covid ceux qui
ont des carrières arrachées les horaires
décalés ceux qui triment et que le
travail concasse le cœur et les esprits
mais vous vous nous parlez justice
travailler
alors que pour nous il faudrait partager
partager le travail le savoir et les
richesses enfin si vous n'êtes pas
convaincu un dernier
argument est-ce que vous pensez
sincèrement que c'est le moment même
Olivier Véran l'a dit
occupons-nous d'abord de l'inflation du
prix de l'électricité des salaires de
l'emploi de la formation et de la
réindustrialisation du pays avant de
voler les deux plus belles années des
retraites seul le ministre il est temps
de battre en retraite et de retirer
votre projet de loi
tu es Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président tout à
l'heure le Président rotaïo nous a dit
quelque chose qui était faux
nous a dit depuis 40 ans personne n'est
revenu sur une réforme des retraites qui
avait été votée c'est faux en 1981 il y
a 40 ans la gauche a voté une réforme
historique qui a passé l'âge de départ à
la retraite de 65 ans à 60 ans c'était
une des réformes qui ont marqué le
siècle oui qui ont marqué un siècle de
progrès sociaux comme les congés payés à
une certaine époque comme la réduction
de la journée du temps de travail à
d'autres etc donc il y a eu un progrès
historique et la vérité c'est qu'on va
être vous ne l'avez jamais accepté donc
ensuite on a eu le droit à Baladur en 93
à Fillon en 2003 et Sarkozy en 2010 et
les 62 ans c'est déjà vous c'est vous
les 62 ans c'est vous qui avez institué
les 62 ans en 2010 et aujourd'hui vous
voulez passer à 64 ans
et si vous étiez resté au pouvoir si
vous étiez resté au pouvoir sans
discontinuer on discuterait pas 62 ou 64
on serait toujours restés à 65 et on
serait probablement à 67 aujourd'hui
parce que vous auriez rajouté deux ans
comme dodo dans d'autres pays européens
donc en vérité ce projet-là c'est votre
projet depuis toujours et le et ce qu'on
a entendu de la part du rapporteur
Savary qui s'éclipse au moment où je
parle de lui c'est une fable c'est une
fable l'idée
l'idée
l'idée que vous êtes finalement obligé
d'en poser les 64 ans parce qu'on a fait
les 40 parce que toi Marisol Touraine a
fait les 43 nuts c'est de la blague en
vérité depuis 1980 votre rêve c'est de
revenir à 65 ans et aujourd'hui vous
progressez alors effectivement monsieur
Retailleau a raison c'est une réforme de
droite à laquelle le gouvernement
aujourd'hui sera lit qu'il met en oeuvre
que vous allez soutenir cette réforme
elle est à contretemps elle est
archaïque elle sera combattue par le
Slimane elle ne sera pas appliquée
madame lilleman
chers
jouer avec le feu
c'est bien entendu l'argumentaire de
votre président de groupe monsieur
Retailleau
son argumentaire c'est
nous avons le courage de faire des
réformes impopulaires
parce que nous savons mieux que le
peuple ce qui est bon pour la nation
alors on le fait une fois
et puis on le fait deux fois et puis on
croit qu'on va pouvoir continuer comme
ça
pendant des lustres pas figurez-vous que
non pour une raison simple c'est que la
première fois les Français ils peuvent y
croire vous allez sauver le système de
répartition vous allez répondre au
problème de du temps et les choses vont
être meilleures pour la nation
et puis il se rendent compte que réforme
après réforme c'est pire pour eux c'est
pire pour le pays donc il ne vous croit
plus
il ne vous croit plus et jamais dans
l'histoire le général de Gaulle nous
aurait eu comme raisonnement
oui oui
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
chaque fois
chaque fois que le général de Gaulle a
eu un doute
eu un doute sur le soutien des Français
il a été devant le peuple il a fait un
référendum vous vous avez peur de faire
cela
elle est conséquente de ses attitudes
elle est
conséquence de ces attitudes
accumuler dans le temps où vous
terrorisez que la bonne politique c'est
celle qui doit être faite contre le
peuple est la même le peuple à
s'abstenir elle amène le peuple à
accumuler la colère elle amène le peuple
à se démoraliser sur l'avenir de la foi
elle amène le CUP vers l'extrême droite
merci monsieur ouzulias
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre j'ai posé une
question et j'ai pas eu de réponse donc
vous vous me permettrez de reposer ma
question elle est très simple lors de la
campagne électorale le président de la
République avait expliqué que le recul
de l'âge de 2 ans permettrait de
financer un minimum retraite à 1200
euros pour tout le monde on sait
aujourd'hui que seul si si je peux je
peux vous redonner les propos de
Monsieur Macron on sait maintenant que
seuls 10000 à 20000 retraités pourront
en bénéficier je vous repose donc une
nouvelle fois la question quel est le
gain budgétaire de cette réforme des
retraites les économistes évaluent à
0,6% du PIB le surcroît de recettes
budgétaire dans 10 ans est-ce que vous
nous confirmez maintenant cette
évaluation et je pense chers collègues
qu'il faudrait prendre conscience comme
la dit très bien le président retaillot
qu'il s'agit aussi d'une réforme
budgétaire c'est un point c'est très
important que français sache que là on
est en train de discuter d'un nouvel
impôt Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président est-ce que ça va le délit
merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues commencez par ça
vous a pas échappé de temps en temps on
a eu des comparaisons
tiens je vais vous parler de l'Allemagne
pour vous faire vibrer dans votre
enthousiasme le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale un chiffre 20%
c'est le taux de pauvreté c'est le taux
de pauvreté des retraités en Allemagne
et puis allez c'est le même en Irlande
et pourtant l'âge de départ est à 66 ans
soit 10% de plus qu'en France
60% c'est le pourcentage de pays ayant
fait machine arrière après avoir
privatisé leur régime de retraite
diminution du taux de couverture baisse
des allocations de retraite aggravation
des inégalités de gens et de revenus
c'est-à-dire croyez la comparaison
européenne ces charges la preuve
y compris par y compris des droites
libérales excusez-moi de le dire mais
par des droites libérales
la deuxième chose c'est que tout à
l'heure on a eu la confirmation d'autres
collègues non affirmé mais là on a un
moment de clarification politique
le président Retailleau a été très clair
il a dit c'est une réforme de droite
donc nous sommes en train de discuter du
dréforme de droite et ça m'a fait penser
on a tous des loisirs etc j'ai pensé au
formidable film
le salaire de la peur
où il y a 4 aventuriers qui parlent
cupidité s'en vont à défier la nature là
on était dans les critères de pénalité
est-ce qu'on vient de vivre depuis jeudi
par le vote de la droite de la première
partie de la loi et par la défense de
rajouter deux années de plus vous êtes
en train de nous proposer de proposer
aux Français la retraite de la peur pour
les obliger à rentrer dans la
capitalisation voilà l'enjeu de cette
réforme merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
minis 70% des Français et plus de 90%
des salariés nous le savons sont opposés
à ce report de 62 et 64 ans de l'âge de
départ à la retraite le président de la
République avance qu'il faut que les
Français travaillent plus nous proposons
quand à nous qu'il travaille tous ce qui
permettrait d'abander les caisses des
assurances sociales avec les cotisations
nouvelles la dernière réforme
paramétrique des retraites qui fait
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite de
60 à 62 ans évoqué par Pierre Laurent
tout à l'heure imposé par Nicolas
Sarkozy en 2010 a eu pour conséquence
selon l'inédith de plonger 100 000
signons dans le chômage de longue durée
entre 2010 et 2022 il ne s'agit pas on
peut le dire d'une brillante réussite
imaginons un métallurgie sous un salarié
à la chaîne chez Renault qui travaille
souvent en 3,8 continué à occuper un
poste de travail dans une entreprise à
64 ans une infirmière me disait
récemment j'ai terminé la carrière
professionnelle par un arrêt maladie
suite à un burnout et une période de
chômage de deux ans comment une
infirmière une aide-soignante pourra
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans voire plus
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
c'est augmenter la période de non emploi
des seniors pour les seniors risquant de
ne pas toucher d'indemnités de chômage
durant ces années ils seront poussés
vers les minima sociaux qui ne
permettent pas de vivre dignement est-ce
là la description d'une réforme de
gauche monsieur le ministre je ne crois
pas et si ce n'est pas l'indigeant index
seniors voter dans l'article 2 de votre
loi qui risque d'inciter les entreprises
à garder les plus de 60 ans dans leurs
effectifs l'allongement des carrières va
immanquablement provoquer un sur chômage
chez les salariés les plus âgés qui
risquent plus de ne pas avoir une
carrière complète ce qui aura un impact
négatif sur leur pension future faire
basculer les dépenses de retraite sur
les indemnités de chômage est une
politique qui n'a aucun sens d'un point
de vue économique pour toutes ces ondes
bien évidemment nous demandons la
merci
nous en avons terminé avec les
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune je vais s'il vous
plaît je vais consulter la commission
avis de la commission
bien merci monsieur le Président
j'attendais effectivement
mon tour pour donner la vie de la
commission après tous ces amendements à
répétitifs
qui font pour certains tableaux de la
valeur travail particulièrement
apocalyptique il y a encore des gens
quand même qui je pense voit les choses
différemment
Monsieur Laurent Monsieur Laurent vous
avez dit que certains rêvaient un âge de
retraite à 64 ans mais Monsieur Laurent
moi la retraite à 60 ans pour moi c'est
un cauchemar ça veut dire qu'on n'aime
pas le système par répartition ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas vu la société la
société vieilli Monsieur Laurent il y a
de moins en moins de naissance la
longévité telle que la retraite
l'espérance de vie dure de plus en plus
longtemps et si vous voulez prendre des
mesures qui vont plomber le système par
répartition c'est que vous n'aimez pas
la répartition j'ai écouté aussi
monsieur Sueur monsieur Sueur qui a fait
une explication tout à fait intéressante
mais qui pense que en travaillant
effectivement plus sur la durée et bien
on pourrait peut-être rendre les gens
les plus heureux et bien non on sait que
plus la durée on travaille sur la durée
les 43 ans ça fait les conséquences
c'est qu'il y a une diminution de la
pension moyenne calculée à une heure de
300 euros lisez les trucs d'impact je
n'ai rien inventé donc ça veut dire que
vous n'aimez pas les retraités que vous
voulez faire des retraités pauvres c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me tourne
vers ce banc l'un de l'hémicycle
ce banc là de l'émission pense qu'il
faut jouer sur le niveau de l'âge légal
mes chers collègues vous avez raison
vous avez raison parce que ces eux le
seul moyen dans un système pas
répartition de faire en sorte qu'on
arrive à élever le niveau des pensions
faire en sorte qu'on puisse dégager des
recettes supplémentaires et qu'on puisse
faire plus de solidarité mais vous
n'aimez pas la solidarité donc et nous
nous aimons la solidarité
et nous aimons la solidarité et nous
voudrions bien la proposer aux Français
non pas à travers des discours mais à
travers des actes ce sont les articles
suivants qui viennent pour les maires de
famille vous en parlez beaucoup nous
agissons
pour l'usure professionnelle
ah je vous ai taquiné pour l'usure
professionnelle nous avons des mesures
pour la retraite progressive nous avons
des mesures en conséquence il serait
temps monsieur le Président que nous
puissions passer dans l'examen du sexe
les Français attendent de nous que l'on
donne un peu plus de justice sociale à
ce texte il en manque un peu messieurs
les ministres un peu plus de justice
sociale à travers les divers
dispositions que nous souhaiterions
vivement examinés voilà vous l'avez
compris mes chers collègues la vie sera
défavorable de la part de la Commission
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
en donnant la vie du gouvernement qui
sera défavorable en réponse aux 70
amendements de suppression je ne
reprendrai pas les arguments très
synthétiques qui ont été évoqués par
Olivier du soft mais je donnerai
quelques principes qui concernent la
fonction publique les agents de la
fonction publique qui sont effectivement
inclus dans cet article 7 et en le
faisant je veux me réjouir que
dans cette chambre on puisse débattre de
la situation des agents de la fonction
publique parce que cela n'avait pas été
possible à l'Assemblée nationale et je
pense que c'était dommage de ne pas
évoquer au fond les principes qui
concernent les agents de la fonction
publique et qui sont majoritairement
dans cet article 7 d'abord je le ferai
de façon monsieur le Président très
synthétique pour aller plus vite sur
ensuite explication sur les différents
amendements d'abord un principe d'équité
je crois que les Français n'auraient pas
compris que les mesures plus fort qui
concerne les salariés du privé ne soient
pas demandés de façon absolument
symétrique aux agents de la fonction
publique ce sera le cas pour l'âge
d'ouverture des droits ce sera le cas
pour l'accélération de la durée de
cotisation ensuite un principe de
cohérence nous avons préservé et
conserver les caractéristiques
fondamentales du système de retraite
pour les agents de la fonction publique
sur le calcul sur les six derniers mois
calcule sur la rémunération indiciaire
des fonctionnaires ce que nous
conservons aussi c'est le principe des
catégories actives à tout point de vue
nous en conservons le principe mais nous
conservons aussi la durée de service
pour les catégories actives et Olivier
du stop l'a rappelé pour les catégories
actives comme pour les agences
sédentaires nous ne modifions pas l'âge
d'annulation de la décode c'est le cas
pour tous les agents de la fonction
publique et puis le troisième principe
est un principe de progrès parce que en
supprimant cet article 7 ce sont des
améliorations du système et des progrès
pour les fonctionnaires contre lequel
vous voteriez je veux en mentionner de
façon très rapide trois qui sont
contenus dans ce texte d'abord la
portabilité des droits pour les agents
publics qui sont dans les catégories
actives la situation actuelle c'est que
si vous changez de métier quand vous
êtes policier que vous devenez par
exemple douanier ou agent de la
pénitentiaire vous perdez tout le
bénéfice de vos années passées en tant
que policier ou dans la fonction
publique pénitentiaire et bien grâce à
l'article 7 nous mettons fin à cette
situation injuste plus injuste encore
en votant contre l'article 7 vous
viendriez voter contre une mesure quelle
est la suppression de la clause
d'achèvement la suppression de la clause
d'achèvement ça peut paraître technique
quand on le dit comme ça mais c'est un
principe qui existe dans le système de
retraite actuel qui consiste à faire en
sorte que vous ne bénéficiez des mesures
qui concernent les catégories actives
si vous terminez votre carrière en tant
que catégorie actif c'est-à-dire dans le
métier pénible c'est à dire tout
l'inverse de ce que nous devons faire
pour aménager les fins de carrière et
bien dans cet article 7 on le votant
vous allez supprimer la clause
d'achèvement ce citerai une troisième
amélioration elle concerne les
contractuels de la fonction publique 20%
des agents publics aujourd'hui les
contractuels qui aujourd'hui font
parfois le même métier que les agents
publics qui sont intégrés actives mais
qui ne bénéficient pas des mesures de
protection qui concernent les agents des
catégories actives et bien avec
l'article 7 vous feront vous ferez en
sorte que les agents contractuels dès
lors qu'ils seront titularisés dans la
fonction publique ils verront leurs
années passées en tant que contact
actuel parfois 5 ans parfois 6 ans je
pense au plus de 100 000 agents
contractuels qui sont des
aides-soignants à l'hôpital et bien vous
ferez en sorte que ces années passées
elles contront et elles seront intégrées
dans les années de service quand ils
seront intitulé La réserves en fonction
publique voilà des avancées qui sont
inclus dans l'article 7 et autant de
bonnes raisons de donner un avis
défavorable aux amendements de
suppression de ce même article 7
du gouvernement avis des favorable de la
commission j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public
par la commission les groupes
communistes républicains citoyen
écologie le groupe socialiste et le
groupe écologiste solidarité et est
territoire je rappelle qu'il porte sur
les amendements identiques de
suppression d'explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le Président mais je
voudrais dire au rapporteur qui était
pas avec nous toute la nuit hier mais
que des amendements de solidarité on en
a posé un certain nombre qu'ils ont été
tous balayés mais oui nous aimons la
solidarité la vraie celle qui fait payer
ceux qui profitent le plus alors j'ai
déjà expliqué la la situation de blocage
démocratique dans laquelle nous étions
ce soir et vous avez commencé ce débat
hier et avant-hier pour refuser tout
autre mode de financement alternatif
avec logique du travail et plus
pour les français pour les travailleurs
vous éloignez une fois de plus l'horizon
du répit avec cette réforme du décalage
de l'âge de départ à la retraite
l'horizon de la vie enfin sortie de la
course à la production pour nous
écologistes cette réforme va donc à
rebours de tous les enjeux du moment de
tous les enjeux du siècle et je veux
reprendre les propos de d'Olivier Véran
vous avez d'autres urgences à gérer nous
avons deux urgences à gérer le défi
climatique doit être la priorité absolue
qui devrait nous mobiliser qu'il
renouvelisé ici soir et weekend s'il le
faut mais qu'il aurait une neomusé
beaucoup plus que cette réforme visant à
faire travailler toujours plus
travailler plus c'est trop dur plus
c'est extraire plus c'est polluer plus
faites pour servir un modèle économique
insatiable des structures du climat
cette réforme des retraites va à rebours
de l'urgence la vraie les rapports du
corps sont beaucoup moins inquiétants
que les rapports du GIEC beaucoup moins
précis sur l'avenir aussi beaucoup moins
implacable sur notre destin commun si la
retraite par répartition doit être
renforcée c'est parce que c'est un
système de solidarité entre les
générations et si nous devons repenser
nos modes de production et notre rapport
au travail c'est aussi dans une logique
intergénérationnelle de protection des
générations futures votre réforme
participe à une logique qui épuise
l'humain et la planète en visant des
objectifs insoutenables de croissance
fini dans un monde infini non l'inverse
dans une croissance infinie dans un
monde fini c'est pourquoi nous sommes
écologistes et nous refusons votre
logique obsolète et appelons à la
suppression de cet article que Monsieur
Breuillet
voilà nous avons eu 77 amendements de
suppression qui ont été présentés il y a
institut et la vie de la commission la
vie du gouvernement on passe maintenant
aux explications de vote chaque sénateur
dispose d'une explicat de 2 minutes et
on voit que de nombreux sénateurs de
gauche s'inscrivent pour ces
explications de maths
et c'est donc une réforme pour les
femmes
c'est donc une réforme pour les
fonctionnaires
c'est donc une réforme pour les jeunes
c'est donc une réforme pour les ouvriers
pour les infirmières pour les
aides-soignants pour tous les métiers
pénibles mais ni les femmes ni les
fonctionnaires ni les jeunes ni les
infirmières ni les aides-soignants ni
tous ceux qui ont un métier pénible ne
la soutiennent quel ingratitude quel
ingratitude de ce peuple qui refuse une
réforme de progrès que vous nous
présentez et non seulement ils ne disent
pas seulement comme monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable ils disent
retraites
[Applaudissements]
c'est un rappel aux règlements monsieur
le Président à partir c'est sur la base
de l'article 38 77 amendements de
suppression tous
identique monsieur le Président je
demande cette application
donc je suis saisi par Monsieur
autaillou président de groupe
de clôture sur les explications de vote
sur les amendements numéro 3 à 2268 en
application de l'article 38 de notre
règlement la clôture peut être proposée
lorsque au moins deux orateurs c'est le
cas Davy contraire sont intervenus et je
peux donner les paroles si le souhaitent
à un opérateur par groupe crâne
pardonnez-moi un orateur par groupe et
c'est la Turquie figure sur la liste
donc un groupe qui souhaite prendre la
parole
monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
après avoir entendu la litanie des
orateurs qui sont succédés pour plaider
pour plaider
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'arguments
similaires
qui se sont succédés je me dis que
j'aimerais bien être petite souris à la
prochaine réunion du Parti socialiste
européen parce que j'ai entendu
description de l'Apocalypse
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme et
se faisant vous disqualifiez aussi des
gens comme prémunistes Costa le
président Sanchez qui ont conduit ce
type de réforme et donc eu gouverne eux
ont été réélus eux ont assumé et c'est
je crois là une grande différence avec
effectivement votre positionnement
Lionel Jospin est-il revenu sur la
réforme Balladur non
François
Hollande est-il revenu sur la réforme
werthe non il a quelques petits
aménagements
reviendrez-vous sur l'article 7 s'il est
voté la réponse est non vous l'avez
d'ailleurs décrit comme une sorte
d'impôt sur la vie on sait bien que les
impôts vous les baissez jamais et donc
vous ne reviendrez jamais naturellement
là-dessus alors je vais paraphraser le
collègue Lucien Stanzione qui disait
ayez du courage et bien ayez du courage
retirer ses amendements de suppression
parce que vous ne reviendrez pas dessus
et donc pour le groupe RDPI en tout état
de cause nous votre compte parce que ces
grands écarts permanents non seulement
ça fait mal aux adducteurs mais ça fait
mal à la confiance dans la politique je
rappelle que nous sommes sur un débat de
clôture madame la Présidente donc j'ai
compris que vous étiez favorable à la
clôture en même temps voilà madame merci
monsieur le président je pourrais dire
nous ne sommes pas surpris par cette
proposition de clôture de notre
discussion elle parcourt quand même les
couloirs du Sénat depuis quelques heures
maintenant parmi d'ailleurs d'autres
rumeurs qui circulent qui circulent
aussi
ce recours je vous le dis sincèrement se
recourt à cette procédure est un acte de
faiblesse de la part de la droite
sénatoriale c'est une marque de
fébrilité qui parcourt vos rang comme
elle parcourt les rangs du gouvernement
je au nom d'une soi-disante obstruction
que nous en petite musique que nous
entendons depuis depuis le début depuis
le début de l'examen de ce projet de loi
vous usez d'une procédure monsieur le
Président qui est peu usité ici au Sénat
et ce à quelques heures d'une magnifique
mobilisation dans le pays et l'annonce
d'une autre grande mobilisation
samedi prochain monsieur Lemoine nous
avons du courage
mais vous vous perdez votre sang-froid
avec ce coup de force
que nous dénonçons je le dis aussi
crûment que je le pense cette procédure
est une attaque contre la démocratie et
les droits du Parlement ce n'est pas
digne du Sénat monsieur le Président
alors parce que nous avons besoin de
maîtriser parce que nous avons besoin de
mépriser l'ordre du jour
où l'organisation des débats dans les
prochaines heures nous demandons avec
les présidents de gauche c'est-à-dire
moi-même le président le cadener et le
président en compta la Réunion immédiate
d'une conférence des présidents
nous poursuivons monsieur le Président
Retailleau
[Applaudissements]
pour indiquer que bien entendu de votre
ampoule la clôture puisque cela fait 5
jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à faire
à une obstruction je voudrais dire
que l'obstruction c'est la négation du
rôle du Parlement bien sûr le rôle du
Parlement c'est de débattre mais de
débattre pour voter on a été lu non pas
pour faire des groupes de parole mais
pour voter
l'obstruction c'est une sorte d'auto
effacement d'auto des saisissements du
Parlement vous allez refuser puisque on
va intra d'escargot de voir et de voter
sur l'ensemble du texte par exemple sur
les petites retraites par exemple sur
l'usure professionnelle par exemple sur
le handicap au travail et bien nous nous
voulons je crois que choisir de ne pas
voter c'est choisir de ne pas peser
méfiez-vous bien que l'obstruction ne
mène pas à alimenter l'anti
parlementarisme parce que les Français
vont constater qu'à force de discuter le
Parlement ne sert à rien oui
affirme je l'affirme l'obstruction est
au Parlement ce qu'une désertion est un
soldat la négation même de sa mission
que le président Kader
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président
oserais-je dire honte à vous
honte à vous
vous êtes laissés bâillonner par le 47 1
de la Constitution et le gouvernement et
vous voulez maintenant bâillonner votre
position c'est un scandale
[Applaudissements]
l'article 38 n'a jamais été utilisé sans
faire de ma part dans cette hémicycle
vous le faites parce que vous aviez
incapable de défendre vos arguments tout
au long de ces cinq jours
nous nous sommes exprimés devant les
Français avec nos arguments avec notre
projet de société et vous vous êtes
couché
je le dis
alors mes chers collègues oui monsieur
le Président vous allez pouvoir utiliser
l'article 38 le règlement vous en donne
la possibilité
mais nous serons consultés avant cela
mais je tiens à rappeler quand même
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
du 11 juillet 2019 notez cela mes chers
amis le Conseil confirme la réserve d'un
interprétation déjà formulé en 2015
selon laquelle il appartiendra au
président de séance d'appliquer cette
limitation dans le temps cette clôture
du débat ce baïonnage
cette limitation eu le temps de temps de
parole en veillant en respect des
exigences de clarté et de sincérité du
débat parlementaire
et bien nous ferons nous ferons les
recours auprès du conseil pour savoir si
cette intérité a été préservée dans
cette administique
monsieur le Président compta
merci merci monsieur le Président vous
vous rendez compte quand même de la
responsabilité que vous avez ce soir ici
oui la responsabilité un jour historique
de mobilisation vous choisissez vous
choisissez ce soir sur l'article 7 un
des articles plus importants l'article
qui va passer qui va donner deux ans de
plus aux Français de travail vous
décidez de bâillonner le Parlement vous
décidez de censurer le Sénat ce soir
vous imaginez la responsabilité que vous
avez par rapport à la population par
rapport à tous ceux qui nous regardent
c'est quand même lamentable je ne
comprends pas ça alors on nous dit alors
on nous dit on a
on a fait de l'obstruction mais on a eu
trois jours trois jours de débat on est
à l'article 7 c'est-à-dire qu'on est à
la moitié de ce texte où est
l'obstruction où est l'obstruction on a
eu des arguments un par un on les a
débattus où sont vos arguments on ne
vous a pas entendu une seule fois c'est
vous c'est avec votre obstruction
silencieuse qui
donne une phrase donc franchement je ne
comprends pas l'usage de cet article
l'usage de cet article 38 je pense que
vous avez encore la possibilité de le
retirer en tout cas je me avec mes deux
autres collègues évidemment on demande à
ce que la Conférence des Présidents
puissent se réunir parce que je pense
qu'il y a besoin c'est un moment grave
c'est un moment important je j'espère
que vous que vous que vous rendez compte
de la responsabilité que vous avez
franchement
bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres demandes
monsieur le Président Marseille
non mais merci
je suis
monsieur le Président Laurent merci
merci
je vous ai écouté depuis longtemps j'ai
écouté sur tous ces banques comme tous
mes collègues vous avez utilisé les
ressources du règlement pour faire
entendre votre opposition nous l'avons
écouté avec beaucoup de patience en
étant très conciliant en étant très
conciliant vous vouliez qu'on arrive à
l'article 7 le 7
quasiment à cette heure
bon ça a été fait et on a été et ça
continue bon le règlement il est le même
pour tout le monde il est le même pour
tout le monde et nous nous utilisons
maintenant le règlement pour faire
entendre aussi une autre voix une autre
voix une autre voix je ne vous ai pas
reproché d'utiliser le règlement pour
faire entendre vos propos votre
opposition nous utilisons maintenant le
règlement
nous utilisons
et alors et alors il est il est là il y
a même d'autres articles du règlement
qui n'ont jamais été utilisés non plus
bon vous les utilisez nous les utilisons
y le règlement intérieur il a été étudié
par la par le Conseil constitutionnel il
a été approuvé chacun l'utilise c'est
normal et donc à partir de maintenant et
ben
comme on dit dans les campagnes les
mouches ont changé d'âne
d'autres demandent
d'intervention
[Applaudissements]
trois choses avant que nous procédions
votre monsieur le Président kaner
il appartient au président de séance
d'appliquer ses limitations du temps de
parole en veillant au respect des
exigences de clarté de sincérité du
débat parlementaire et je rappelle que
les révisions de notre règlement depuis
1959 a été soumis en 2015 et 2019 au
Conseil constitutionnel comme le
président Marseille vient de le rappeler
nous avons eu sur cet article l'état 124
interventions je considère que les
exigences de clarté et de sincérité ont
été respectés par l'importance de ces
intervalles
par ailleurs sur les sujets de rappel au
règlement puisque je voyais s'agiter
quelques petits livres verts l'article
38 prévoit strictement les modalités du
débat et je les ai respectés et le
rappel au règlement
constituent un détournement de procédure
mais connaissant s'est alinéa nous
allons donc maintenant procéder au vote
parce scruta public
la clôture qui est favorable à la
clôture le manifeste enlevant la main
avis contraire
la clôture est adoptée et nous allons
maintenant engager le vote parce que
le scrutin est ouvert je vous réponds
voilà de fortes tensions dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat depuis une dizaine
de minutes depuis que Bruno Retailleau
le chef de fil des LR au Sénat a demandé
l'utilisation de l'article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat alors que s'est-il
passé il y avait une longue série de
prise de parole de la gauche avec 77
amendements de suppression d'article 7
vous savez cet article sur les 64 ans
dans la réforme des retraites et donc le
chef de fil de la droite a demandé à ce
que l'on utilise et bien un article de
règlement qui vient contraindre les
explications de vote un pour un
contreparamondement cela vient donc
réduire les temps de débat et donc là on
voit la gauche du matériel qui a dénoncé
l'utilisation de cet article qui est la
première dans le débat au Sénat depuis
sa création en 2015 et donc on voit
cette forte tension avec des prises de
parole des présidents des principaux
groupes politiques du Sénat à gauche on
dénonce la mesure et à droite on la
soutient on va voir donc que cela va
tendre d'un coup les débats
autour de cet article 7 la gauche qui
demande une suspension de séance pour la
réunion de la réunion des la Conférence
des Présidents et donc qui pourrait
suspendre les débats on n'y est pas
encore pour l'instant on va voir donc ce
qui se passe autour de ce scrutin public
pour l'heure puisque c'est bien ce que
implique se tient dans l'hémicycle en ce
moment on ira juste après avec notre
journal non notre journaliste Mathias
sarez retournant l'hémicycle pour suivre
ces moments de fortes tensions depuis
une dizaine de minutes
voilà on a entendu par exemple le
président canner dire honte à vous vous
voulez bâillonner votre opposition c'est
un scandale on a vu aussi un que il y
avait une comme ça une contestation de
l'utilisation de cet article 38 selon la
gauche cela pourrait venir interférer
avec la sincérité du débat et là-dessus
et bien ça fait réagir le président de
séance le président du sénage à un
marché qui a dit que et bien lorsque le
Sénat avait révisé son règlement en 2015
et en 2019 il avait fait avec et bien
l'accord du Conseil constitutionnel et
qu'il y avait depuis le début de
l'examen de l'article 7 c'était vers 23
heures 124 interventions
va écouter ce qui se passe en séance
c'est la priorité sur ce qui se passe on
va écouter le résultat de ce scrutin
public
344 votants 340 exprimés pour
115 contre 225 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
ses amendements de suppression
madame la Présidente vous avez souhaité
la réunion de la Conférence des
Présidents madame la Présidente assassin
vous avez souhaité la réunion de la
Conférence des Présidents elle est
prévue demain je vous la confirme mais
si vous souhaitez ajouter à l'ordre du
jour il faut que je reçoive par écrit et
je les intégrerai le forment du jour
sans aucun problème madame la Présidente
en application de notre règlement
j'entends bien monsieur le Président
mais pourrais-je vous demander
solennellement une suspension de séance
parce que nous avons après l'annonce du
recours à cet article 38 nous avons
besoin de nous organiser je ne vous
demande pas une heure je vous demande 15
minutes de suspension de séance attendez
j'ai la commission m'avait fait savoir
qu'elle souhaitait aussi une suspension
de séance donc la conjonction fait le
bonheur alors madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président en effet je
demande une suspension de séance de 10
minutes pour réunir la Commission et
notre commission se réunit dans sa salle
la salle 213 je vous remercie on vous
donne un quart d'heure jusqu'à ça permet
de répondre à l'ensemble des demandes à
1h30
13h30 c'est pour la suite
voilà il est 1h15 sur l'antenne de
public Sénart on vient de vivre 10 15
minutes de fortes tensions dans
l'hémistique alors pour tout comprendre
on va les rejoindre notre journaliste
Mathias sarez Mathias vous avez tous
suivi depuis la tribune de presse que
s'est-il passé le point de départ vous
êtes d'accord avec moi c'est
l'utilisation de cet article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat la clôture c'est bien
ça explique-nous tout absolument c'est à
partir du moment où le président du
groupe LR Bruno Retailleau a demandé
l'application de l'article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat que les choses se
sont tendues tout à coup alors que
prévoit cet article 38 et bien qu'à
partir du moment où il est activé
lorsque au moins deux orateurs d'avis
contraire seront intervenus le président
Larcher un président de groupe où la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales pourra proposer la fin de la
disclus de la fin de la discussion une
clôture qui est ensuite adoptée ou non
par les sénateurs avec un vote à main
levée c'est c'est ce qui s'est produit
et donc cette activation de l'article 38
a été vivement critiqué par tous les
présidents de groupe de gauche a
commencé par la présidente communiste
Eliane assassy qui a immédiatement
demandé une suspension pour que ce
tienne une réunion de la Conférence des
Présidents assassin qui a également
parlé de marque de faiblesse de la part
de la droite Patrick canaire et lui
allait plus loin en parlant de honte
vis-à-vis de cette application en
parlant de la droite incapable de
défendre ses arguments ce à quoi a
répondu Bruno retaillaux qu'ils avaient
subi cinq jours et 5 nuits d'obstruction
de négation du rôle du débat donc ça
c'était par rapport à l'activation de
l'article 38 le vote a ensuite eu lieu
le vote en scrutin public suite à quoi
la présidente communiste Eliane assassy
a deux nouveaux demander une suspension
pour que se tienne une réunion de la
Conférence des Présidents elle a demandé
15 minutes minutes pour que les groupes
puissent se réorganiser les groupes de
gauche et puis c'était également à ce
moment-là que la commission des affaires
sociales a elle aussi demandé une
suspension de 10 minutes suspension qui
vient donc d'avoir lieu merci allez une
première réaction à mon micro
j'accueille ici en salle des conférences
Françoise Gatel bonsoir bons
d'Ille-et-Vilaine pardon il aura donc
fallu attendre une heure du matin pour
voir ses fortes tensions dans
l'hémicycle autour de cet article 7
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé la droite et
le centre on dit stop à cette
obstruction cordiale
le président du Sénat bien expliqué que
je crois que la majorité sénatoriale a
été très attentive
aux propositions et au débat conduit par
la gauche sauf que le débat était
étouffé puisqu'on a eu sur ce dernier
article 124 interventions de même nature
ça veut dire qu'à un moment la majorité
sénatoriale n'arrive pas à s'exprimer
que nous avions le risque de ne pas
aller au bout du texte et je crois que
les Français attendent et les syndicats
aussi
attendre que nous débattions de ce texte
sur le fond sachant qu'après l'article 7
arrive tous les points d'amélioration
que le Sénat souhaite porter en termes
de mesure sociale donc je crois que le
président du Sénat il a simplement une
recours un article du règlement qui je
crois n'a jamais été oui mais sa
création bien sûr mais je ne sais pas
s'il y a eu ici dans cette émission le
débats de cette nature ou depuis jeudi
ou vendredi nous écoutons avec respect
nos collègues qui ont un discours très
monolithique et qui répète
inlassablement leurs arguments mais vous
étiez déjà contraint par le 47 ans sur
ce projet loi de financement
rectificatif c'est-à-dire des temps de
débats contre un là vous contraignez
encore davantage avec cette règle du
règlement un orateur pour un orateur
contre ça donne pas une impression que
la démocratie a un peu le bras tordu
alors nous sommes nous sommes contraints
par la procédure que le gouvernement a
choisi et donc nous devons pouvoir aller
au bout de cette discussion sincèrement
la démocratie elle est pas du tout
entravée moi je le dis avec beaucoup de
respect pour mes collègues que
j'apprécie je pense qu'à un moment il y
a quand même eu de l'obstruction
c'est-à-dire on nous a empêché d'avancer
bien merci merci on va voir ce moment où
Bruno Retailleau a demandé l'application
d'article 38 et on va en parler avec lui
juste après
fais 5 jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à
faire à une obstruction je voudrais dire
que l'obstruction c'est la négation du
rôle du Parlement bien sûr le rôle du
Parlement c'est de débattre mais de
débattre pour voter on a été élu non pas
pour faire des groupes de parole mais
pour voter voilà le principal intéressé
est ici sur ce plateau bonsoir Bruno
Retailleau chez toi je suis le président
du groupe LR ici au Sénat on vient de
vous entendre lorsque il y a quelques
minutes c'est à dire à peu près 10
minutes vous avez demandé que l'on
utilise le règlement du Sénat son
article 38 pour venir contraindre les
débats quel était votre intention avec
cet article 38 mon attention c'est
dénoncer l'obstruction ça fait cinq
jours cinq nuits qu'on assiste à une
multiplication de prise de parole des
centaines d'amendements qui sont
parfaitement identiques et je vois bien
que la gauche qui voulait pourtant
arriver à l'article 7 qu'on le discute
le 7 mars on l'a fait et bien là il y
avait une forme de blocage il faut qu'on
aille au bout du texte parce que il y a
des articles qui sont si importants pour
les Français moi je veux discuter de la
retraite des mères de famille je veux
discuter de l'usure professionnelle des
petites retraites de la euh l'assurance
vieillesse par exemple pour les pour les
aidants c'est ce que j'ai indiqué je
pense que finalement
l'obstruction c'est pour le Parlement la
négation de son rôle c'est une sorte de
49.3 à l'envers c'est un autodésissement
du Parlement on a entendu le chef de fil
et des socialistes un paprikaner vous
dire honte à vous vous voulez bâillonner
votre position c'est un scandale
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez j'espère
que les téléspectateurs ont depuis cinq
jours et 5 nuits écoutez et ils ont vu
qu'on a rien bâillonné du tout qu'en
réalité l'obstruction c'est une vieille
ficelle qui consiste quand on n'a pas
une majorité à essayer de bloquer les
débats on peut pas bloquer les débats
pour bloquer un vote voilà il y a une
règle en démocratie il y a des minorités
il y a des majorités recourir à des
artifices de procédures pour en
calaminer les débats pour moi ça n'est
pas la démocratie parlementaire quand on
est parlementaire on n'appartient pas un
groupe de parole vous voyez où on
parlerait à l'infini notre job à nous
notre métier c'est de débattre et pour
voter la gauche vous alerte sur le fait
que on risquerait de porter atteinte à
la sincérité des débats avec cet article
38 qui je le rappelle est une première
son utilisation depuis sa création ou
son instauration dans le règlement du
Sénat qu'est-ce que vous répondez là
encore j'ai un archi et elle l'aura très
bien répondu cet article a fait l'objet
précisément d'un contrôle du Conseil
constitutionnel et à l'issue de ce
contrôle du Conseil consuel le Conseil
n'a rien trouvé à redire sur la
constitutionnalité de l'article 38 ça
signifie donc que nous pouvons
l'employer à sans doute une exigence
près c'est que les oppositions aient pu
débattre et puis s'exprimer ce qu'ils
ont fait durant cinq jours et 5 nuits de
façon quasiment continue qu'est-ce que
ça va changer très concrètement pour
noter les spectateurs
à partir de maintenant vous le dites
c'est fini cette obstruction cordiale de
la part de la gauche le monologue de la
gauche est terminé va pouvoir avancer
beaucoup plus vite dans le texte c'est
pas avancer vite c'est simplement avancé
c'est qu'on ne nous empêche pas de
discuter des articles qui sont
importants je les ai cités tout à
l'heure sur l'usure professionnelle sur
les Invalides sur par exemple les maires
de famille ou encore sur les toutes
petites retraites
juste un dernier mot là-dessus est-ce
que vous allez défendre vous encore et
bien cet article 7 ou est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'on avance c'est qu'on passe
cet article 7 ah bah il faut voter sur
l'article 7 bien sûr mais déjà ce que
j'observe c'est que il y aura pas de
suppression d'articles 7 c'est donc une
première victoire elle ne sera pas
supprimée maintenant c'est acté puisque
c'est voté merci merci beaucoup Bruno
Retailleau chef de fil derrière ici au
Sénat on va rejoindre notre journaliste
Mathias sarez Mathias réexpliquez-nous
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent depuis maintenant une dizaine
une quinzaine 15 minutes le président du
groupe LR a demandé l'utilisation de
l'article 38 du Règlement qu'est-ce que
ça signifie et bien cet article 38 du
Règlement intérieur prévoit qu'un parti
de maintenant lorsqu'on - 2 orateurs
d'avis contraire seront intervenus le
président Larcher un président de groupe
ou la président de la commission des
affaires sociales pourra proposer la fin
de la discussion une clôture qui sera
ensuite adoptée ou non par les sénateurs
par un vote à main levée voilà ce que
dit le règlement c'est une première
utilisation de l'article 38 et qui a été
introduit en 2015 il n'avait jusqu'ici
jamais été dégainé alors pour autant cet
article 38 il ne permet pas d'arriver
directement au vote de l'article 37 il
va simplement permettre de gagner du
temps si je peux dire si je puis dire en
supprimant la multiplication des prises
de parole préalables ou encore la
multiplication des explications de vote
en les limitant à une intervention par
sénateur par groupe merci m'intéresse
pour toutes ces explications j'accueille
ici en salle les conférences
Marie-Noëlle linman bonsoir à vous une
réaction sur ce qui se joue dans
l'hémicycle depuis 15 minutes et le
déclenchement de cet article 38 une
première depuis sa création et le fait
qu'il était instauré dans règlement du
Sénat et ben triste de soirée pour le
Sénat pour d'abord son image auprès des
Français
et je crois pour la démocratie
traditionnellement cette assemblée des
tas de défauts mais c'est quand même un
lieu de débat et cet article qui stoppe
le débat sur la l'abandon de l'article 7
et n'a jamais été utilisé il y a quand
même eu des tas de choses et c'est bien
un signe de faiblesse en plus de ça
faire ce mauvais coup de baïonnage du
débat
parlementaire le jour où il y a une
puissante manifestation sociale où les
français demandent à être entendus
compris
et que le Sénat la majorité est l'air du
Sénat complicité avec le gouvernement
dit circuler il n'y a rien à voir on a
raison tout seul c'était d'ailleurs
l'argumentaire de Monsieur Retailleau on
est courageux on sait que c'est un
populaire mais il faut le faire je pense
quand même quand démocratie multiplier
les réformes impopulaires c'est hyper
dangereux la droite elle vous dit aussi
que vous aviez pris la parole 124
interventions sur l'article 7 depuis 23
heures que c'était une forme de
monologue c'est ça qu'elle dénonce de
votre part cette obstruction cordiale
non le monologue il est aussi lié au
fait qu'une sorte pas leurs arguments à
part les monsieur c'est la gauche qui
les a déposés oui mais il pourrait y
avoir des arguments de la droite faire
un certain nombre de propositions depuis
le début de l'examen de cette réforme
c'est silence dans les rangs au mieux il
y en a ou deux qui parlent et le reste
pas d'arguments et toujours les mêmes
arguments nous nous essayons de
convaincre en multipliant argumentaire
et de nous de relayer aussi ce que
disent les Français parce que le
Parlement ça devrait être la boîte Déco
l'écho de l'attente des peuples du
peuple ça n'est pas le cas et de toute
façon c'est pas la première fois qu'il y
a des lois ou beaucoup de demandes de
parole sont faites et je ne crois pas
que l'avenir de la France se joue à une
heure ou deux de débats supplémentaire
qui serait insupportable pour les
parlementaires et l'air merci merci
Marion Mylène pour cette réaction notre
micro on va écouter le chef de fil des
socialistes et on revient ici en salle
des conférences avec un invité
honte à vous
[Applaudissements]
honte la constitution et le gouvernement
et vous voulez maintenant bâillonner
votre opposition c'est un scandale
[Applaudissements]
l'article 38 n'a jamais été utilisé sans
faire de ma part dans cette émission
vous le faites parce que vous avez
incapable de défendre vos arguments tout
au long de ces 5 jours
bonsoir Messei bonsoir président du
groupe centriste ici au Sénat environ de
ces mots de Patrick Kanner honte à vous
vous voulez bâillonner votre position
c'est un scandale qu'est-ce que vous
répondez au chef de fil des socialistes
au Sénat
ce que nous lui avons répondu en séance
c'est-à-dire que il arrive un moment où
trop c'est trop je veux dire nous avons
laissé l'opposition parler jusqu'à
maintenant l'opposition souhaitée
symboliquement traiter l'article 7 le 7
je crois que nous avons été très
conciliant nous avons écouté
l'opposition à utiliser
légitimement les ressources du règlement
intérieur et bien maintenant nous les
utilisons à notre tour je pense que
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
légitime on avait déjà vu qu'il y avait
une contrainte sur les temps de débats
avec l'utilisation d'un projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale maintenant on passe à cet
article du règlement du Sénat qu'est-ce
que ça donne comme image sur une réforme
des retraites adoptée ou examinée dans
de telles contraintes écoutez je crois
que
la gauche et ses alliés de la nupaisse
parce que au Sénat la gauche n'aime pas
qu'on rappelle quelle est la société de
la nupesse à la nupesse est un accord
électoral au législative oui c'est aussi
une réalité politique qui s'est exprimée
à l'Assemblée nationale pour ne pas
discuter le texte pour ne pas le voter
et qui jusqu'à présent ici au Sénat
c'est beaucoup exprimé pour s'opposer au
texte on a le droit aussi de dire
pourquoi on va le voter mais alors il y
a un double contexte de suspension de
séance peut-être que vous allez pouvoir
nous éclairer mais du coup la gauche a
demandé à suspendre la séance pour se
réorganiser c'est ce qu'elle demandait
il y a une assassin et dans le même
temps on a entendu quelque chose que nos
téléspectateurs n'ont peut-être pas noté
mais qui est très important la
commission des affaires sociales a
également demandé 10 minutes 15 minutes
de suspension de séance qu'est-ce qui
est en train de se passer autour du
texte
écoutez il est vraisemblable que la
commission des affaires sociales va
réécrire
les articles de du texte pour les faire
voter et cela va entraîner la
suppression de beaucoup d'amendements
les 1300 autour de l'article 7 c'est ça
que vous êtes en train de donner aux
aventures de rester les bras ballants à
écouter les interlocuteurs successifs
des groupes socialistes communistes et
verts on a aussi le droit de s'exprimer
et on a aussi le droit d'utiliser le
règlement pour rationaliser le débat
donc la commission des affaires sociales
du Sénat va présenter un nouvel
amendement sur l'article 7 qui le
réécrit et les 1300 amendements de la
gauche vont donc tomber et donc là à 1h
du matin c'est une nouvelle partie de
guérilla parlementaire qui s'ouvre
puisqu'on le sait la gauche peut
maintenant déposer des sous amendements
pour revenir sur cette nouvelle version
de la commission des affaires sociales
c'est ça qui est en train de se jouer à
1h du matin au Sénat bah écoutez à
quelle heure voulez-vous que ça se joue
puisque c'est eux qui occupent le
terrain depuis 5 jours il fallait leur
demander de faire tomber des amendements
pour qu'on puisse faire ça à 15h à 16h
ou à 17h bon je veux dire c'est une
partie de guérir parlementaire qui est
en train de s'ouvrir non c'est un débat
parlementaire c'est un débat
parlementaire le débat n'a pas pu faire
du règlement le dépôt d'amendement au
cours de discussion sur un article bon
si vous voulez on peut aussi partir
comme ça on les laisse tout seul et puis
tout va bien non je veux dire la gauche
n'a pas voulu qu'on débatte à
l'Assemblée elle s'oppose au débat au
Sénat nous utilisons le règlement pour
pouvoir exprimer notre différence et
nous nous souhaitons qu'il y ait un
débat que le texte enrichi et que nous
votions et alors que dire de ces
soupçons sur la sincérité du débat on a
entendu que Patrick kaner et bien vous
alerter sur le fait que en utilisant
l'article 38 cette clôture des débats la
pouvait ensuite avoir des conséquences
sur la sincérité des débats ensuite
d'ailleurs il a annoncé qu'ils allaient
déposer des recours auprès du Conseil
constitutionnel pour dénoncer
l'utilisation de ce règlement bon ben
écoutez on verra ce que dit le Conseil
constitutionnel enfin un débat
parlementaire pardon mais je reviens
capable de fébrilité qui vous qui
parcourbe au rond comme elle parcourt
les rangs du gouvernement je au nom
d'une soi-disante obstruction que nous
en petite musique que nous entendons
depuis depuis le début depuis le début
de l'examen de ce projet de loi vous
usez d'une procédure monsieur le
Président qui est peu
usité ici au Sénat voilà il est 1h33
nous sommes en direct sur antenne de
Public Sénat depuis 20 minutes de vive
tension agite la chambre haute du
parlement pourquoi parce que la droite
sénatoriale a demandé l'utilisation de
l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat qui
va venir contraindre à partir de
maintenant les débats autour des
amendements seul une prise de parole
pour une prise de parole contre seront
autorisées puisqu'il y a eu une
délibération dans l'hémicycle et que
l'utilisation de cet article 38 a été
acceptée deuxième actualité qui est en
train de se jouer alors que nous sommes
en suspension de séance la commission
des affaires sociales va sans doute
proposer une nouvelle écriture de
l'article 7 qui vien pas faire tomber
des centaines d'amendements de la gauche
sénatoriale pour en parler on a
accueilli ici Daniel Breuillet bonjour
vous êtes bonsoir bonne nuit
sénateur écologiste du Val-de-Marne
qu'est-ce qui vous semble le plus urgent
là dans ce qui est en train de se jouer
l'utilisation de l'article 38 qui va
venir contre année débats ou le fait
qu'on va maintenant débattre peut-être
d'un nouveau texte un nouvel article 7
dans les prochaines minutes ce qui me
semble le plus urgent c'est de souligner
le grand paradoxe qu'au soir d'une
manifestation énorme dans les villes
dans les villages dans les grandes
villes et dans les petites villes qui a
vu des millions de personnes dire qui ne
voulaient pas de cette réforme la
présidence la majorité sénatoriale
décide avec la présidence de contraindre
et de limiter les débats
ces débats avaient déjà été contraints
par le gouvernement par l'utilisation
d'un projet de loi de finance
rectificatif par l'utilisation de
l'article 47 1 et nous qui défendons le
par le parlementarisme nous rajoutons
une supplémentaires pour empêcher
l'expression donc cet article 38 est
déjà en soi jamais utilisé ce qui prouve
bien son caractère exceptionnel et et il
existe il est dans notre règlement on ne
le conteste effectivement depuis 2015 et
son sacréation dans le règlement voilà
donc c'est quand même oui un coup de
force démocratique d'une certaine façon
que de tenter de faire taire les
sénateurs notre droite parole est amputé
il y aura un pour un compte
bon par ailleurs vous venez de
l'annoncer un autre événement se prépare
c'est-à-dire qu'il va y avoir une
réécriture de l'article 7 pour faire
tomber la totalité des événements alors
la majorité sénatoriale le président
Marseille disait les mouches ont changé
d'âme bah j'espère qu'elle retourne à
leur Anne de prédilection et bien nous
utiliserons nos cils les les outils
réglementaires pour continuer à faire
entendre notre opposition et à proposer
de d'améliorer ce texte et même de
renoncer totalement à cette mesure d'âge
vous avez entendu le président Larcher
il a dit que depuis le début de l'examen
de l'article 7 il y avait eu 124
interventions
99% venu de la gauche est-ce que la
droite et le centre n'avait pas aussi
l'intention de d'arrêter ce monologue de
la gauche c'est peut-être ça aussi qui
se joue ben ils auraient surtout du
défendre prendre la parole aussi à cet
article 7 pour le défendre le fait de
contraindre nos concitoyens à travailler
deux années de plus à travailler jusqu'à
64 ans il y a eu je veux le souligner il
y a eu une intervention de quelques
collègues centristes qui ont proposé une
mesure de liberté d'équilibre en disant
ne mettons pas la barrière à 64 ans et
laissons le choix et la liberté aux
salariés de leur départ de leur date de
départ j'ai une dernière question est-ce
que vous aviez déjà prévu la
contre-offensive vous nous le dites ça
ce micro il y a des centaines de sous
amendements qui sont prêts de la part de
la gauche pour cette nouvelle version
qui va sortir de sociales de l'article 7
décidément vous entendez tout
on a bien placé on va dire ça le comme
ça avec ce studio au milieu de la salle
des conférences on a quelques un
félicitations vous faites votre travail
de façon excellente merci allez on va
écouter votre chef de fil Guillaume
Gontard c'était il y a un instant dans
les mystique c'est parti
c'est ce soir sur l'article 7 un des
articles plus important l'article qui va
passer qui va donner 2 ans de plus aux
Français de travail vous décidez de
bâillonner le Parlement vous décidez de
censurer le Sénat ce soir vous imaginez
la responsabilité que vous avez par
rapport à la population par rapport à
tous ceux qui nous regardent c'est quand
même lamentable je ne comprends pas ça
alors on nous dit alors on nous dit on a
on a fait de l'obstruction mais on a eu
trois jours trois jours de débat on est
à l'article 7 c'est-à-dire qu'on est à
la moitié de ce texte où est
l'obstruction
voilà il est 1h37 si vous nous rejoignez
sur le public c'est là nous sommes en
direct et avec un coup de théâtre
parlementaire qui s'est joué il y a une
vingtaine de minutes dans l'hémicycle
peut-être un peu plus une demi-heure
maintenant avec l'utilisation d'un
article du réglement du Sénat demandée
par la droite l'article 38 qui vient
contraindre les débats et dans le même
temps et bien une suspension de séance
demandée par la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat qui va sans doute
proposer une nouvelle écriture de
l'article 7 sur la mesure d'âge pour en
parler j'accueil ici pierre ouzouglia
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes sénateur
communiste des Hauts-de-Seine alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle est l'actualité des
deux que je viens de mentionner qui est
la plus importante dans ce qui est en
train de se jouer à maintenant au milieu
de la nuit au Sénat une troisième
actualité je vous écoute troisième je
pense qu'on vient d'assister à un
remaniement gouvernemental les
républicains viennent de rentrer au
gouvernement c'est clair vous avez bien
compris tout ça a été prévu de longue
date organisée le nouvel article 7 a été
rédigé de façon conjointe avec le
gouvernement vous le pensez depuis
plusieurs jours à même avant l'examen du
texte on sentait que c'était en
préparation donc il y a très clairement
une composition politique majeure
historique les républicains viennent de
rentrer au gouvernement il soutiendront
maintenant la politique gouvernementale
jusqu'au bout on en a l'intime
conviction l'objectif c'est d'aller le
plus rapidement possible sur le texte en
diminuant les possibilités d'amendement
de l'opposition là on a on a basculé il
y a un changement de l'époque le
quinquennat de Monsieur de Macron vient
de passer dans tout à fait autre chose
on verra ce qu'elle est dans l'article 7
en l'occurrence lorsque la commission
des affaires sociales reviendra de sa
réunion pour l'instant il y a toujours
une suspension de séance qui est qui est
en cours que dire en tout cas de ce que
vous dit la droite sénatoriale le fait
qu'il y avait ces nombreuses prises de
parole je sais 124 rien que sur
l'article 7 99% du temps de parole
occupé par la gauche est-ce que ça les
poussait pas à l'action
société qui se débat jusqu'au bout mais
99% du temps de parole occupé par la
gauche parce que la droite a refusé de
parler là-bas les 77 amendements de
suppression c'est en l'occurrence la
gauche qui les avait posé et ça
contraint enfin monologue mais ce qui
compte un tout le tout le discours
parlementaire c'est le 47-1 et le
gouvernement a choisi cette forme très
particulière pour nous empêcher de
discuter de ce projet et surtout pour
nous empêcher d'avancer un projet
alternatif pourquoi nous intervenons
autant parce que nous avons un projet
alternatif et que nous voulons débattre
de ce projet alternatif on fait pas des
amendements pour le plaisir d'occuper
mystique vous l'avez bien vu à chaque
fois sur chaque amendement il y a du
fond il y a des idées et un projet
alternatif pierre posé là qu'est-ce qui
va se passer ensuite si vous déposez des
centaines de sous amendements ça veut
dire que là il va falloir suspendre la
séance pour de longues minutes car il
faut réorganiser tout le débat autour de
l'article 7 non mais là la
responsabilité celle du président du
Sénat s'il veut continuer à faire que le
soit le lieu de la démocratie respectée
maintenant aujourd'hui ça lui d'agir et
bien très bien on va écouter justement
le président du Sénat qui en plus
préside cette séance autour de l'article
7 on écoute
la partie au président de séance
d'appliquer ses limitations du temps de
parole en veillant au respect des
exigences de clarté de sincérité du
débat parlementaire et je rappelle que
les religions de notre règlement depuis
1959 ont été soumis en 2015 et 2019 au
Conseil constitutionnel comme le
président Marcel vient de le rappeler
nous avons eu sur cet article l'état 124
interventions je considère que les
exigences de clarté et de sincérité ont
été respectés par l'importance de ces
intervalles
voilà ça s'est joué il y a quelques
instants en séance si vous nous
rejoignez il y a un coût de théâtre
autour de l'article 7 et de son examen
ici en séance de nuit au Sénat pourquoi
parce qu'il y a une demi-heure la droite
a demandé l'utilisation d'un règlement
d'une partie du Règlement du Sénat
l'article 38 qui vient contraindre les
débats et dans le même temps la
commission des affaires sociales a
demandé une suspension de séance car
elle entend peut-être sans doute
présenter une nouvelle version de
l'article 7 Guillaume gontin vous êtes
avec nous en salle des conférences chef
de fil des écologistes ici au Sénat ce
qui se joue avec la commission des
affaires sociales qui a qui s'est réuni
qu'est-ce que ça dit de ce qui va se
passer maintenant d'abord dire quand
même qu'on est dans un moment grave un
moment quand même triste pour à la fois
le parlementarisme pour le Sénat quand
même parce que en plein milieu de la
nuit de décider comme ça de
d'autocensurer le débat parlementaire
alors qu'on avait un débat parlementaire
riche construit il y a une très lourde
responsabilité à la fois du gouvernement
mais évidemment du groupe des
Républicains de Bruno Retailleau d'avoir
déjà dégainé cet article 38 qui
contraint justement les débats et puis
maintenant la commission qui va réécrire
le texte pour quelle raison tout
simplement pour faire tomber l'ensemble
de nos amendements et donc pour qu'on ne
puisse plus les défendre oui alors que
la cloche retentit dans le palais du
Luxembourg ça signifie que les sénateurs
sont rappelés en séance d'un instant à
l'autre mais encore quelques questions
si vous le permettez qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire on nous parle de liasse de
sous amendement qui sera en cours
d'impression de la part des groupes de
gauche de quoi s'agit-il bah tout
simplement le texte est réécrit on va
redéposer un certain nombre de sous
amendements sous amender le nouveau
texte que vaut 1000 300 avant
et vous allez déposer des centaines de
sous amendements pour pouvoir à nouveau
débattre nous ce qu'on veut c'est
débattre on est des parlementaires on
est là pour pour débattre pour
construire ce texte pour discuter pour
échanger et c'est ce que refuse
totalement les républicains depuis déjà
deux trois jours vous êtes d'accord pour
dire qu'on rentre dans une partie de
guérilla parlementaire à une heure 43 du
matin écoutez c'est les républicains qui
veulent faire de l'obstruction je veux
dire qu'il donne raison en fait à ce qui
s'est passé à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est comme ça nous on a eu un débat
serein calme jusqu'à présent ils veulent
maintenant que ça se passe autrement je
leur laisse la responsabilité est-ce que
vous allez devoir suspendre la séance
pour examiner ses centaines
d'amendements alors ça la séance je
pense crise de la suspendu quelques fois
parce que il va falloir se réadapter
ouais bon bah c'est une soirée agitée
qui nous attend sur le public c'est la
merci Guillaume je vous laisse rejoindre
l'hémicycle nous on va aller voir
Mathias sarez en tribune de presse merci
Mathias d'être avec nous est-ce que vous
pouvez nous réexpliquer ce qui est en
train de se jouer notamment autour de
l'article 38 Mathias ben écoutez on l'a
vécu il y a un peu plus d'une demi-heure
l'article 38 a été dégainé par le
président du groupe LR Bruno Retailleau
un article qui vise à réduire les débats
notamment en limitant les prises de
parole avant les articles et également
en limitant les explications de votre
mais ce n'est pas tout Quentin vous
l'avez dit il y a eu des demandes de
suspension afin que la Commission puisse
réécrire le texte mais je crois que la
science est en train de reprendre et on
va suivre ça ensemble
[Musique]
pour une bonne partie
d'erreur matérielles coordination ou
clarification rédactionnelle
il intègre l'amendement du Gouvernement
prévoyant que la mise en œuvre du
nouveau dispositif de maintien en
fonction jusqu'à l'âge de 70 ans pour
les fonctionnaires n'entraîne pas la
radiation des cadres des personnes
concernées
il précise les modalités d'entrée en
vigueur de la mesure de report de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à 64 ans ainsi
que son implication dans les
collectivités
ultramarines enfin il reprend les
demandes exprimées par plusieurs groupes
d'une clause de revoyure d'ici à 2027 il
s'agit donc vous le voyez d'apporter de
nombreuses précisions que nous jugeons
utiles au sein de cet article
par ailleurs monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
du fait de sa rédaction il est de quelle
nature à clarifier les débats
en effet
il va permettre au Sénat de se prononcer
d'un blog sur les paramètres essentiels
de cet article 7
dont nous avons déjà amplement des
battus depuis 19h et à vrai dire depuis
le début de notre travaux jeudi dernier
le Sénat veut-il oui ou non qu'a compté
du premier septembre 2023 l'âge
d'ouverture des droits soit
progressivement relevée jusqu'à
atteindre 64 ans pour la génération 1968
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le Sénat veut-il oui ou non une
accélération de la mise en œuvre de la
réforme Touraine
afin
vous allez dire oui vous afin que la
durée de cotisation requise pour
l'obtention du taux plein soit porté à
43 années à partir de la génération 1965
[Musique]
notre vote sur cet amendement permettra
à chacun de nous d'exprimer clairement
sa position et de trancher ce débat
essentiel
son adoption
ferait tomber plus de 1100 amendements
qui se répartissent
[Musique]
pour l'essentiel en deux catégories
premièrement
des amendements tendons à introduire des
dérogations par métier
587 amendements
n'oubliez pas n'oubliez pas dans ces
amandes blancs là de retirer celui qui
concerne les bornes d'âge de 62 à 64 ans
pour les internes en médecine
des amendements de replis des
amendements de suppression d'articles on
en a déjà eu quelques-uns me semble-t-il
tendance à supprimer des alinés à du
texte 517
mais mais je vous rassure
même après l'éventuelle adoption de cet
amendement
il nous restera vous voyez que vous avez
tout prévu il nous restera un débat
riche suscept article 7
puisqu'ils d'amendements de tous les
groupes politiques qui nous permettront
des débats de fonds sur des sujets
importants notamment la situation des
maires de famille la situation des
sportifs de haut niveau le rachat de
trimestre d'études supérieures et des
périodes de stage des conditions de
départ en retraite des enseignants ou
encore des sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels
la commission sera même favorable à
l'adoption de plusieurs de ses
amendements là encore venant de
différents groupes et il nous restera
évidemment un débat riche sur tous les
articles qui suivront
je vous remercie de votre attention et
vous appelez évidemment à bien vouloir
voter en faveur de cet amendement de la
commission
comme la présidente
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur assoline si vous pouvez
éviter de crier derrière ce serait ce
serait plus sympathique et surtout ça
devient fatigant en application
l'article 46 bis alinéa 2 du règlement
ce n'est pas en hurlant qu'on se fait
mieux entendre et qu'on est le plus
intelligible donc voilà
en application l'article 46 bis elle est
un peu du règlement la Commission a voté
en ce sens et propose au Sénat de 10
juin l'amendement numéro
4762 de la discussion commune merci
alors
c'est bien une demande de priorité alors
c'est une demande de disjonction oui
je demande en application de l'article
44 alinéa 6 du règlement la priorité
d'examen et de vote sur cet amendement
les deux
je suis donc saisi d'une demande de
priorité de la commission afin qu'ils
soient mis aux voix avant l'ensemble des
amendements de la discussion commune je
rappelle pour l'organisation de nos
débats c'est l'article 44 aliasis de
notre règlement la priorité de droit
quand elle est demandée par la
Commission saisie au fond à moins que le
gouvernement s'y oppose le gouvernement
de s'y oppose pas
merci à monsieur le président
merci monsieur le président
je note monsieur le Président mais vous
l'avez fait avant moi et avant la
suspension qu'il y a eu plus de 120
interventions sur cet article et je note
aussi pour avoir regardé rapidement
évidemment l'amendement tel que
l'adopter par la commission des affaires
sociales que cet amendement va permettre
et va nous permettre si les adopté bien
sûr de discuter débattre de plusieurs
dizaines d'amendements qui pensent sur
des sujets de fonds des sujets
importants permettant de progresser sur
l'article 7 pour la disjonction à la vie
du gouvernement n'est pas requis je
crois monsieur le Président et donc
évidemment le Gouvernement s'en remet la
décision du Sénat et pour ce qui
concerne la priorité traditionnellement
et par
usage mais aussi par respect des travaux
du Sénat le Gouvernement s'en remet
aussi au Sénat donc je considère que le
gouvernement de s'oppose pas la priorité
est donc de droit et
je vais maintenant vous faire demander
l'application de l'article 46 sur la
demande par la commission d'examen
séparés de l'amendement je vais
consulter là le Sénat s'il y a des
observations
madame la Présidente
comme nous nous
attendions également
voilà la réécriture de cette article 7
nous avons bien évidemment parce que
nous sommes courageux monsieur Lemoine
qui est parti nous avons bien évidemment
travaillé des sous amendements et donc
je vous remets je remets au service de
la séance les sous amendements que mon
groupe a vient dépose pour
l'examen de cette réécriture de
l'article 7
ça veut dire que
je vais consulter néanmoins pour savoir
qui est pour
cette demande de disjonction donc ceux
qui sont pour le manifeste en levant la
main
avis contraire abstention et vous allez
pouvoir nous remettre les sous
amendements
et ce qui va m'amener madame la
Présidente à ce que la Commission se
remette au travail pour un certain temps
pour un certain temps monsieur le
Président donc je demande en effet une
suspension de séance pour réunir la
commission pour examiner les quelques on
parle de 3000
trop bien
vous verrez le chiffre en arrivant ça se
pèse
et donc je vous propose trois quarts
nous reprendrons à deux heures 45 voilà
voilà on va aller vers une nouvelle
suspension de séance voilà ça y est
c'est fait nouvelle suspension de séance
la deuxième depuis une heure du matin
avec voilà deux actualités qui se qui se
profile pour le Sénat déjà l'utilisation
l'article 38 demandée par la droite cet
article 38 va venir contraindre les
débats à partir de maintenant et surtout
surtout la réunion de la commission des
affaires sociales qui a donc proposé un
nouvel écriture de l'article 7 cet
article sur la mesure d'âge qui vient
donc remettre à plat complètement le
débat sur cet article 7 et la mesure
d'âge et on vient de le voir des
sénateurs de gauche qui avait préparé la
manœuvre et qui viennent de redéposer
des amendements et donc il y a une
nouvelle réunion de la commission des
affaires sociales car elle va devoir
examiner tous ces sous amendements et
car effectivement avec la manœuvre du
gouvernement et bien tous les
amendements précédents 1300 que la
gauche avait déjà déposé sur les textes
ils viennent de tomber c'est donc une
nouvelle page qui s'ouvre autour
d'examen de cet article depuis 1h du
matin une forme de guérilla
parlementaire qui se met en place ici à
la Chambre haute avec à la fois la
droite qui utilise le règlement du Sénat
et la gauche qui également utilise et
bien les sous amendements pour et bien
revenir sur ce qui se joue en séance on
va les retrouver la matière sarez
peut-être pour nous parler de l'article
38 Mathias un mot sur ce qui s'est passé
il y a maintenant 50 minutes et Bruno
Retailleau qui a demandé l'utilisation
l'application de cet article 38 du
Règlement s'il vous plaît oui c'est un
article 38 qui a donc mis le feu aux
poudres maintenant on le voit avec tous
les coups de théâtre qui s'enchaînent
ici dans dans l'hémicycle et bien cet
article 38 du Règlement intérieur du
Sénat que prévoit-il et bien il prévoit
que lorsque au moins deux orateurs
d'avis contraire seront intervenus le
président Larcher un président de groupe
ou la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales pourra proposer la fin
de la discussion ensuite une clôture
sera votée par les sénateurs dans un
vote à main levée c'est un article 38
qui limite modérément les débats
puisqu'il peut simplement limiter le
nombre de prises de parole préalable à
l'examen des amendements ou encore le
nombre d'explications de vote on l'a vu
donc des groupes politiques qui ont dû
user d'une nouvelle manœuvre politique
avec la réécriture Quentin de cet
article 7 et merci Mathias pour toutes
ces explications j'accueille ici en
plateau Olivier Hainaut bonjour soir et
vous êtes sénateur centriste du Nord il
est 1h57 et on a son assiste au début
d'une partie de guérilla parlementaire
on peut le dire depuis 50 minutes
règlement du Sénat contre nouvelle
écriture sous amendement comment est-ce
que vous voyez toute cette séquence vous
alors nous nous avons une volonté
d'aboutir le rôle du Parlement c'est
discuté il y a eu sur cette article 7
près de 150 interventions 24 124
exactement
l'idée est de permettre bien sûr encore
quelques discussions il s'agit pas du
tout fermer la discussion mais on a
constaté qu'il y avait des amendements
plus de 100 amendements qui étaient
absolument
identique et donc c'est pas une volonté
de discuter c'est une volonté de
d'empêcher l'issue de de ce débat et le
président l'archet en accord avec les
présidents de groupe avec Hervé
Marseille et Bruno retaillod ont exprimé
la volonté c'est une volonté publique
c'est dans la presse dans les médias de
de faire en sorte que à l'issue de du
débat c'est-à-dire dimanche minuit au
plus tard nous puissions les uns et les
autres en responsabilité exprimaient un
vote par rapport au texte or si on
continue à discuter des 2150 amendements
qui sont inscrits à l'ordre du jour on
peut pas y arriver on peut pas dire non
plus que moi je maintenant quelques
expériences on peut pas dire non plus
que presque deux semaines de débats se
sont insuffisant pour permettre
d'exprimer une position et donc voilà
c'est le règlement du Sénat il est
utilisé pour permettre d'aboutir et
d'avoir une position du Sénat à l'issue
de la discussion le chef de fil des
socialistes a dit en séance honte à vous
ou vous voulez bâillonner votre position
c'est un scandale qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à la gauche qui se sentent
bâillonné par l'utilisation de cet
article 38 du Règlement du Sénat qui est
d'ailleurs une première c'est la
première fois depuis que l'on intègre
cette mesure dans règlement du Sénat en
2015 que l'on l'utilise en séance tout
ce qui est excessif et dérisoire écoutez
quand on vient de s'exprimer 126 fois
avec des amendements plus de 320
amendements absolument identiques alors
je ne nie pas qu'ils ont travaillé mais
enfin peut-être aurait dû se coordonner
car si cette écordonné ils auraient pas
déposé des amendements identiques avec
des prises de parole systématiques moi
je respecte la flibusterie parlementaire
je sais qu'elle existe mais il y a un
moment donné il faut dire STOP parce que
c'est de la crédibilité du Parlement des
parlementaires et du Sénat parce qu'on
est regardé et je voudrais pas que ayez
une nuptéisation du une les lfiation du
Sénat c'est ça qui est en jeu c'est la
crédibilité du Sénat et c'est la raison
de pour laquelle j'approuve les choix du
président Larcher alors ça c'est pour ce
qu'est de l'application du de l'article
38 du Règlement du Sénat il y a une
deuxième actualité brûlante qui se joue
en ce moment c'est la réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales en ce
moment car la Commission a déposé une
nouvelle version de l'article 7 une
manœuvre de la droite là encore et du
centre pour faire tomber les 1300
amendements de la gauche c'est ça qui
s'est joué à une manœuvre c'est votre
appréciation ça n'est pas la mienne
c'est c'est non c'est un on a constaté
les deux rapporteurs ont constaté qu'il
y avait des amendements qui étaient
identiques
bon c'est une volonté d'obstruction et
donc il fallait trouver un moyen c'est
le règlement et donc cet amendement au
fond il évacue ses amendements
identiques mais reprend 120 amendement
de tous les groupes qui permettent
vraiment d'aborder la discussion donc ça
n'est pas une volonté de d'obstruction
tous les débats sont possibles toutes
les discussions mais les amendements
identiques ils sont évacués et pour les
néophytes ce que vient de présenter René
Paul Savary en séance le rapporteur de
la branche vieillesse c'est une version
similaire à ce qu'il y avait dans le
texte du Gouvernement en matière de
borne d'âge etc il y a rien qui change
sur le fond il y a pas grand chose qui
change il y a que quelques amendements
qui étaient proposés initialement par
les rapporteurs mais grosso modo cette
procédure permet d'évacuer les
amendements qui étaient identiques et
qui sont nombre de plusieurs centaines
voilà c'est tout simple rien de plus
rien de moins dernier réacte dans ce qui
s'est joué dans cette guérilla
parlementaire qui est en train de se
jouer depuis une heure du matin la
gauche qui à nouveau redépose des
centaines de sous amendements à cette
nouvelle version du texte qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez eux ils parlent de
courage ben j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont en train tout simplement de
conjuguer le verbe nuccieriser à tous
les temps ouais je ne pense pas que ça
allait grandit et que ça grandisse le
Parlement nous nous agissons en
responsabilité il faut qu'on ait des
discussions il faut qu'on ait des débats
mais qu'à l'issue de de ces journées
parlementaires nous puissions tout
simplement nous exprimer et voter par
rapport au texte merci merci Olivier
nous pour cette réaction au micro de
Public Sénat on va réécouter ce moment
charnière où le président Retailleau a
demandé l'application de l'article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat et on en reparle
juste après avec une invitée
c'est un rappel au règlement monsieur le
Président à partir c'est sur la base de
l'article 38 77 amendements de
suppression
tous
identiques monsieur le Président je
demande cette application
donc je suis saisi par Monsieur
autaillou président de groupe des
demande de clôture sur les explications
de vote sur les amendements numéro 3 à
2268 en application de l'article 38 de
notre règlement la clôture peut être
proposée lorsque au moins deux orateurs
c'est le cas d'avis contraire sont
intervenus bonsoir de la Gontrie bonsoir
vous êtes sénatrice socialiste de Paris
on vient de voir ce moment où le
président Retailleau demande que l'on
enclenche l'article 38 du Règlement
votre chef de fil Patrick Kanner qui a
parlé de scandale et du fait que
l'opposition était bâillonnée qu'est-ce
qui s'est joué exactement à ce moment là
écoutez la mise en scène est très
curieuse parce que depuis le début du
débat on sait quand même que ce texte
est très important on sait qu'il y a eu
3 millions de personnes dans les rues
aujourd'hui c'est la sixième
manifestation donc le sujet est
évidemment passionne absolument les
Français et depuis le début de ce débat
la droite est totalement silencieuse
nous avons attaqué seulement en fin
d'après-midi l'article 7 qui reporte
l'âge de la
banque donc c'est c'est vraiment
l'article emblématique du texte nous
avons déposé des amendements de
suppression d'abord puis des amendements
qui avaient vocations à améliorer voilà
à organiser tout ce qui nous semblait
préférable et
ça indispose la droite c'est à dire que
là où depuis quatre jours il ne parlait
pas là ils veulent que le débat tourne
court donc on a déjà une procédure très
particulière choisie par le gouvernement
qui nous impose de terminer nos travaux
au plus tard dimanche et on a
aujourd'hui une droite qui n'a aucune
envie que le débat est lieu et du coup
décide de de mettre en place une
procédure pour limiter ce temps de
parole la droite elle vous accuse aussi
d'une forme d'obstruction cordiale là
encore sur l'article 7 124 interventions
depuis 19h dit Gérard archet et 99% de
ses interventions de la part de la
gauche est-ce que il fallait pas aussi
utiliser des armes du règlement pour que
le débat avance plus rapidement mais
pourquoi le débat devrait-il avancer
plus rapidement on est en train de
parler encore une fois aujourd'hui même
3 millions de personnes dans la rue donc
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas passer deux
heures deux heures au Sénat pour en
parler j'ai reçu notre boulot aussi de
défendre les intérêts des Français donc
c'est tout à fait étonnant de voir que
le Sénat qui d'habitude et un lieu de de
réflexion
responsables non agitées tout à coup en
plein milieu de la nuit décide de oui de
bâillonner parce que c'est un article
qui est tellement violent que d'une part
il n'a jamais été utilisé au Sénat et
que d'autre part le Conseil
constitutionnel
cadre de beaucoup de précautions c'est à
dire qu'il ne peut pas empêcher que les
groupes s'expriment et il va falloir
toute la nuit que nous votions à chaque
occasion le principe même de
l'application de cet article donc c'est
d'une grande lourdeur mais ça se ça se
complète d'une autre démarche qui est
venue juste après ou la commission a
décidé de déposer un amendement complet
de réécriture qui par technique
parlementaire permet de faire tomber
1000 amendements que nous avions déposé
donc la droite veut simplement que le
débat n'est pas lieu oui on a entendu
votre chef de fil d'ailleurs dire qu'il
y avait une des dangers pour la
sincérité des débats et que votre groupe
allait sans doute déposé un recours
auprès du Conseil constitutionnel c'est
bien ça on a bien compris oui
c'est-à-dire que ce principe d'encadré
de manière extrêmement drastique le
temps de parole au Parlement le Conseil
constitutionnel qui a eu à se prononcer
là-dessus déjà
l'accepte mais à condition que ce qu'il
appelle la clarté la sincérité des
débats parlementaires soit respecté
c'est à dire que toutes les opinions
divers et puis s'exprimer et donc le
président l'archet qui a à cœur la
réputation de sérieux du Sénat va devoir
y veiller donc tout ça va être quand
même très lourd donc à chaque amendement
il va falloir consulter le Sénat pour
savoir si nous ne sommes d'accord si
c'est d'accord pour actionner cette
procédure spécifique ensuite nous allons
nous exprimer sur le recours à la
procédure puis nous allons nous exprimer
sur bref et nous nous avons du coup pour
nous défendre déposer des sous
amendements qui vont voilà qui seront
jumeaux des amendements que nous aurions
déposés donc tout ça est la droite en
fait se ridiculise un peu c'est pas le
genre de du Sénat de faire ce genre de
choses et les Français ne comprendront
pas à leur même que eux perdent des
jours de salaire par les manifester pour
faire grève etc ici on considère qu'on
ne peut pas passer quelques heures pour
traiter de leur sujet il y a une
deuxième actualité qui vient de se jouer
dans les dernières minutes c'est le fait
que la commission des affaires sociales
a présenté un nouveau texte juste pour
cet article 7 une nouvelle rédaction qui
fait tomber des facto la quasi-totalité
des amendements autour de l'article 7 je
crois qu'il y en a une centaine qui est
conservé qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
manœuvre là comment est-ce que vous
l'avez compris c'est encore une fois une
façon d'éviter les débats mais nous y
répondons en déposant des sous-amands à
ce nouvel amendement qui vient de sortir
en plein milieu de la nuit et donc ce
débat il aura lieu donc
c'est c'est une dénaturation de ce qui
doit se passer normalement ici mais je
ne comprends pas que le président
l'archet encore une fois qui est très
vigilant à la réputation de sérieux du
Sénat ce soit ce soit embarqué dans une
telle un tel procédé et donc un dernier
mot une dernière question la gauche vous
avez présenté des sous amendements
plusieurs centaines c'est bien cela y
compris aux parties socialiste bien sûr
oui et combien exactement je n'ai pas le
décompte à l'heure où je vous parle
parce qu'évidemment tout ça c'est fait
dans la précipitation mais il y aura au
final plusieurs milliers d'amende de
sous amendements qui vont qui sont
déposés par les en groupe de gauche une
dernière question très rapidement vous
êtes d'accord pour dire qu'on rentre
dans une phase de fin de guérilla
parlementaire à 2h du matin au Sénat
c'est ça qui se joue arme du règlement
contre son amendement
il y a une agression de la part de la
droite à l'égard du Parlement et à
l'égard de l'opposition et donc nous
nous défendons avec les faibles moyens
qui sont prévus par la Constitution et
par le règlement merci merci pour toutes
ces explications et ses réactions mes
comptes publics Sénat on va rejoindre
notre journaliste en tribune de presse
matthiasarez Mathias un petit récap un
petit résumé de ce qui est en train de
se jouer avec vous s'il vous plaît et
bah écoutez Quentin après la suspension
de séances que nous avons vécu c'est un
René Paul Savary tout à fait théâtral
qui est revenu au micro pour exprimer le
fait que la commission des affaires
sociales avait écrit un amendement qui
proposait de réécrire l'article 7 de
cette réforme des retraites une
réécriture qui aurait pourrait
éventuellement si elle était adoptée
faire tomber plus de 1100 amendements
des amendements essentiellement venus de
la gauche car ce que souhaite cette
réécriture et bien c'est que le vote de
plusieurs mesures ne se fasse que dans
un seul bloc pour autant le rapporteur
de la branche vieillesse de la
commission des affaires sociales
l'assure si plus de 1100 amendements
tomberaient ils pourraient tout de même
y avoir un débat riche car il restera
une centaine d'amendements notamment sur
des mesures concernant les maires de
famille les sportifs de haut niveau les
pompiers ou encore le rachat de
trimestres un coup politique me
direz-vous Quentin mais qui avait été
prévu par la gauche car on a vu
immédiatement la présidente du groupe
communiste elle est anassassy se lever
et se diriger vers les huissiers ici au
Sénat pour leur remettre on ne sait pas
exactement le nombre de sous amendements
peut-être plusieurs centaines des sous
amendements qui sont donc venus
suspendre de nouveaux la séance puisque
la des affaires sociales a dû s'en
saisir pour les examiner avant de
revenir ici dans l'hémicycle merci merci
Mathias pour toutes ces explications
effectivement depuis la tribune de
presse j'accueille ici en salle des
conférences Mélanie Vogel bonjour
bonsoir
du matin vous êtes sénatrice écologiste
des Français établis hors de France un
mot sur ce qui se joue en séance
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce qui retient
le plus votre attention entre la droite
qui demande l'application l'article 38
qui va venir contraindre maintenant
mécaniquement les débats ou et bien
cette nouvelle version du texte qui fait
tomber tous vos amendements puisque
prenez pas le Savary a présenté un
nouvel amendement de la commission comme
bien de l'expliquer Mathias qu'est-ce
que vous retenez
l'un comme l'autre ça participe de la
même stratégie il est plus de deux
heures du matin on sort d'une journée de
mobilisation massive avec plus de 3
millions de personnes dans la rue et en
plein milieu de la nuit la droite main
dans la main avec le gouvernement décide
par certes une procédure qui existe en
règlement mais qui est jamais utilisé
de faire tomber plus de 1000 amendements
pour qu'on ne puisse pas discuter de ce
qu'on a appelé le cœur du réacteur de la
réforme l'article plus important de la
réforme celui qui décale l'âge de départ
à la retraite au 62 à 64 ans au fond
tous les autres articles si vous voulez
c'est pas grand chose c'est ça le cœur
de la réforme et là il est 2h du matin
alors bon vous vous êtes là mais il y a
quand même plus grand monde au Sénat
pour regarder ce qui se passe et le
message qui a envoyé oui le message qui
envoyé aux françaises et aux Français
c'est ben en fait tout cela des 3
millions de personnes dans la rue on
s'en fout c'est ça le message à droite
c'est complètement irresponsable et
c'est démocratiquement très grave alors
vous allez réagi vous aviez déjà une
parade qui était prête à ce qu'on
comprend la gauche qui va sous amender
cet amendement de la commission c'est à
dire on a vu Elena Stacy avec une liasse
de vous auriez préparé une manœuvre
plus importante oui vous avez le nombre
de sous amendements que la gauche
représenté plusieurs milliers
parce que c'est comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure le cœur du réacteur le débat le
plus important à avoir dans tout ce
débats sur la réforme des retraites on
n'a pas pu la voir à l'astrobation
nationale la droite et la majorité
présidentielle se sont énormément plein
du comportement des députés à
l'Assemblée nationale qui avait empêché
le débat sur l'article 7 et bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe maintenant on a
eu des débats certes avec beaucoup
d'amendements mais enfin il y a eu 3000
amendements au total un petit peu plus
au Sénat c'est parce que j'appelle de
l'obstruction d'accord c'est pas nous
qui avons rencontré les débats et obligé
qu'on finisse l'examen du texte dimanche
c'est le gouvernement qui ont choisi
cette procédure c'est pas nous cette
procédure elle est totalement
inappropriée et d'ailleurs je suis
convaincu que le Conseil constitutionnel
censuré une bonne partie des
dispositions parce que c'est pas le bon
véhicule législatif
on a fait un débat sincère sur le fond
on n'est pas d'accord ça génère beaucoup
d'interventions c'est un texte très
important donc ça prend du temps mais on
n'a pas fait de l'obstruction voyez de
mauvaise foi et là en plein milieu de la
nuit sur le cœur du débat la droite des
sites d'utiliser pile à ce moment-là ce
qui va envoyer ça fait tomber un tiers
des amendements quand même oui et au
final est-ce que vous vous dites pas que
certes c'est plus polissé au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale mais qu'au final
cette bataille est bien elle sera gagnée
par la droite et le centre oui bien sûr
mécanique en démocratie le vote c'est
aussi ce qui doit intervenir à la fin
vous refusez
que le vote en démocratie décide à la
fin je considère néanmoins que la
démocratie parlementaire elle
s'affaiblit pas en écoutant le mouvement
social bien au contraire les batailles
sociales elles se nourrissent des
mouvements sociaux
entre la démocratie parlementaire et la
démocratie sociale certains
représentants syndicaux on en ont parlé
dans les cortèges
parlementaire qui a deux heures du matin
se dit là c'est le bon moment pour
sortir le petit article du règlement qui
va venir censurer le débat que 3
millions et demi de personnes sont venus
nous demander d'avoir et sont venus nous
demander de rejeter oui c'est une
démocratie qui est qui est malade dans
le fond et juste pour revenir sur cette
question de au Sénat c'est plus policier
etc c'est vrai mais moi j'ai toujours
dit faut pas faut pas confondre
l'outrance de la forme avec la brutalité
du c'est pas parce qu'on a des débats
plus policés au Sénat c'est pas parce
que on crie moins c'est pas parce que on
parle moins fort que les propos qui sont
tenus et les propositions qui sont
faites sont pas profondément violentes
voire plus violentes comme c'est le cas
ici qu'elle a semblée nationale j'ai une
dernière question pour revenir sur et
bien cet article du règlement qui va
être utilisé pour contraindre les débats
l'article 38 qu'est-ce que ça signifie à
partir de maintenant ça signifie que
bien vous allez devoir restreindre vos
prises de parole sur chacun amendement
c'est bien ça oui l'article 38 permet
que en fait il y ait qu'une seule prise
de parole en faveur ou contre une
disposition du texte pour clore la
discussion et donc empêche les prises de
parole des milliers d'amendements
examinés
oui
on n'est pas plus bêtes que donc on a
aussi nous on utilise aussi comme les
outils qui existent et qui sont à notre
disposition pour faire que le débat
puisse exister maintenant il existe la
bombe atomique au final qui est le vote
bloqué qui peut être déclenché par le
gouvernement qui serait un coup de force
enfin totalement irresponsable et moi je
veux dire j'appelle le gouvernement là
on est plus que sur un débat de fond sur
la réforme des retraites 62 ou 64 ans
l'index Seigneur et je sais pas quoi il
y a ça c'est très important mais on est
aussi face à un enjeu démocratique très
fort
insister persister s'entêter à refuser
d'écouter le pays ça peut mener vraiment
une catastrophe démocratique je le crois
vraiment et je pense que le gouvernement
doit se réveiller on peut pas continuer
comme ça merci merci Mélanie Vogel et
alors justement parce qu'on parlait de
ce moment où il y a eu le déclenchement
de l'article 38 on va survivre à ce
moment qui sait jouer il y a à peu près
une heure et on reviendra au direct
puisque vous l'avez compris Public Sénat
va devoir va pouvoir être en direct
pendant de longues heures cette nuit
pour suivre l'examen cette réforme des
retraites qui est en train de prendre un
nouveau tour et en ce moment la réunion
de la commission des affaires sociales
qui est en cours donc on va réécouter ce
moment où il y a eu le déclenchement de
l'article 38 et on reviendra juste après
avec un invité en l'occurrence Patrick
Kanner le chef de fil des socialiste on
regarde c'est un rappel au règlement
monsieur le Président à partir c'est sur
la base de l'article 38 77 amendements
de suppression
tous identique monsieur le Président je
demande cette application
donc je suis saisie par Monsieur
retaillou président de groupe
de clôture sur les explications de vote
sur les amendements numéro 3 à 2268 en
application de l'article 38 de notre
règlement la clôture peut être proposée
lorsque au moins deux orateurs c'est le
cas d'avis contraire sont intervenus
je peux donner la parole sur le
souhaitent à un opérateur par groupe
et c'est la Turquie sur la liste donc un
groupe qui souhaite prendre la parole
monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
après avoir entendu la litanie des
orateurs qui sont succédés pour plaider
pour plaider
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'arguments
similaires
qui se sont succédés je me dis que
j'aimerais bien être petite souris à la
prochaine réunion du Parti socialiste
européen parce que j'irai entendu
description de l'Apocalypse
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme et
ce faisant vous disqualifiez aussi des
gens comme préministes Costa le
président Sanchez qui ont conduit ce
type de réforme et donc eugouverne eux
ont été réélus eux ont assumé et c'est
je crois là une grande différence avec
effectivement votre positionnement
Lionel Jospin est-il revenu sur la
réforme Balladur non
François
Hollande est-il revenu sur la réforme
verte non il a quelques petits
aménagements
reviendrez-vous sur l'article 7 s'il est
voté la réponse est non vous l'avez
d'ailleurs décrit comme une sorte
d'impôt sur la vie on sait bien que les
impôts vous les baissez jamais et donc
vous ne reviendrez jamais naturellement
là dessus alors je vais paraphraser le
collègue Lucien Stanzione qui disait
ayez du courage et bien ayez du courage
retirer ses amendements de suppression
parce que vous ne reviendrez pas dessus
et donc pour le groupe RDPI en tout état
de cause nous votre compte parce que ces
grands écarts permanents non seulement
ça fait mal aux adducteurs mais ça fait
mal à la confiance dans la politique je
rappelle que nous sommes sur un débat de
clôture madame la Présidente donc j'ai
compris que vous étiez favorable à la
clôture en même temps voilà madame la
presse
à vrai dire nous ne sommes pas surpris
par cette proposition de clôture de
notre discussion elle parcourt quand
même les couloirs du Sénat depuis
quelques heures maintenant parmi
d'ailleurs d'autres rumeurs qui
circulent qui circulent aussi
ce recours je vous le dis sincèrement ce
recours à cette procédure est un acte de
faiblesse de la part de la droite
sénatoriale c'est une marque de
fébrilité qui vous qui parcourbe au rang
comme elle parcourt les rangs du
gouvernement je au nom d'une soi-disante
obstruction que nous en petite musique
que nous entendons depuis depuis le
début depuis le début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi vous juger d'une procédure
monsieur le Président qui est peu usité
ici au Sénat et ce à quelques heures
d'une magnifique
mobilisation dans le pays et d'une autre
grande mobilisation
samedi prochain monsieur Lemoine nous
avons du courage
mais vous vous perdez votre sang-froid
avec ce coup de force
que nous dénonçons je le dis aussi
crûment que je le pense cette procédure
est une attaque contre la démocratie et
les droits du Parlement ce n'est pas
digne du Sénat monsieur le Président
alors
des débats dans les prochaines heures
nous demandons avec les présidents de
gauche c'est-à-dire moi-même le
président le cadener et le président en
compta la Réunion immédiate d'une
conférence des présidents
nous poursuivons monsieur le Président
Retailleau
pour indiquer que bien entendu de votre
ampoule la clôture puisque cela fait 5
jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à faire
à une obstruction je voudrais dire que
l'obstruction c'est la négation du rôle
du Parlement bien sûr le rôle du
Parlement c'est de débattre mais de
débattre pour voter on a été élu non pas
pour faire des groupes de parole mais
pour voter
l'obstruction c'est une sorte d'auto
effacement d'auto des saisissements du
Parlement vous allez refuser puisque on
va en train d'escargot de voir et de
voter sur l'ensemble du texte par
exemple sur les petites retraites par
exemple sur l'usure professionnelle par
exemple sur le handicap au travail et
bien nous nous voulons je crois que
choisir de ne pas voter c'est choisir de
ne pas peser méfiez-vous bien que
l'obstruction ne mène pas
présenter l'anti parlementarisme parce
que les Français vont constater qu'à
force de discuter le Parlement ne sert à
rien oui je l'affirme je la ferme
l'obstruction est au Parlement ce qu'une
désertion est un soldat la négation même
de sa mission que le président Kader
merci monsieur le président
oserais-je dire honte à vous
honte à vous
vous êtes laissés bâillonner par le 47 1
de la Constitution et le gouvernement et
vous voulez maintenant bâillonner votre
position c'est un scandale
[Applaudissements]
l'article 38 n'a jamais été utilisé sans
faire de ma part dans cette émission
vous le faites parce que vous étiez
incapable de défendre vos arguments tout
au long de ces 5 jours
nous nous sommes exprimés devant les
Français avec nos arguments avec notre
projet de société et vous vous êtes
couché
je le dis
alors mes chers collègues oui monsieur
le Président vous allez pouvoir utiliser
un titre 38 le règlement vous en donne
la possibilité
mais nous serons consultés avant cela
mais je tiens à rappeler quand même
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
du 11 juillet 2019 notez cela mes chers
amis le Conseil confirme la réserve d'un
interprétation déjà formulé en 2015
selon laquelle il appartiendra aux
présidentes séances d'appliquer cette
limitation dans le temps cette clôture
du débat ce baillonnage
cette limitation est temps de temps de
parole en veillant en respect des
exigences de clarté et de sincérité du
débat parlementaire
et bien nous ferons nous ferons les
recours auprès du conseil pour savoir si
cette interritée a été préservé dans
cette technique
monsieur le Président Gautard merci
merci monsieur le Président vous vous
rendez compte quand même de la
responsabilité que vous avez ce soir ici
oui la responsabilité un jour historique
de mobilisation vous choisissez vous
choisissez ce soir sur l'article 7 un
des articles plus importants l'article
qui va passer qui va donner deux ans de
plus aux Français de travail vous
décidez de bâillonner le Parlement vous
décidez de censurer le Sénat ce soir
vous imaginez la responsabilité que vous
avez par rapport à la population par
rapport à tous ceux qui nous regardent
c'est quand même lamentable je ne
comprends pas ça alors on nous dit alors
on nous dit on a
on a fait de l'obstruction mais on a eu
trois jours trois jours de débat on est
à l'article 7 c'est-à-dire qu'on est à
la moitié de ce texte où est
l'obstruction où est l'obstruction on a
eu des arguments un par un on les a
débattus où sont vos arguments on ne
vous a pas entendu une seule fois c'est
vous c'est avec votre obstruction
franchement je ne comprends pas l'usage
de cet article l'usage de cet article 38
je pense que vous avez encore la
possibilité de le retirer en tout cas je
me avec mes deux autres collègues
évidemment on demande à ce que la
Conférence des Présidents puissent se
réunir parce que je pense qu'il y a
besoin c'est un moment grave c'est un
moment important je j'espère que vous
que vous que vous rendez compte de la
responsabilité que vous avez franchement
bien est-ce qu'il y a d'autres demandes
monsieur le Président Marseille
[Applaudissements]
non mais merci
je suis
monsieur le Président Laurent merci
merci
je vous ai écouté depuis longtemps j'ai
écouté sur tous ces banques comme tous
mes collègues vous avez utilisé les
ressources du règlement pour faire
entendre votre position nous l'avons
écouté avec beaucoup de patience en
étant très conciliant en étant très
conciliant vous vouliez qu'on arrive à
l'article 7 le 7
quasiment à cette heure
bon ça a été fait et on a été et ça
continue bon le règlement il est le même
pour tout le monde il est le même pour
tout le monde et nous nous utilisons
maintenant le règlement pour faire
entendre aussi une autre voix une autre
voix une autre voix je ne vous ai pas
reproché d'utiliser le règlement pour
faire entendre vos propos votre
proposition nous utilisons maintenant le
règlement
[Musique]
nous utilisons
et alors et alors il est il est là il y
a même d'autres articles du règlement
qui n'ont jamais été utilisés non plus
bon vous les utilisez nous les utilisons
le règlement intérieur il a été étudié
par la par le Conseil constitutionnel il
a été approuvé chacun l'utilise c'est
normal et donc à partir de maintenant et
ben
comme on dit dans les campagnes les
mouches ont changé donne
[Applaudissements]
d'intervention
trois choses avant que nous procédions
votre monsieur le Président kaner
il appartient au président de séance
d'appliquer ses limitations du temps de
parole en veillant au respect des
exigences de clarté de sincérité du
débat parlementaire et je rappelle que
les révisions de notre règlement depuis
1959 ont été soumis en 2015 et 2019 au
Conseil constitutionnel comme le
président Marseille vient de le rappeler
nous avons eu sur cet article l'état 124
interventions je considère que les
exigences de clarté et de sincérité ont
été respectés par l'importance de ces
intervalles
par ailleurs sur les sujets de rappel au
règlement puisque je voyais s'agiter
quelques petits livres verts
l'article 38 prévoit strictement les
modalités du débat et je les ai
respectés et le rappel au règlement
constituent un détournement de procédure
mais qui méconnaissant s'est alinéa nous
allons donc maintenant procéder au vote
parce que
voilà retour direct puisque vous venez
de revivre ce moment où et bien le Sénat
a enclenché l'article 38 du Règlement
c'était donc il y a à peu près une heure
et quart c'est l'une des informations de
la soirée la seconde c'est que la
commission des affaires sociales a
déposé un nouvel amendement sur
l'article 7 une réécriture de cet
article pour en parler avec ici
Elisabeth dono bonsoir
vous êtes centriste ils sont triste de
Mayenne et rapporteur général du budget
de la Sécurité sociale ici au Sénat un
mot sur ce qui s'est joué il y a une
suspension de séance qui est en cours
dans l'hémicycle parce que votre
commission la commission des affaires
sociales était réunie pour examiner des
amendements autour de cette réécriture
voulue par le rapporteur René Paul
Savary c'est bien ça c'est bien ça en
réalité depuis le début de la soirée
nous étions sur cet article 7 dont tout
le monde voulait débattre les débattre
ça veut dire que il ne faut pas faire
d'obstruction or nous avons pu
écouter nos collègues le plus souvent de
l'opposition il y avait 120 amendements
à peu près qui ont été posés pour des
amendements suppression et donc à partir
oui à partir de là on s'est dit qu'il
fallait agir je pense que de toute façon
depuis 5 jours et 5 nuits on voit bien
que l'opposition avait usé de tous ses
droits et ce qui est tout à fait voilà
réglementaire en quelque sorte et nous
avons jugé que là sur l'article 7 il y
avait
1300 amendements et qu'il fallait qu'on
avance vraiment sur les sujets de ce
texte donc ça qui se jouait avec ce
qu'on a vécu en séance tout à l'heure
René Paul Savary en réaction à ce très
grand nombre d'amendements de la gauche
les 1300 sur l'article 7 a réécrit
l'article 7 puisque la Commission a le
droit de déposer un amendement cours de
séance afin de faire tomber tous les
amendements de la gauche oui la réalité
c'est que effectivement l'OPP
avait posé des amendements qui qui
étaient vraiment d'obstruction je vous
en raconte juste un cette idée que les
internes en médecine partiraient à la
retraite à 62 ans au lieu de 64 ans mais
est-ce que quelqu'un peut encore croire
que les internes sont internes à cet âge
avancé de la vie enfin il y avait
beaucoup de d'amendements fantaisistes
et on voulait vraiment pas passer toutes
les heures qui viennent sur ces
amendements qui qui n'avaient pas lieu
d'être combien d'amendements va-t-il y
avoir à examiner maintenant que il y a
eu cette réécriture parce que vous
pouvez conserver certains amendements
exactement nous n'avons pas voulu clore
le débat comme ça comme certains le
disent évidemment il trouve que c'est
très très brutal comme la loi d'ailleurs
qu'il trouve très brutal en fait nous ce
qu'on propose c'est que sur certains
amendements ils sont à peu près au
nombre de 120 je crois et bien on puisse
avoir un débat de fond mais que tous les
amendements fantaisistes disparaissent
de de notre dérouleur alors la gauche
c'est notoriale avait prévu le coup
avait vu venir ce nouvel amendement
Savary et à déposer des centaines de
nouveaux sous amendements et là vous
venez des examiner et ils sont jugés à
la quasi unanimité irrecevable c'est
bien cela oui alors écoutez moi j'ai
envie de dire c'est la nuit des dupes on
est dans guérilla parlementaire
ici au Palais du Luxembourg on a connu
la journée des dupes mais je sais pas
qui est le plus dupé finalement parce
que la gauche s'attendait à ce que cet
outil réglementaire puisse être utilisé
par la majorité donc il n'était plus
étonné ils avaient préparé des
sous-amendements donc en réalité on a
examiné la recevabilité de ces sous
amendements et un seul est resté
possiblement en discussion c'est à dire
que c'est un amendement pour
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon que nous avions
introduit parce qu'il était déjà dans le
texte initial et là il y a effectivement
un report de date pour l'application de
la loi retraite sur voilà
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon merci merci
Isabelle dono on va rejoindre notre
journaliste Mathias tarez en tribune de
presse Mathias racontez-nous un petit
peu ce qui se joue depuis maintenant
1h20 au Sénat bien écoutez c'est un
cette l'article 38 du Règlement
intérieur qui a été dégainé par Bruno
retaillod qui a mis le feu aux poudres
alors cet article 38 que prévoit-il et
bien il n'y ait qu'une seule prise de
parole par groupe fin également des
prises de parole préalables fin
également des explications de vote c'est
donc un tout à tour de rôle les
présidents de groupe qui ont pris la
parole pour dénoncer cette décision il y
en assassy a parlé de marque de
faiblesse Patrick Kanner a également
dirigé à la droite un honte à vous il a
dit il a dit tout simplement que la
droite était incapable de défendre ses
arguments à Patrick canard qui a
également remis en doute la
constitutionnalité de cet article 38 il
a dit qu'il appartiendra au président de
séances d'appliquer dans une limite de
temps et que cela n'atteigne pas la
sincérité des débats alors pour le
Président gérarchie il n'y a pas de
doute sur cette application de l'article
38 Bruno Retailleau a également répondu
qu'il y avait été pendant 5 jours et 5
nuits questions d'une obstruction que le
Sénat avait connu une négation de son
rôle de débat c'est finalement le
président Gontard du groupe écologiste
qui a regretté cette décision d'utiliser
cet article 38 en disant que la droite
décidait de censurer le Sénat
merci Mathias pour toutes ces
explications pour en parler j'accueille
ici Eliana SSI bonsoir madame SSI vous
êtes la présidente du groupe communiste
du groupe communiste ici au Sénat un mot
sur ce qui se joue depuis 1h20 qu'est-ce
que vous retenez vous de cette séquence
mais écoutez pour être honnête avec les
téléspectateurs et vous-même nous
savions depuis un moment que des choses
se tramaient dans les couloirs des
rumeurs Bruxelles un petit peu partout
les sans penser que la majorité
sénatoriale de droite allait recourir à
des procédures que permettent le
règlement bien évidemment et donc à
l'annonce du recours à l'article 38 du
Règlement par Monsieur Retailleau le
président du groupe LR nous n'avons pas
été surpris non demeure pas moins
que nous considérons que bien évidemment
c'est dans le règlement mais que c'est
un coup de force contre le Parlement
c'est un
déni de démocratie c'est un acte
absolument contraire à la Constitution
c'est-à-dire précisément au droit
d'amendement des parlementaires et donc
bien évidemment nous avons réagi
vivement dans l'hémicycle et nous avons
créé des conditions puisque la rumeur
brissait de déposer des centaines de
sous amendements au nouvel article
rédigé donc par la commission des
affaires sociales
puisque la commission était réunie pour
examiner ces centaines de sous
amendements que vous aviez préparé en
réaction à cette nouvelle écriture de
l'article 7 et ils ont donc quasiment
tous été jugés il recevable qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez mais écoutez c'est
exactement de la mes propos seront de la
même teneur que les précédents c'est à
dire que on
contact on a réagi à l'article 38 on
dépose des sous amendements parce qu'on
veut qu'il y ait un vrai débat sur
l'article sur l'article 7 et qu'il y a
un vote sur ces Tarticle la droite
sénatoriale
avec le gouvernement on choisit d'autres
d'autres on se sont saisis plus
exactement d'autres outils pour ne pas
que pour que ce débat n'est pas lieu
donc
je suis vraiment attristée pour le Sénat
mais vraiment attristé pour le Sénat
qu'on en arrive à ce que y compris des
sous amendements qui ont été déposés
c'est-à-dire qu'on joue jeu de la
volonté de débattre de cet article 7 que
c'est suffisamment été visiblement
puisque je ne suis pas à la commission
des affaires sociales mais si j'ai bien
compris ils ont pratiquement tous été
sauf un absurde
la commission des affaires sociales donc
c'est un coup de force mais vraiment un
coup de force et ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas représentatif de ce qu'est le Sénat
dans la sagesse
que l'on lui connaît si on se met à la
place de Bruno Retailleau qui soutient
la réforme est-ce que lui qui vous voit
monopoliser la parole sur cette article
7 avec 124 prises de parole 99% de
l'entre elles par la gauche est-ce que
vous lui donnez pas raison d'utiliser
toutes les armes y compris du règlement
pour et bien contrer cette forme
d'obstruction cordiale qui le qu'il peut
qu'il peut dénoncer mais vous savez il y
a le texte je dis toujours qu'il y a le
texte et le contexte
usé de cette procédure qui est
réglementaire
usé de cette procédure en pleine nuit
après une mobilisation qui a réuni près
de 3 millions 500 000
Français
la sixième après un communiqué de
la terre syndicale qui annonce voilà qui
demande à être sûr en urgence par le
Président de la République
bien évidemment pour qu'il retire sa
réforme qui annonce une nouvelle
mobilisation samedi
je dois dire que le
Sénat la majorité et sa majorité et le
et le gouvernement sont dans leur bulle
je l'ai déjà dit une fois je le redis
aujourd'hui ils sont dans leur bulle ils
n'entendent rien ils ne voient rien il
ne réagissent même pas je parle des LR
au véhicules législatif qui a été choisi
par le gouvernement pour examiner ce
texte qui déjà nous contraignait dans le
temps et ils ne sont recours à des
procédures pour nous empêcher encore de
porter la voix de ce qui de porter la
voix de celles et ceux qui sont
mobilisés et qui exigent comme nous le
retrait de ce texte est-ce que vous
pensez que cela peut affaiblir
constitutionnellement parlant le texte
on a entendu votre collègue président du
groupe socialiste Patrick Kanner dire
que il allait déposer un recours auprès
du Conseil constitutionnel vous allez
vous allez vous allez vous y associer
pour le faire je vous remémore quand
même que j'ai déposé une question d'y
recevabilité au début de de l'examen de
ce texte donc jeudi dernier et dans
lequel dans explicité en fait toutes les
raisons tous les motifs
d'inconstitutionnalité de ce texte donc
il y a et et les 64 ans sont
un motif à eux seuls à motif des
recevabilité de d'un constitutionnalité
donc oui nous allons recourir au Conseil
constitutionnel pour qu'il nous donne
son avis sur ce texte et le fait que
l'utilisation de cet article du
règlement pour contraindre les débats ça
peut participer de cet argumentaire
auprès du Conseil constitutionnel je
vous l'ai dit c'est un outil du et c'est
un outil qui est la disposition du
président du Sénat j'ai toujours dit que
au Sénat il y avait plus d'outils de
procédure car l'Assemblée nationale
voilà ils en ont usé ça ils n'en demeure
pas moins que nous pensons que ce texte
est anticonstitutionnel et bien merci
merci il est nécessaire pour tous ces
explications on va rejoindre notre
journaliste parlementaire en tribune de
presse mathiasarez Mathias hein tous ces
jeux aussi autour de la prise de parole
de René Paul Savary leur apportant de la
branche vieillesse du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
absolument c'était l'une des
possibilités et bien elle l'a prise la
commission des affaires sociales a donc
soumis un amendement pour une nouvelle
écriture de l'article 7 de cette réforme
des retraites une nouvelle écriture qui
devrait faire tomber plus de 1100
amendements et qui a été annoncé par un
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse de
cette commission des affaires sociales
René Paul Savary théâtral écouter le
merci monsieur le Président j'attendais
effectivement
mon tour pour donner la vie de la
commission après tous ces amendements à
répétitifs
qui font pour certains tableaux de la
valeur travail particulièrement
apocalyptique il y a encore des gens
quand même qui je pense voit les choses
différemment
Monsieur Laurent Monsieur Laurent vous
avez dit que certains rêvaient un âge de
retraite à 64 ans mais Monsieur Laurent
moi la retraite à 60 ans pour moi c'est
un cauchemar ça veut dire qu'on n'aime
pas le système par répartition ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas vu la société la
société vieilli Monsieur Laurent il y a
de moins en moins de naissance la
longévité telle que la retraite
l'espérance de vie dure de plus en plus
longtemps et si vous voulez prendre des
mesures qui vont plomber le système par
répartition c'est que vous n'aimez pas
la répartition j'ai écouté aussi
monsieur Sueur monsieur Sueur qui a fait
une explication tout à fait intéressante
mais qui pense que en travaillant
effectivement plus sur la durée et bien
on pourrait peut-être rendre les gens
les plus heureux et bien non on sait que
plus la durée on travaille sur la durée
les 43 ans ça fait les conséquences
c'est qu'il y a une diminution de la
pension moyenne calculée à de 300 euros
lisez l'étude d'impact je n'ai rien
inventé donc ça veut dire que vous
n'aimez pas les retraités que vous
voulez faire des retraités pauvres c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me tourne
vers ce banc là de l'hémicycle
ce banc là de l'émission pense qu'il
faut jouer sur le niveau de l'âge légal
mais chers collègues vous avez raison
vous avez raison parce que ces eux le
seul moyen dans un système pas
répartition de faire en sorte qu'on
arrive à élever le niveau des pensions
faire en sorte qu'on puisse dégager des
recettes supplémentaires et qu'on puisse
faire plus de solidarité mais vous
n'aimez pas la solidarité donc et nous
nous aimons la solidarité
et nous aimons la solidarité et nous
voudrions bien la proposer aux Français
non pas à travers des discours mais à
travers des actes ce sont les articles
suivants qui viennent pour les maires de
famille vous en parlez beaucoup nous
agissons
pour l'usure professionnelle
ah je vous ai taquiné pour l'usure
professionnelle nous avons des mesures
pour la retraite progressive nous avons
des mesures en conséquence il serait
temps monsieur le Président que nous
puissions passer dans l'examen du sexe
les Français attendent de nous que l'on
donne un peu plus de justice sociale à
ce texte il en manque un peu messieurs
les ministres un peu plus de justice
sociale à travers les divers
dispositions que nous souhaiterions
vivement examinés voilà vous l'avez
compris mes chers collègues la vie sera
défavorable de la part de la Commission
un amendement qui sera donc rapidement
mis sous la sur la table car il a fait
l'objet d'une demande de priorité
d'examen par la rapporteur du budget de
la Sécurité sociale Catherine de roche
une demande de priorité d'examen qui a
été accordé par le Sénat merci Mathias
pour tous ces explications on vous
retrouve un tout au long de cette nuit
que l'on va vivre en direct à une
extension sur Public Sénat la séance
devrait reprendre d'un instant à l'autre
mais pour en parler je savais que Jérôme
Durin bonjour monsieur Durin vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de Saône-et-Loire un
mot sur cette séquence qui se joue
depuis maintenant une heure et demie au
Sénat qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
c'est la suite d'une plus longue
séquence ou on a un problème politique
de fond c'est à dire une incapacité
l'exécutif et puis du coup la droite
c'est l'intérieur entendre des Français
et puis une un problème qui tient aussi
à la succession des contournements de
procédure parlementaires ça n'est
peut-être pas les pilogues mais c'est un
mauvais tour joué à la démocratie
parlementaire tout ça dans le contexte 5
6e journée de mobilisation
demandée par l'Inter syndical qu'est-ce
que ça dit aussi aux Français qui
regarde toutes ces débats sur la joie de
départ je crois que ça
démontre un divorce important entre une
partie des représentants et tous ceux
qui ont des filets aujourd'hui dans les
rues en disant qu'ils étaient contre cet
article 7 et ce record de l'âge légal
merci monsieur Durand au moment où nous
nous parlons gérarchi et bien annoncé la
réouverture de la séance sans l'écoute
merci monsieur le Président donc nous
avons reçu beaucoup de sous amendements
la commission déclare et recevable
en application de l'article
44 bis alinéa 3 du règlement les sous
amendements qui ne se rapportent pas au
texte
et qui ne s'impute pas donc correctement
et qui aurait pour effet de contredire
le sens des amendements de l'amendement
auquel il s'applique
[Musique]
c'est c'est très clair soit ça n'est pas
dans le texte mais un sous amendement
qui contredit le sens de l'amendement du
rapporteur n'est pas recevable
non je le fais pas la Loue c'est très
simple quand on a sous amendement qui va
qui va quand on a sous un moment qui va
dans un sens contraire de l'amendement
et bien il n'est pas recevable par
ailleurs par ailleurs on se calme par
ailleurs
on se calme par ailleurs la Commission
des poser une exception d'y recevabilité
à l'encon de tous les sous-amendements
contraires aux principes
constitutionnels d'égalité en ce qu'ils
en sortent des dérogations par
profession par pathologie ou par des
catégories de la population
et la commission prononcerait la même
exception du recevabilité
à tous les amendements similaires si
nous venait en discussion s'ajoute 270
amendements que le soupe le groupe C
vient de déposer claque commission n'a
pas examiné mais qu'elle considère au
regard des arguments que je viens
développer comme irrecevable il reste
donc
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît non mais
on ne hurle pas
mais s'ils ont le même sens mais si on
les a vu la séance des amis la
commission je dis à Commission des a pas
examiné ils sont dans la même mouture la
même veine que ceux qu'on a examiné
c'est pas du bricolage arrêté n'importe
quoi
ils sont donc y recevables restent un
amendement recevable que celui du
sénateur Artano sur lequel le rapporteur
a donné envie favorable
donc en application de l'article 44 bis
à l'idée à neuf de notre règlement lire
recevabilité
lorsqu'il est affirmé par la commission
au fond voilà
ça rappelle le règlement madame
rossignol
le règlement s'effondra tout le monde
sans doute sur le 44 bis alinéa 3
puisque ont été déclarés irrecevables au
motif que ces amendements les sous
amendements ne s'appliqueraient pas
effectivement au texte qu'il vise
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary porte
sur le même objet que la que l'article 7
du projet de loi premièrement
deuxièmement nous avons déposé une série
d'amendements qui ont été nous avons
déposé une série d'amendements à
l'article 7 qui avait été déclaré
recevable donc ne portant atteinte ni
aux principes d'égalité ni étant un
contradictoire à quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui et même les mêmes
amendements devenus sous amendement
positionné comme il le faut à La Linea 3
à 5 c'est-à-dire bien positionné et qui
était recevable hier sur le fond
deviennent irrecevables maintenant quand
ils sont sur l'amendement je ne
comprends pas pourquoi d'autant plus que
c'est une interprétation assez extensive
de la contradiction alors qu'il ne
s'agit que de dérogation
vous comprendrez bien que tout ceci doit
être clairement précisé dans le Sénat
aujourd'hui j'ai bien intégré le fait
que pour reprendre une formule célèbre
nous avons probablement juridiquement
tort parce que nous sommes politiquement
minoritaires pour autant pour
autant politiquement majoritaire donc
c'est la discussion avec menée au fond
sur ce que la manœuvre de procédure que
vous mettez en place parce que c'est
essentiel dans la constitutionnalité de
l'adoption de cet amendement
monsieur Laurent un deuxième rappel au
règlement oui ou dans la parole
oui un rappel au Règlement sur le même
article mais je veux insister sur ce que
vient de dire ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol comment on l'espace d'une
demi-heure des amendements qui ont été
déclarés recevables par la commission
après avoir déclaré irrecevable je le
rappelle mille amendements donc c'est
pas des amendements que la Commission
avait oublié d'examiner puisqu'elle en a
déclaré il receva mille elle avait donc
regardé attentivement tous ceux qu'elle
avait déclaré recevable comment on
l'espace d'une demi-heure sans même
regarder ses amendements la Commission
peut maintenant nous dire qu'elle
déclare irrecevable ces amendements
donc il y a donc il y a il y a un pour
le mois un débat sur l'interprétation
qui est faite par la Commission de
l'article 44 bis alinéa 3 parce que
on nous invoque maintenant des motifs
d'irosabi recevabilité qui n'existait
pas il y a à peine une demi-heure sur
des amendements
identiques
donc il y a quand même un sérieux
problème et on ne voit pas comment ce
qui nous est présenté peut être
considéré comme acceptable en termes de
droit par le Sénat sauf à foulée au pied
toutes nos règles communes de travail
sérieux et responsable nous vous en
donnons acte je suis par ailleurs donc
je suis par ailleurs saisi par la
Commission saisie au fond d'une
exception des recevabilité c'est bien ça
à l'encontre de l'ensemble des sous
amendements déposés relatifs aux
dérogations par profession et autres
types de catégories en application s'il
vous plaît du dernier alinéa de
l'article 44 bis c'est moi qui préside
de notre règlement la question de le
recevabilité soumise avant leur
discussion à la décision du Sénat seul
l'auteur de la demande des recevabilité
et un orateur d'opinion concrets la
Commission et le gouvernement peuvent
intervenir il n'y a pas d'explication de
vote la parole est donnée à la
commission madame la présidente des
affaires sociales sur cette exception du
recevabilité un orateur dominant je vous
donnerai pour un rappel réglement
monsieur le Président après allez-y
je pense qu'elle vous a été distribué
non non
c'est donc une exception direcevabilité
à l'encontre je dis bien de sous
amendement contraire aux principes
constitutionnels d'égalité en ce qu'ils
instaure des dérogations par profession
pathologique catégorique il s'agit des
sous amendements qui viennent d'être
déposés voilà monsieur le Président le
sens de cette exception
alors d'opinion contraire monsieur
Assouline
c'est là-dessus peut-être qu'il y a un
malentendu il y a ceux que vous avez
déclaré à la louche et en gros paquet il
recevable et là il y a ces amendements
précisément qui parle de rupture c'est
sous amendement qui parle
dont madame la Présidente dit que ils
sont sur les ruptures d'égalité les
mêmes amendements
n'ont pas reçu cet avis de la commission
et ont été déclarés recevables donc
cette argument de rupture d'égalité
puisqu'en est sur le fond on n'est pas
sur les 1000 à la louche là et bien sur
le fond comment vous nous expliquez que
ces amendements qui étaient recevables
hier en étant examiné ne le sont pas là
est-ce qu'on peut non mais est-ce qu'on
peut avoir la réponse parce que vous
pouvez dire circuler il y a rien à voir
vous avez proposé quelque chose de très
précis
oui oui bien sûr ils ont jamais été
déclarés irrecevables la Commission les
a examinés et
oui ces amendements ont été examinés et
c'est le même en sous amendement ce sont
ce sont les mêmes contenus la Commission
les allaient examiner et avaient donné
un avis défavorable mais ils étaient
recevables pourquoi ils deviennent ils
receva maintenant on veut la réponse
alors j'ai compris que c'était une
opinion contraire à l'exception d'y
recevabilité que vous défendiez
rappel au règlement monsieur Gontard
oui merci monsieur le Président appelle
un règlement sur l'article 44 bis et il
a 3
de la même manière déjà moi je me pose
la première question sur le temps
matériel et la possibilité matérielle de
pouvoir étudier alors je sais pas
combien il y avait au total de sous
amendements qui ont été déposés mais
je me pose quand même les questions de
cette possibilité là parce que là on est
quand même sur le fond des amendements
ça veut dire qu'il faut quand même
analyser les amendements pour savoir sur
leur recevabilité si ça correspond
justement au texte donc je mets quand
même en doute sur la possibilité
matérielle de pouvoir faire ça surtout
qu'on a déposé ses amendements on a eu
quoi 45 minutes d'interruption de séance
on les a déposés il y a quoi il y a même
pas 20 minutes je pense que voilà je me
demande comment tout ça est possible et
puis j'ai regardé on a un certain nombre
d'amendements par rapport à ce que
Madame la rapporteur a pu dire je prends
l'abonnement
4672 sur le rachat de trimestres pour
stage il me semble qu'on est tout à fait
dans quelque chose qui en tout cas qui
qui correspond tout à fait au texte qui
n'est pas en en décalage par rapport au
texte donc ça me ça me pose quand même
un un problème
donc voilà et puis ce qui a dit Monsieur
Assouline de la même manière donc
j'aimerais avoir des explications assez
clair parce que sinon c'est vrai qu'on a
un certain nombre liste d'amendements
qu'on a déjà analysé et qui me
paraissent rentrer en tout cas je vous
prévenir la vie du gouvernement sur
l'exception des recevabilité
merci monsieur le Président le
gouvernement sur ces questions-là sont
investissement à la vie de la Commission
et nous faisons confiance aux travaux de
la commission donc favorable alors je
soumets au vote sur l'exception d'y
recevabilité
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
de manifestants devant la main
avis contraire
adopté
nous allons donc passer
à l'examen
de l'amendement numéro
47,62 présenté par Monsieur Savary
madame Doineau les deux rapporteurs
monsieur Savary au nom de la commission
des affaires sociales
qui ensuite d'un sous amendement qui
porte le numéro 47 63
vous l'aviez présenté monsieur Savary
vous voulez le il avait été présenté oui
il a été présenté oui tout à l'heure
chez le président l'amendement a été
présenté tout à l'heure
et par contre il doit y avoir un petit
[Musique]
une rectification
qui doit être faite
concernant
concernant un dispositif
concernant un dispositif pour 5 pierres
et micro pour lequel la commission
[Musique]
pour laquelle la Commission a demandé la
vie du gouvernement donc je demande la
visite du gouvernement sur cet
amendement de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
il serait peut-être bon d'entendre
monsieur Artano monsieur Artano
je suis entre vos mains Monsieur le
Président alors cette insertion de
Saint-Pierre miton dans le texte pose
plusieurs difficultés la première c'est
que le régime de retraite à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon date d'une loi
du 17 juillet 87 qui n'est pas visée
dont l'amendement qui a été proposé donc
il y a un problème déjà de légistique et
de droit sur l'applicabilité du texte à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon la deuxième
chose c'est que j'ai obtenu après moult
insistance un engagement du gouvernement
et du ministère des Outre-mer de ne pas
toucher à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon pour
l'instant sur le recul de l'âge légal
pourquoi parce qu'il y a tout simplement
un dispositif de convergence au niveau
du trimestre et la durée de cotisation
pour Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et je
pense que le gouvernement veut se donner
du temps technique pour travailler avec
les opérateurs locaux et la Caisse de
Prévoyance sociale c'est la raison pour
laquelle effectivement le gouvernement
ne souhaite pas prendre cette décision
maintenant je vais à la disposition du
ministre du socle de l'engagement du
ministère des Outre-mer c'est pas une
lubie de ma part mais effectivement il a
il devrait difficultés juridiques
au-delà du fait que je ne saurais
qu'inviter le ministre à ne pas
persister dans ce recul d'âge légal
puisque je m'y oppose fondamentalement
il y a des problèmes de droit monsieur
le Président alors monsieur le
rapporteur donc je rectifie l'abonnement
conformément à ce qui a été dit par
Monsieur Artano
donc monsieur Artano retire son sous
amendement et de 47 62 devient rectifier
nous sommes d'accord la vie du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
simplement faire une précision pour dire
que
il y a une difficulté particulière sur
Saint-Pierre Miquelon il y en a une
aussi sur Mayotte je connais
l'implication du sénateur de Mayotte
c'est juste en face de moi tany Mohamed
suali et nous avons continué à
travailler pour faire en sorte que les
travaux qui sont les siens puissent
déboucher et aboutir de la manière la
plus favorable pour le système de
retraite pour le reste la vie du
Gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement rectifié
bien alors j'ai
un sous amendement un amendement
toujours 47 62 pardonnez-moi qui était
présenté par Madame pensé Monge ou
monsieur Montard
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
déposer des sous amendements
nous allons procéder au vote
voilà pourquoi alors on a le droit de
déposer j'ai le droit de sous-amender un
amendement
on se voit
première signature madame pont c'est bon
qui porte le numéro 311
[Musique]
il a été distribué
et il remplace la balle de 68 par la
date de 69 non il n'est pas défendu donc
nous allons procéder maintenant nous
avons la vie du gouvernement et nous
allons procéder aux explications de vote
[Applaudissements]
on va aller on va aller
suspends 10 minutes
[Musique]
voilà nouvelle suspension de séance dans
cette nuit agitée que traverse le Sénat
autour de l'examen de l'article 7 vous
savez la mesure d'âge de la réforme des
retraites depuis une heure du matin 1h10
du matin et on voit cette tension très
vive entre la droite et la gauche avec
plusieurs étapes tout au long de cette
nuit tout d'abord la droite sénatoriale
avec Monsieur Retailleau qui a demandé à
ce que l'on enclenche un article du
règlement du Sénat qui vient contraindre
les débats ensuite la majorité de la
droite et du centre qui a déposé un
amendement qui vient réécrire
complètement l'article 7 et qui fait
tomber les amendements de la droite de
la gauche pardon et donc cette gauche
qui est bien dénonce ce qui se joue
depuis dans l'hémicycle pour en parler
on rejoindre mathiasaraez Mathias vous
êtes nos yeux et nos oreilles dans
l'hémicycle on peut le dire de très vif
tension depuis une heure dix du matin et
ça vient encore de passer une nouvelle
étape n'est-ce pas il y a absolument
Quentin depuis le retour ici dans
l'émission on sentait la tension monter
sur les bancs de la de la gauche ici
vous le savez vous l'avez dit la
quasi-totalité des sous amendements qui
avait été déposés par la gauche suite à
la réécriture du texte par la commission
sont tombées ou ont été jugées en tout
cas irrecevables la gauche a donc crier
au scandale à travers la voix de David
Assouline de Laurence Rossignol ou
encore de Pierre Laurent même de
Guillaume Gontard qui interroge sur
pourquoi des amendements qui hier
étaient recevables sont dorénavant
irrecevable donc c'est une colère qui
continue de monter ici dans l'hémicycle
à tel point que lorsque le président
Gérard Larcher a annoncé que l'on allait
passer au vote sur l'amendement qui a
été soumis par la Commission et bien la
gauche a tout simplement décidé de se
lever et de quitter l'hémicycle et merci
Mathias sarez je suis en compagnie de
Patrick Kenner bonsoir Monsieur caner il
est 3h05 du matin vous venez de quitter
l'hémicycle pourquoi
en même temps le président qui a vu cela
a suspendu la séance donc peut-être
qu'il a voulu Broca bien compréhensible
on ne comprend plus rien la procédure
qui a été lancée on évoque des
amendements qui ne sont pas distribués
j'ai le sentiment que le président de
Larcher et Bruno retaillos sont rentrés
dans une machine infernale qui est en
train de les dépasser je n'ai jamais vu
ça au Sénat même les plus anciens
considèrent qu'il y a vraiment un
problème majeur donc voilà vouloir
bâillonner l'opposition c'est prendre un
très grand risque pour l'image du Sénat
je le regrette vraiment y compris pour
son président le point de départ c'est
ce que la Commission a proposé René Paul
Savary qui a déposé une nouvelle
écriture de l'article 7 et café tombé
par cette astuce de procédure qui était
donc calculé depuis longtemps parce que
les amendements étaient écrits donc les
mauvais coups entre guillemets étaient
préparés à l'avance donc voilà voilà où
nous en sommes et donc vous aviez prévu
une réaction vous aviez anticipé ce
qu'elle est faire René Paul Savary vous
aviez préparé là encore des centaines
d'amendements et ils doivent des
milliers oui des milliers ils ont été
jugés ils recevables en une demi-heure
de réunion ça vous paraît inconcevable
qu'on les ait examinés sur le fait ça
veut dire que le travail n'a pas été
fait
donc aujourd'hui
on est devant un coup de force de la
majorité sanatoriale je le regrette
parce que c'était pas comme ça que nous
étions rentrés dans ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire maintenant vous et les
autres groupes de gauche est-ce que vous
comptez quitter ce débat l'abandonner à
la droite sénatale a voté ton article 7
sans aucune opposition de gauche dans
l'hémicycle nous allons en décider
collectivement naturellement puisque
nous sommes à trois à je dirais organisé
notre notre riposte mais l'image encore
une fois donnée ce soir n'est pas la
hauteur de l'enjeu merci je vous libère
et Patrick canard puisqu'on voit
qu'effectivement ces groupes de gauche
qui se réunissent derrière moi en salle
des conférences sans doute allez vous
choisir votre stratégie pour les
prochaines minutes allez-y on va les
rejoindre Mathias sarez en tribune de
presse Mathias allez-y expliquez-nous ce
qui se joue depuis votre passe
d'observation ce que vous voyez vous
bien écoutez en fait ça a commencé au
retour de cette suspension vous le savez
la gauche amer de cette nouvelle 10
recevabilité de la quasi-totalité des
sous-amendements qui avaient été déposés
suite à la réécriture du texte cette
scène elle commence par un discours de
Catherine Deroche qui est la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
qui tentent d'expliquer l'irrecevabilité
de ses sous-amendements sur les bancs de
la gauche c'est l'hilarité car il est
vrai ce discours est assez difficile à
comprendre et c'est donc ensuite des
prises de parole qui se sont enchaînés
de la part des sénateurs de gauche car
il s'agit là d'un débat assez juridique
comme l'a expliqué Laurence Rossignol
c'est natrice de l'Oise je vous propose
de l'écouter
la sénatrice de l'Oise le sonore qui
arrivera très très prochainement je
l'espère qu'il y a donc expliqué qu'il
se s'agissait d'un débat juridique tout
comme la fin également Pierre Laurent ou
encore David Assouline qui interroge sur
pourquoi ces amendements hier était
recevable et aujourd'hui ne le sont plus
on va écouter Laurence Rossignol
s
tout le monde sans doute sur la 44 bis
alinéa 3 puisque ont été déclarés ils
recevables au motif que ces amendements
les sous amendements ne s'appliqueraient
pas effectivement au texte qu'il vise
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary porte
sur le même objet que la que l'article 7
du projet de loi premièrement
deuxièmement nous avons déposé une série
d'amendements qui ont été nous avons
déposé une série d'amendements à
l'article 7 qui avait été déclaré
recevable donc ne portant atteinte né au
principe d'égalité ni étant un
contradictoire à quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui et même les mêmes
amendements devenus sous amendements
positionné comme il le faut à La Linea 3
à 5 c'est-à-dire bien positionné et qui
était recevablir sur le fond deviennent
irrecevables maintenant quand ils sont
sur l'amendement je ne comprends pas
pourquoi d'autant plus que c'est une
interprétation assez extensive de la
contradiction alors qu'il ne s'agit que
de dérogation vous comprendrez bien que
tout ceci doit être clairement précisé
dans le Sénat aujourd'hui j'ai bien
intégré le fait que pour reprendre une
formule célèbre nous avons probablement
juridiquement tort parce que nous sommes
politiquement minoritaires pour pour
autant le Conseil constitutionnel lui
n'est peu sensible aux arguments de
politiquement majoritaire donc c'est la
discussion va être menée au fond sur ce
que la manœuvre de procédure que vous
mettez en place parce que c'est
essentiel dans la constitutionnalité de
l'adoption de cet amendement une
décision qui est vécue de très
difficilement à gauche comme on a pu
l'entendre depuis cette tribune de
presse où je me trouve avec une
sénatrice qui déclarait que et bien
finalement le Sénat perdait un petit peu
de son sens ici ce soir merci Mathias le
Sénat qui perd de son sens selon une
sénatrice de gauche on va poser la
question à Laurence Cohen bonsoir madame
Cohen sénatrice communiste du
Val-de-Marne un mot sur votre stratégie
et la gauche vous venez de quitter
l'hémicycle au même moment et bien le
président l'archet qui a suspend un
nouveau la séance pour la troisième fois
depuis une heure du matin qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire maintenant à gauche
d'abord c'est un coup de force c'est un
coup de force qui vient d'être infligé
à l'aide contre la démocratie et
franchement ça ne valorise pas du tout
le Sénat on était arrivé à l'article 7
il y a des milliers voire
deux millions en plus de 2 millions de
personnes dans la rue très mécontente
qui rejettent toutes et tous de manière
pacifique cette réforme qui est une une
réforme inique et qu'est-ce que fait le
Sénat la majorité du Sénat et bien c'est
de dire finalement maintenant ça suffit
et on va aller au patchage pour voter la
réforme telle qu'on l'a vu et on a bien
vu là la convergence de la droite et je
dirais des droites puisque le
gouvernement laisse complètement faire
parce qu'en fait c'est la même réforme
celle de la droite et celle du
gouvernement donc ce coup de force là on
ne peut pas l'accepter et c'est pour ça
que tous les les groupes de gauche ce
sont levés et sont sortis quand on nous
bâillonne on va pas rester à l'intérieur
de de l'hémicycle pour faire de la
figuration c'est pas notre genre c'est
ça parce qu'en fait on le comprend vaut
1300 amendements sur l'article 7 A
tomber vous en aviez redéposé des sous
amendements pour essayer à nouveau
intervenir avec la nouvelle écriture de
René Paul Savary et ses amendements là
ont été jugés ils recevables et c'est
cette décision que vous jugez
incompréhensible c'est ça ben c'est une
décision incompréhensible parce qu'on a
redéposé 1000 amendements toujours dans
un esprit de continuer le le débat et là
des amendements qui avaient été qui
n'avaient pas été du tout déclaré il
recevable mais quand ils sont
transformés en sous-amendement ils sont
frappés du recevabilité et il y en avait
même certains parmi ceux qu'on avait
déposé au nombre de 400 qui étaient
uniquement pour corriger des erreurs
matérielles ça n'a même pas été pris en
compte donc là on voit bien que la
volonté de la majorité de droite au
Sénat c'est de bâillonner et bien les
voix qui s'élèvent contre cette réforme
parce que c'est une mauvaise réforme
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
maintenant quel est l'étape d'après
est-ce que vous avez mis en place une
stratégie à gauche que vous allez mettre
en place à partir de maintenant bah
écoutez pour demain moment la gauche
elle est unie elle est rassemblée on va
déc ensemble si on quitte définitivement
la séance ou si on rentre à nouveau mais
si c'est rentré pour faire de la
figuration ça sera sans nous mais si
vous quittez la séance ça signifie et
bien un boulevard pour la droite et le
centre pour voter cet article 7 en
quelques heures quelques minutes de
toute façon
par les merci
effectivement Gérard lynché en train de
prendre la parole on l'écoute merci ils
sont tous dans la même veine de ce qui
est avant avec les mêmes les mêmes
contradictions avec le sens de
l'amendement du rapporteur donc pour les
mêmes raisons suscite les mêmes effets
ils sont également ircevables merci nous
passons aux explications de votre santé
madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur le
président
non vous me dites
donc monsieur le Président après le
recours au 47 ans par le gouvernement
pour examiner ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif la commission des affaires
sociales a pris la décision de rejeter
tous les sous amendements que nous avons
déposé et les a examinés à une vitesse
je dois dire éclair sans tenir compte de
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que des sous amendements
ont été donc rejeté alors que les
amendements les mêmes les mêmes qui les
mêmes amendements ont été retenus en
leur temps lors des travaux de la
commission des affaires
sociales donc j'ai une question moi cela
veut simplement dire que le Sénat ne
veut pas débattre de l'article 7 qui est
pourtant
le cœur du texte et le sujet le sujet
d'allongement de l'âge de départ à la
retraite qui préoccupe des millions de
nos concitoyens et de nos concitoyens
comme on l'a vu aujourd'hui dans la rue
et les jours précédents et comme on le
verra encore encore samedi prochain donc
vous refusez le débat démocratique et
sincèrement monsieur le Président je
pense et vous me connaissez je pense que
ça ne dort pas notre institution ça ne
mord pas le Sénat et je veux vous le dis
aussi crûment que ça nous refusons de
participer à cette entomine et nous
quittons l'hémicycle ce soir et nous
reviendrons demain
monsieur le Président Kader
le Président Monsieur le Président mais
monsieur et les ministres
vous sentez que nous sommes dans une
colère froide voilà les événements sont
passés
je regrette ce qui nous arrive
collectivement mes chers collègues je
pense que la droite c'est notoriale est
en train de rentrer dans une machine
infernale qui est en train de la
submerger y compris en termes d'image y
compris en terme d'image ce qu'a dit
notre collègue elle est assassin sur
l'irrostabilité les amendements qui
n'ont même pas été examinés
ils n'ont pas pu être examinés
techniquement mes chers amis c'est
impossible et ils ont été déclarés
irrecevables
peut-être que vous considériez que nous
n'aurions pas de riposte potentiel après
l'utilisation de
l'amendement prioritaire porté par le
rapporteur
mais nous avons le droit de nous
exprimer essayer de défendre nos idées
vous ne voulez pas manifestement et il y
a beaucoup beaucoup
d'imperfections pour ne pas dire
de bricolage dans la gestion de notre
débat de ce soir je le regrette monsieur
le Président vous n'êtes sûrement pour
rien mais le constat il est là et les
membres de mon groupe donc ont décidé de
s'associer à la démarche qui est la
nôtre de vous laisser vous voterez
peut-être l'article 7 cette nuit et bien
nous en rendre compte devant les
Français qui ont défilé aujourd'hui mes
chers collègues nous vous laissons entre
vous
merci monsieur le Président d'abord vous
dire quand même parce que je vois que ça
en fait rire certains parlent de cinéma
moi je trouve quand même que le moment
il est grave il est grave il est lourd
et franchement l'image et je vais le
dire quand même l'image que vous donnez
on a débattu on a des battu on a des
battu
longuement pendant trois jours on est
arrivé à cet article en cet article 7 il
n'y avait aucune raison d'interrompre ce
débat et de vouloir passer en force
comme le vous le faites et puis ensuite
on entrave ce soir notre droit
d'amendement parce que franchement on
dépose des sous amendements c'est
impossible matériellement de pouvoir
faire ce que vous avez fait donc c'est
une entrée à vos droits d'amendement
c'est une entrave au droit parlementaire
à notre travail de parlementaire moi je
suis peiné effectivement que ça se passe
ici et que ça se passe ici au Sénat je
pense qu'on avait donné une bonne image
et que là on donne une image vous donner
une image désastreuse donc avec
l'ensemble des trois groupes
effectivement nous allons quitter
l'assemblée mais je peux vous dire que
les sénatrices et les sénateurs de nos
trois groupes ne le font pas de gaieté
de cœur franchement on avait mieux à
faire ce soir on a bien eu à faire toute
cette semaine pour contexte
effectivement d'importance un texte qui
est attendu avec des gens qui ont défilé
aujourd'hui en nombre que ça vous plaise
ou pas et que cette place au débat elle
était importante donc on va partir et on
le regrette vous ferez ce que vous
voulez cette nuit nous on reviendra
demain et j'espère qu'on pourra revenir
dans des conditions un peu plus sereine
pour pouvoir débattre et travailler
sereinement merci à tourne la Présidente
je voudrais dire quelques mots et
moi-même opposer une question monsieur
kaner vous nous dites qu'on a pas eu le
temps matériel d'examiner c'est sous
amendements nous avions pour vous dire
ce sont les amendements que le
l'amendement du rapporteur ne faite
faisait tomber ces amendements c'est
quand même 600 dérogations par métier
500 qui supprimaient des alinéa on avait
des amendements déposés sur un article
qui comprend 180 linéaires autant que
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
tous les sous amendements que vous
mettez correspondent à vos amendements
vos amendements on les a examinés on les
a tous examinés on leur a donné un avis
défavorable en commission donc quand ils
arrivent c'est pas compliqué même ce
sont les mêmes donc les mêmes qu'on a
examiné donc ne dites pas qu'on avait
pas le temps mais non nous dites pas
qu'on n'avait pas le temps de les
examiner ce sont les mêmes tous les
mêmes sauf quelques-uns qu'on a
regrappié comme ça et d'autres mais les
autres ce sont les mêmes donc ce sont
des amendements examinés en commission
sur lequel on a donné un avis que vous
nous remettez en sous amendement on en
va pas passer la nuit à examiner des
choses qu'on a examinées donc c'est pas
c'est assez clair comme explication moi
ce que je vous dis c'est que nous la
commission elle poursuit deux objectifs
c'est contribuer à la clarté des bas en
les recentrant sur les enjeux du texte
et vous savez très bien et ne faites pas
les vierges va coucher vous savez très
bien que lorsque vous déposez un millier
d'amendements plus d'un millier
d'amendements sur article 7 en faisant
des tas de trucs comme ça vous clarifier
et vous clarifier le débat il reste à
l'issue de l'abonnement du rapporteur
plus d'une centaine d'amendements qui
seront sur le débat de fond sur le débat
de fond et nous l'aurons demain
donc je voulais vous demander si vous
maintenez votre demande de scrutin
public sur cet amendement puisque c'est
vous qui vous aviez déposé donc je le
considère qu'il est déposé j'aurais
profité de votre présence encore dans
votre poussiez la porte il reste 75
amendements sur cet article vous avez
dit souhaité un débat de fond demain la
Commission a souhaité un débat de fond
sur cet article donc nous vous donnerons
rendez-vous pour le débat de fond sur
ces articles demain ce qui me semble et
la sagesse et la réponse du Sénat
j'allais dire amendement éclair sous
amendement et clair et je souhaite que
nous ayons un débat mais que nos
caricaturions pas l'attitude de notre
ensemble
monsieur carochi voulait s'exprimer
explication de vote parce que
je vais mettre on voit l'amendement
c'est pour ça
sur l'amendement et sur la réponse en
réalité je le dis pour l'ensemble de mes
collègues et peut-être pour le Conseil
constitutionnel mais le Conseil le sait
les amendements peuvent être
parfaitement déclarés recevables
lorsqu'ils portent sur un article de loi
parce que et c'est la liberté des
parlementaires heureusement on a le
droit de critiquer un article de le
contredire de le modifier en revanche un
sous amendement des recevable que s'il
va dans le sens de l'amendement parce
que sinon il est en contradiction avec
l'amendement et dans ces conditions il
est irrecevable et autant les
amendements de la gauche étaient
recevables sur l'article autant ils sont
irrecevables sur un amendement
réécrivant l'article parce qu'il ne
correspondent pas au sens de l'amende
merci pour cette pédagogie en
explication de vote
je redemande le gouvernement vous savez
que nous avons rectifié l'amendement
pour intégrer Saint-Pierre et Miquelon
vous restez favorable
oui monsieur le Président le
gouvernement reste favorable et pour
aller un peu plus loin même dans la
précision apportée au sénateur Danny
Mohamed soli nous souhaitons qu'à
l'occasion de la poursuite du débat soit
bien précisé que ce qui sera voté ce
soir pour une application pour s'empire
et Miquelon puis cette voté dans les
mêmes termes avec les mêmes applications
mais pas les mêmes références
légistiques pour le territoire de
Mayotte
bien je vais pratiquer un scrutin public
sur cet abonnement
oui
explication de vote
d'une seule présidente j'avais demandé
la parole pour une explication de vote
pour aller dans le sens de ce que vient
de dire monsieur le ministre la
réécriture de l'article 7 à emporté les
dispositions sur Mayotte ou que ce sont
des dispositions
spécifiques moi je suis favorable à cet
article 7 par contre quand vient de le
préciser monsieur le ministre dans le
cadre de la navette il va falloir
ajuster les dispositions sur Mayotte sur
lesquels l'ensemble des parlementaires
de Lille les députés comme les sénateurs
nous sommes parvenus à un accord global
pour avancer
bien nous terminons sur cette tonalité
d'accord
donc je vais procéder maintenant scrutin
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà c'est un scrutin public qui est en
cours sur l'un des seules amendements
qui restaient après la réunion de la
commission des affaires sociales on va
tout vous expliquer dans un instant mais
donc de ce que l'on comprend le
président Gérard lâcher et qui pourrait
décider de lever la séance après de
forts rebondissements depuis une heure
du matin et la menace est maintenant qui
était entrée en mesure de la gauche qui
quitte l'hémicycle après avoir et bien
subi la perte de centaines voire de
milliers d'amendements dans l'examen de
l'article 7 cette gauche qui dénonçait
le fait et bien d'être bâillonné par la
majorité sénatoriale donc après toutes
ces tensions la séance devrait être
suspendue pour reprendre demain
puisqu'il reste encore une centaine
d'amendements qui aura donc bien un
débat sur l'article 7 mais avec un
nombre bien restreint d'amendement et le
tout dans un contexte de fortes
contestation de ce qui se joue dans
l'hémistique par la gauche sénatoriale
qui dénonce la façon dont la séance a
été présidée
et donc c'est dans ce contexte qu'ils
ont décidé de quitter l'hémicycle on va
y revenir dans un instant avec notre
journaliste qui se trouve en tribune de
presse mais d'abord il y a donc et bien
ce vote autour de ce qui était l'un des
derniers amendements autour de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon qui donc était
une exception qui n'était pas dans la
réécriture de René Paul Savary autour de
cet article 7 mais c'est très
anecdotique et comparé à tout ce qui
s'est passé autour de cette soirée on va
écouter le résultat du scrutin et on en
reparle juste après avec notre
journaliste
246 pour 225 contre 21
l'amendement de la commission est donc
adoptée en conséquence l'ensemble des
amendements à cet article à l'exception
75 d'entre eux qui seront examinés
demain puisque la Commission a souhaité
qu'il y a des pâtes font sur ces
amendements je vais donc lever la séance
prochaine séance Mercredi 8 mars à 15h
nous commencerons par les questions
d'actualité puis nous reprendrons sur
ces amendements la séance est levée
il est 3h26 sur l'antenne de public
c'est nous sommes en direct ensemble
depuis 22h une soirée forte en émotion
ici à la Chambre haute avec et bien une
forte crise entre la droite et la gauche
notoriale avec ce point d'acné ce moment
où la gauche du matériel a décidé de
quitter l'hémicycle pour en parler on va
rejoindre Mathias sarez Mathias c'est le
dénouement de cette forte tension dans
l'hémicycle depuis 1h du matin cette
gauche qui avait donc décidé de quitter
l'hémicycle après avoir eu et bien des
arbitrages défavorables sur ces
amendements c'est bien ça absolument
Quentin c'est un véritable retournement
de situation que nous avons vécu ici
dans cette hémicycle du Sénat la gauche
qui ne digère pas le fait que c'est sous
amendement ait été jugé ircecevable
après la suspension qui a été courte de
10 minutes environ et bien seuls les
trois présidents des groupes de gauche
sont revenus prendre place ici dans
cette hémicycle ils ont pris la parole
tour à tour elean assassin Guill et
encore Patrick à nerf pour expliquer
leurs gestes de quitter cette
hémicycléaire il y en assassy pour le
groupe communiste a ainsi expliqué que
ce geste non n'aurait pas l'institution
du Sénat que son groupe mais également
les autres groupes de gauche à les
quitter l'hémicycle et ne reviendrait
que demain Patrick caner lui a parlé
d'une colère froide a dit que les
amendements n'avaient pas pu être
analysé techniquement que c'était
impossible et qu'il laissait finalement
le gouvernement la majorité sanatoriale
traitée ensemble ce soir Guillaume
Gontard a fermé la marche l'écologiste a
dit que l'image donnée par ce geste
n'était vraiment pas bonne pour cette
institution que cela représentait une
entrave à leur droit d'amendement
pendant quelques minutes seulement
puisque depuis le président Gérard
Lachaise décidé de lever la séance on a
eu droit à un scrutin public ici des
débats qui n'ont pas pu être menés et
qui reprendront demain vous l'avez
entendu à partir de 15 heures Quentin
ouais effectivement on voit c'est forte
tension on va refaire un peu le film le
point de départ c'est lorsque et bien à
1h15 du matin le président du groupe LR
au Sénat Bruno retaillod a annoncé et
bien que il demandait la mise en place
de l'article 38 du Règlement du Sénat
qui vient contraindre elle est débat
dans la foulée et bien on a entendu et
que la Commission souhaitait une
suspension de séance pour réécrire
l'article 7 puisque la Commission
dispose du droit de déposer des
amendements pendant la séance tout comme
le gouvernement d'ailleurs or lorsque et
bien et bien René Paul Savary a déposé
cet amendement cela a fait tomber les
1300 amendements de la gauche là-dessus
la gauche qui avait prévu que il y
aurait cette et bien cet événement en
séance la gauche a redéposé des sous
amendements là il y a une suspension de
45 minutes de la séance pour la réunion
de la commission des affaires sociales
et cette réunion de la commission de
l'affaire sociale et bien à juger que
les milliers d'amendements de la gauche
étaient irrecevables ce qui a provoqué
l'incompréhension de la gauche car ces
amendements étaient des copier-collés
d'amendements prêts qu'ils avaient déjà
déposé par le passé c'est donc sur cette
brouille manifeste que nous nous
séparerons à la gauche c'est la droite
qui est bien sont verticalement opposés
sur ce qui s'est passé en séance
aujourd'hui prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité du Parlement dans la
matinale de rayonnementcini à 7h30 qui
reviendra sur tous les détails de ce qui
s'est joué en séance merci à toutes les
équipes techniques et éditoriales qui
ont permis ce Grand Direct Merci à VOUS
Mathias qui m'avait accompagné depuis
22h dans ce cas restera comme une des
soirées de fortes tensions de l'examen
de la réforme des retraites au